>>> THE PLAYOFFS ARE HERE.
THE PLAYOFFS ARE HERE.
WE ARE ALL EXCITED.
WE ALL GOT OUR BEST BETS.
WE'RE GOING TO GO AROUND THE
HORN.
BRYSON GOT A VERY, VERY
INTERESTING BET.
SAVE HIM FOR LAST.
FIRST, GUYS, I'LL START THIS OFF
EASY.
YOU GUYS SEE THE JERSEY I'M
ROCKING.
Y'ALL KNOW I'M ROCKING 49ers
MONEY LINE.
THAT IS MY FAVORITE BET.
I GOT OTHER BETS, DON'T LAUGH AT
ME, MICHAEL.
I GOT OTHER BETS.
>> OKAY.
>> BUT THAT'S MY FAVORITE ONE,
BRO, THAT'S MY FAVORITE.
SAM?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, IT'S
GREAT TO BE HERE WITH EVERYONE
IN PERSON.
THE STUDIO'S AMAZING.
I AM TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THE
LAY OF THE LAND, DO I STARE AT
THAT CAMERA --
>> RIGHT THERE.
>> RIGHT THERE?
OKAY.
I'M THINKING BIG PICTURE.
I COULD TAKE THE NINERS TO WIN
TODAY.
I'M TAKING THE NINERS TO WIN THE
SUPER BOWL AND I'M GOING TO PUT
MYSELF ON THE PATH FOR THE NEXT
MONTH TO JUST RIDE ALONG WITH
BROCK PURDY AND THE BOYS.
CMC, DEEBO, EVERYONE.
SO I'M JUST SAYING NINERS ON THE
SUPER BOWL, THAT'S THE ONLY
THING ON MY MIND TODAY.
>> CUE ANDERSON TOO, THIS AGREES
WITH YOU.
SEAHAWKS WINNING, NO CAP.
>> OKAY.
>> HEY.
>> NO CAP.
>> HAS ANYONE COMMENTED ON THE
ED SHEERAN HAT?
THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT THING.
>> NO.
>> FAIR.
>> IF ANYONE KNOWS ANYTHING
ABOUT MY PAST, I WAS A WEATHER
BOY AT ONE POINT.
AND IF ANYONE KNOWS ANYTHING
ABOUT THE GAME TODAY, IT COULD
BE A LITTLE CRUMMY.
IT RAINED ALL DAY.
I'M BEING A SQUARE, I'M TAKING
THE UNDER.
THAT'S GOING TO BE MY BIG BET,
42 1/2.
>> MICHAEL RITTER IS ROCKING
WITH THE UNDER IN THE RAIN.
>> IN THE RAIN.
>> IT IS RAINING OUT THERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
>> MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
>> THE WEATHER IS NOT AS BAD AS
WE THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO BE.
>> A MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
>> THOUGHT I HEARD THE -- I
THOUGHT I HEARD THE MAN OF THE
PEOPLE.
>> A MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW, BEST BET,
WHAT'S YOUR RECORD ON THE SHOW?
YOU LOVE TOING BROTHER.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY, RECORD OF
THE SEASON IS 33 AND WE TALKED
ABOUT THE BEST BET RECORD, HATER
AGAIN, LIKE EVERY WEEK.
YEAH.
I THINK THE KING OF THE BEST BET
IS PROBABLY A BETTOR --
>> KING OF THE RAP.
>> KING OF THE RAP, KING OF THE
BEST BET.
>> GOT TO BE EMOJIS IN THE CHAT.
>> DON'T DO THAT, DON'T DO THAT.
BEST BET TODAY, D.K. METCALF
OVER 4 1/2 RECEPTIONS.
I BELIEVE I GOT IT AT MINUS 135
ON DRAFT KINGS.
GENO SMITH WILL BE FORCE FEEDING
HIM ALL DAY LONG BECAUSE THE
SEAHAWKS WILL BE TRAILING AND
THEY NEED TO GET INTO A
PLAYMAKER.
D.K. METCALF OVER 4 1/2
RECEPTIONS.
>> RYAN LIKES D.K. METCALF.
MY EYES KEEP WATERING, I DON'T
KNOW WHY.
>> GETTING EMOTIONAL.
THE 49ers ARE ABOUT TO WIN A BIG
GAME.
>> THEY ARE.
THANK YOU FOR SPEAKING THAT INTO
EXISTENCE.
WE GOT MY BOY LOGAN IN THE BACK.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, WE'RE IN --
>> QUESTIONABLE.
SHOULD WE SKIP HIM?
>> WE SHOULD.
>> NO, NO, PLEASE, PLEASE.
FIRST OF ALL, MOST OF YOU KNOW
ME FORMALLY AS BAGEL AND LOX OR
KING OF THE RAT COLLECTIVE.
RYAN IS LUCKY I'M NOT IN THE
CHAT TODAY, ABSOLUTELY JUST
ABUSE HIM.
BUT --
>> YOU'LL BE THERE.
>> YOU STILL CAN.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> WE'RE ALL HERE.
>> DON'T GET CONFUSED BY THE
SEAHAWKS TARP, I AM A JETS FAN.
BUT I GOT TO RIDE WITH MY BOY
JENO, JETS LEGEND.
WE GAVE UP ON HIM A LITTLE TOO
EARLY.
I HOPE HE'S NOT RIDING BACK
TODAY.
SEAHAWKS POST 9 1/2.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY --
>> THAT'S LIKE -- THAT'S BAD
VIBES.
>> THAT IS TERRIBLE VIBES.
THAT IS TERRIBLE VIBES.
>> BAGEL AND LOX, THAT IS
TERRIBLE VIBES, BUT IT'S OKAY,
WE LOVE YOU STILL.
MY BOY, IF YOU GUYS DON'T KNOW,
MY MAN GOES VIRAL ON TIKTOK
EVERY WEEK, IT SEEMS LIKE.
VINNY MICK, HOW WE DOING BACK
THERE?
>> DOING GOOD.
I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE, HAPPY TO
BE BACK.
BACK FOR ANOTHER WATCH PARTY.
I WILL HAVE TO SAY, LOGAN, LET'S
RIDE.
>> LET'S GO, BABY.
>> I'M ALL OVER SEAHAWKS PLUS
9 1/2.
I THINK THIS IS PLAYING INTO
EXACTLY THE STYLE OF GAME THAT
PETE CARROLL LOVES.
>> HARD TO SEE.
>> THAT'S WHY HERE IN THE BACK.
BOYS IN THE BACK.
>> LISTEN.
YOU KNOW, WE ARE THE BIRDS OF
WAR, WE'RE GOING TO FLY
TOGETHER.
I WILL SAY THAT ELI MITCHELL
OVER 38 1/2 YARDS.
>> I LIKE THAT.
>> I'M LOCKING IN, I REALLY LIKE
THAT.
HE'S BACK, HE'S HEALTHY.
HE'S GOING TO BE A GROUND AND
POUND RUNNING GAME.
YEAH.
LOCKED IN.
>> MY MAN ELI IS BACK.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE RUNNING THE
BALL.
IT'S A LOT OF RAIN OUT THERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE SAVED THE BEST FOR LAST.
MY MAN BRYSON'S BEEN COOKING
THIS FOR I DON'T KNOW HOW LONG.
IT'S PROBABLY BEEN A WEEK OR SO.
TELL THE PEOPLE WHAT YOU'VE
DONE.
TELL IT, GO AHEAD.
>> I SPENT MY ENTIRE WEEK DEEP
IN QUANTITATIVE RESEARCH TO FIND
MY BEST BET THIS WEEK.
AND YOU KNOW, I DON'T BET BIG
VERY OFTEN.
PEOPLE GET IT MISCONSTRUED.
>> I BET LIKE AN IDIOT.
>> I DO NOT BET BIG.
THIS, IN MY OPINION, IS MY
WHOMMER LOCK.
GAME TOTAL WILL BE ODD, MINUS
110, DRAFT KINGS SPORTSBOOK.
THEY'RE GIVING ME A DISCOUNT ON
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE MINUS
130, IN MY OPINION.
QUANTITATIVE RESEARCH, IT TOOK
FOUR OR FIVE MINUTES LOOKING AT
GAME HISTORY.
THE TOTAL IN SEAHAWKS/NINERS
SINCE 1997 HAS FINISHED ODD 74%
OF THE TIME.
THIS YEAR, BOTH GAMES FINISHED
EVEN.
TWO TIMES IN THEIR HISTORY
BEFORE THIS SEASON, THE GAME
TOTAL WAS EVEN.
>> WHAT ARE WE DOING?
WHY ARE WE HAMMERING --
>> YEAH.
>> CORRELATION --
>> YOU CAN TALK ABOUT THIS AS
LONG AS YOU WANT.
>> WE'RE NOT LISTENING.
>> LISTEN, GUESS WHAT HAPPENED
THIRD GAME?
SOMEBODY GUESS.
IT FINISH ODD.
HERE WE ARE IN THE THIRD GAME,
IT'S GOING TO FINISH ODD.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, MAN, AT
THE END OF THE DAY YOU'RE SAYING
FOOTBALL COIN?
THAT'S WHAT I'M DOING HERE.
>> BRYSON.
BRYSON, THE MOST IMPORTANT PART
IS, HOW MUCH MONEY ARE YOU
FLIPPING THAT COIN ON?
>> $1,000.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> A PLEA TO OUR AUDIENCE, DO
NOT TAIL THAT -- IF YOU'RE
PUTTING $5 ON IT, DO NOT DO WHAT
HE JUST DID.
>> IT'S UP TO YOU.
>> AUDIENCE, I'M NOT SELLING --
>> WHAT ARE WE DOING?
>> I'M NOT SELLING ANYONE ON
ANYTHING ELSE.
YOU HEARD ALL THESE LOSERS
GIVING OUT --
>> OH!
>> WOW.
>> OKAY.
>> I TAILED THIS PLAY.
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY, I'M
CONFIDENT.
THAT'S ALL YOU NEED RIGHT HERE.
>> TRUE.
>> I GOT BOTH.
>> YEAH, I DIDN'T LIKE THE VIBES
AT THE END OF ALL THAT.
LET'S GET TO THE PEOPLE.
WE HAVE A PARLAY TO BUILD.
>> LET'S GO!
>> WE HAD FIVE LEGS, FIVE LEGS,
FIVE LEGS, FIVE LEGS?
DON'T LIKE THE ODDS ALREADY.
WE NEED YOUR LOCKS.
GET IN THE CHAT, DROP SOME
LOCKS, LET'S BUILD IT UP.
DYLAN WINN SAID 49ers MINUS 3,
D.K. TOUCHDOWN, DEEBO TOUCHDOWN.
WHICH ONE OF THOSE THREE DO YOU
GUYS LIKE?
>> 49ers MINUS 3.
>> I WAS IN A PUSH FOR 49ers
MONEY LINE TO BE THE FIRST LEG.
I ACTUALLY DON'T HATE --
>> THE MINUS 3.
>> I LIKE IT, YEAH.
>> CAN WE DO MINUS 2 1/2?
>> HERE GO RYAN.
>> NO, GO AHEAD, GO AHEAD.
>> I DON'T WANT TO PUSH.
>> KEEPING IT DOWN.
>> GO AHEAD.
MINUS 2 1/2.
>> 49ers MINUS 2 1/2.
>> WHAT'S THE ODDS?
>> MINUS 380.
>> OH, BEAUTIFUL.
>> FOR A LEG?
THAT'S A LOT FOR A LEG.
I LIKE THAT.
I GOT SEAHAWKS PLUS 11 1/2 AT
MINUS 150.
I LOVE THAT.
>> THE ODDS ARE GREAT TODAY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
DO YOU WANT TO DEFEND YOURSELF
THAT YOU JUST BOUGHT 2 POINTS TO
THE CHAT?
>> THAT'S WHAT I WAS SAYING TO
RITTER, WHEN VINCE AND LOGAN
WERE TALKING ABOUT HOW THEY'RE
ON THE SEAHAWKS, I AM AS WELL
BUT I BOUGHT 2 POINTS TO PLUS
11 1/2.
I CAN SEE THIS GAME BEING 21-10.
>> THAT'S A YIKES, BRO.
>> DISGUSTING BEHAVIOR.
>> IF THEY LOSE BY 11 POINTS,
YOU GUYS WILL NEVER HEAR THE END
OF THIS, I PROMISE.
>> IF THEY LOSE BY 12, YOU JUST
GAVE AWAY EXTRA MONEY.
>> THAT'S A RISK I'M WILLING TO
TAKE.
>> WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THEY LOSE
BY 12 AND THE GAME TOTAL IS ODD?
>> YOU'RE RICH AND HE'S POOR.
>> NO, I TAIL PRICE IT.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> I'M A VIBES GUY.
I'M LIKE YOU, VIBES GUY.
>> SO NINERS, MINUS 2 1/2, FIRST
LEG?
DO WE LIKE THAT, CHAT?
THUMBS UP, THUMBS DOWN?
>> LIKE THAT.
>> NO.
>> WE GOT A --
>> EVEN TOTAL SCORE.
>> JKR --
>> EVEN TOTAL SCORE IN THE CHAT.
SOMEBODY'S COMING AT BRAY SON.
>> NICK BOSA, ONE SACK.
>> I GOT THAT ALREADY.
>> YEAH, A LOT OF COMMENTS ON
THAT.
>> RITTER LOOKS, RITTER'S
LOOKING GOOD.
>> YOU CAN PUT THAT IN IF YOU
WANT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> IT'S LIKE MINUS 2 SOMETHING.
>> MINUS 280.
>> MINUS 280 FOR ONE SACK?
OH, MAN.
>> FOR NINERS?
>> FOR NICK BOSA.
>> OH, OKAY.
>> YOU DON'T LIKE THAT?
>> CAN WE DO --
>> PLAYING ODDS?
>> MINUS 280.
MINUS 130 IF WE PUT THAT IN.
>> I'M GOING TO HAVE TO DO QUICK
RESEARCH ON HIS SACK TOTALS.
>> HE'S THE DEFENSIVE PLAYER OF
THE YEAR.
>> IT IS INSANE HOW GOOD HE IS.
>> LEO PENA, KITTLE TD.
I LIKE KITTLE TD, BUT I DON'T
KNOW IF THE WEATHER.
>> I DON'T WANT TO DO ANY --
>> I REALLY LIKE IT, BUT I DON'T
KNOW WITH THE WEATHER.
>> WE ALREADY HAVE METCALF.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE SAYING
49ers 3-PLUS SACKS.
DO WE LIKE THAT OVER BOSA?
>> WE CAN'T DO TEAM SACKS.
>> GO CHECK THAT.
>> WHAT WAS IT?
>> TEAM SACKS FOR 49ers.
>> I DON'T THINK WE CAN -- WE
MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO PUT THAT.
>> GOT IT, GOT IT.
>> IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE BOSA.
I THINK THAT SAME PERSON
DROPPED --
>> IT DID.
>> QUIET KKR SAID, AIYUK OVER 30
YARDS.
DROPPED A TON OF PLAYS.
I'M NOT GOING TO -- WE'RE NOT
GOING TO TAKE YOUR ENTIRE STATE
GAME PARLAY.
>> SOMEONE TWEETED, WHICH I
AGREE WITH, THE BIGGEST TEST IS
YOUR THOUGHTS ON BRANDON AIYUK.
THAT GUY IS SO -- IT'S THE
CURSE -- THAT GUY IS SO GOOD.
>> HE IS GOOD.
>>.
>> YOU DON'T REALIZE HOW GOOD
AND DYNAMIC HE IS.
AND HOW -- IT'S NOT JUST KITTLE,
McCAFFREY, AND DEEBO, AIYUK IS
ONE OF THE BEST RECEIVERS.
>> PURDY IS MAKING HIM LOOK LIKE
NUMBER ONE.
>> WHAT DOES 30-PLUS YARDS LOOK
LIKE?
>> OVER 29 1/2 YARDS WOULD BE
MINUS 265, BETTER VALUE THAN THE
NICK BOSA 1 PLUS SACK IF WE LIKE
THAT.
>> I'M DOWN WITH THAT.
>> LET'S DO THAT.
SO THAT WOULD BE -- WOULD GET TO
US MINUS 135.
>> I'M SEEING FIELD GOALS.
>> WE'RE MOVING.
135.
WE'RE TRACKING.
>> STRAIGHT AWAY, SEAHAWKS TEAM
TOTAL UNDER -- IT'S AT 15 1/2.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S GOING TO BE A NO.
>> LOW, TOO LOW.
SOMEONE THREW OUT McCAFFREY 60
PLUS?
>> YEAH.
RUSH?
>> YEAH, RUSH.
>> YOU NEVER KNOW WITH THE
RECEPTIONS.
>> CAN'T EVEN GO DOWN THAT LOW.
>> CAN WE DO AN ALL PURPOSE FOR
HIM?
>> I DON'T THINK YOU CAN IN THE
SAME GAME.
THE LOWEST YOU CAN GO McCAFFREY
IS 65 PLUS.
>> WHAT ARE THE ODDS?
>> MINUS 255.
>> IN THE ELEMENTS.
ROOKIE QUARTERBACK.
YOU MENTIONED ROBBY --
>> OH, DON'T TALK ABOUT BROCK
PURDY LIKE THIS NOW.
>> THIS IS MY QUARTERBACK.
>> I KNOW BUT DON'T CALL HIM A
ROOKIE QUARTERBACK, AND WE'RE
GOING TO BE CALLING HIM JOE
MONTANA IN 15 MINUTES.
>> IS HE -- IS HE OR IS HE NOT A
ROOKIE QUARTERBACK?
>> HE LOOKS GREAT, HE DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE A ROOKIE QUARTERBACK.
>> IS HE OR IS HE NOT A ROOKIE
QUARTERBACK?
>> HE IS A ROOKIE QUARTERBACK.
>> THANK YOU.
ROOKIE QUARTERBACK, THE
ELEMENTS, DIVISIONAL RIVAL,
ROBBIE GOULD --
>> ARE THERE GOING TO BE LESS
FIELD GOALS BECAUSE IT'S WINDY?
THAT'S MY ONLY CONCERN.
>> FAIR.
THAT'S FAIR.
>> GOOD POINT.
>> YEAH.
>> WHAT'S THE LATEST FROM THE
WEATHERMAN?
>> ROBBY --
>> IT'S GOING TO BE ON AND OFF
ALL DAY.
THE RADAR PULLED UP ALL DAY.
>> A LITTLE RAID DARE.
>> SANTA CLARA, SOUTH BAY.
YEAH.
>> WE'RE GOING TO BE DEALING
WITH RAIN JUST ABOUT ALL DAY
PRETTY MUCH, ON AND OFF.
>> WHAT ABOUT THIS ONE, TYLER
LOCKETT, 45 RECEIVING, A FEW
DEEP BALLS.
IT RAINS IN SEATTLE EVERY DAY.
THAT WAS JIMMY SCHULTZ.
LEO SAID, LOCKETT IS GENO'S
FAVORITE TARGET.
>> YEAH, THERE IS A LOT OF
LOCKETT.
>> LET'S THINK ABOUT THIS.
WE KNOW WARD'S GOING TO BE ON
D.K.
>> YEP.
>> THE OTHER CORNER AT THE
49ers, LENYARE, 38, HE'S NOT
THAT GOOD.
>> I WILL SAY THIS, NINERS
DEFENSE, OBVIOUSLY BEST IN THE
LEAGUE, THE ONLY PLACE THEY ARE
WEAK IS THE DEEP BALL.
>> YES.
>> AND IF, YOU KNOW -- IF IT'S
ONLY 50 YARDS, IT TAKES ONE
TYLER LOCKETT DEEP BALL TO
POTENTIALLY CATCH THIS.
>> CALL ME CRAZY.
DO WE LOCKETT 45 PLUS BETTER OR
LOCKETT 4 PLUS RECEPTIONS
BETTER?
>> OOH, THAT'S TOUGH.
>> GREAT QUESTION, SHOUT-OUT ME,
GREAT QUESTION.
>> THE AUDIENCE ARE ALSO --
>> SOMETHING AS WELL --.
THE AUDIENCE SAYS, REAL QUICK,
LOCKETT SCORES TOUCHDOWNS.
WE'VE ALREADY SAID NO.
>> NO TOUCHDOWNS.
>> OH, MAN.
THAT'S BAD VIBES.
THEY GOT COOKED IN BASKETBALL
TODAY.
I DON'T LIKE --
>> I HEAR YOU.
>> GREG LETS ME KNOW THIS EVERY
WEEK.
THE PARLAY IS NOT ABOUT YOU.
>> OKAY.
THAT'S TRUE.
>> IT'S NOT ABOUT YOU.
>> HEY, LET THEM KNOW, RIGHT?
LET THEM KNOW.
>> WE'VE GOT TO GET THE NEXT
LEG.
>> YOU'RE LEAVING ME HANGING?
>> WHILE YOU'RE AT IT, PUT GAME
TOTAL.
WE'VE GOT TO GET THE NEXT LEG.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> WE HAVE TO GET THAT -- YEAH,
WE DON'T HAVE MUCH TIME.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE SAYING YARDS.
>> I LIKE YARDS MORE.
>> YARDS, YARDS.
>> THAT'S THREE LEGS.
>> OH, PLUS 150?
>> STOP IT.
>> HERE WE ARE.
>> DON'T TEMPT ME.
>> WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE?
>> LEO PENA, 45 PLUS TOO.
>> SHOUT-OUT YOU.
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
>> WE NEVER TOUCHED McCAFFREY?
>> WE DIDN'T.
>> ALREADY LEVERAGED.
>> DILLON WIN?
>> THAT GUY'S VERY GOOD AT
PLAYING FOOTBALL.
>> KENNETH WALKER, 50 PLUS
RUSHING YARDS?
>> WALKER'S INTERESTING.
>> GREAT RUSHING DEFENSE.
>> YEAH, IT'S TRUE.
THAT DEFENSE IS NICE.
>> DOES THAT FALL INTO THE
QUANTITATIVE RESEARCH?
>> HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
GAME TOTAL.
>> SO IT DIDN'T.
COULDN'T BE BOTHERED.
>> KENNETH WALKER RUSH YARDS IS
THE GAME SCRIPT I'M PROJECTING,
NINERS GO UP BIG, SEAHAWKS NEED
TO THROW.
THAT'S WHY I'M COOL WITH
LOCKETT.
>> BUT LOSE BY 11.
>> IS THE GAME TOTAL ODD?
>> YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
>> SOMEBODY SAID -- I'M JUST
BRINGING THIS UP BECAUSE I'M
LOOKING AT CHAT.
SOMEBODY SAID BROCK PURDY OVER
6 1/2 RUSHING YARDS.
>> OOH.
>> I SAW THAT TOO, I DON'T KNOW
WHO DROPPED THAT.
>> IN TERMS OF WHAT HE'S DONE
RECENTLY?
>> IT'S THE PLAYOFFS.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE
PLAYS.
>> HE'S GOING TO SCRAMBLE.
>> 6 PLUS RUSHING YARDS IS MINUS
200.
>> I'M PULLING UP STATS.
>> YES.
6 PLUS, YEAH.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S SEE.
>> WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON THAT?
>> I LOVE IT.
>> MOST RECENT GAMES, 7 YARDS,
MINUS 3.
SIX YARDS, MINUS 2.
3 YARDS, MINUS 1.
>> THAT'S GOING TO BE A PASS FOR
ME.
>> IT'S THE PLAYOFFS, THOUGH,
IT'S DIFFERENT.
>> I KNOW.
DIFFERENT PLAYBOOK.
>> THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE
PLAYS.
>> WHAT YOU GOT?
>> I LIKE GENO SMITH PASSING
ATTEMPTS OVER.
>> THAT I DO LIKE, YEAH.
>> WHAT'S THE NUMBER?
>> 32.
>> GENO SMITH PASSING ATTEMPTS.
>> DID YOU GET THAT FROM THE
CHAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHERE MY PHONE'S
AT, BRO.
>> I THINK WE SHOULD MAKE
McCAFFREY.
>> FOR RUSHING YARDS?
>> WHATEVER HIS LOWEST RUSHING
YARD IS -- JUST A NICE LEG, MAN.
>> WE DID DROP A 64 TO GET SOME
LEGS.
I WILL GIVE YOU CREDIT.
BUCKETS ON TWITTER.
>> BRIAN BUCKETS SAID IT ON
TWITTER.
>> YOU WOULD KNOW ABOUT TWITTER.
>> I ALSO -- I THINK McCAFFREY
SHOULD BE IN THERE, BUT I DON'T
WANT TO BE THE ONE TO SAY WE
HAVE TO DO IT, THEN IT LOSES,
THEN EVERYONE IS GOING TO BE
MEAN TO ME.
>> YEAH, THAT'S TRUE.
>> YOU DON'T WANT TO BE THAT
GUY.
>> DA ONIONS ASKED IF WE CAN
AVENGE JORDAN MASON.
>> DUDE.
>> PLAYOFFS?
>> PLAYOFFS.
>> HE SCORED.
>> HE DID SCORE.
>> IN MY MINE, HE SCORED.
>> IT WILL ALSO BE --
>> WHAT ARE DEEBO'S STATS?
>> INTERESTING PROPS.
HE HAS AN INTERESTING RUSHING
PROP.
>> SUPER LOW, LIKE 16 1/2.
>> SUPER LOW, 15 1/2, I BELIEVE.
YOU'RE GOING TO LOOK IT UP?
>> IF WE TAKE HIS RUSHING OVER,
WE'RE GOING TO GET SCREWED.
BROCK PURDY IS GOING TO LET GO
OF IT A LITTLE BIT, THEY'LL CALL
IT A RECEPTION, HE'S GOING TO
RUN FOR 40 YARDS.
>> LOWEST YOU CAN GO WITH GENO
IS 10.
>> McCAFFREY, 65 PLUS, I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO
DO?
WE DEFINITELY NEED TWO MORE
LEGS.
I THINK WE SHOULD ADD SOMETHING
THAT'S PLUS MONEY THAT YOU SET
UP.
>> HERE GOES RYAN.
>> GENO SMITH PASSING ATTEMPTS.
>> HERE GOES RYAN TRYING TO
JUICE UP THE PARLAY.
>> WE CAN'T HAVE A FIVE-LEG
PARLAY.
>> WHAT IS McCAFFREY'S RECEIVING
PROP?
WHAT'S HIS LOWEST RECEIVING
TOTAL?
>> 19 1/2?
>> THERE HE IS.
BLOCK 13, BABY.
>> SOMEBODY SAID DEEBO 30 1/2 IS
CRAZY.
>> THE LOWEST YOU CAN GO IS
19 1/2, MINUS 500.
>> WHAT'S DEEBO'S RECEIVING
PROPS?
>> THAT'S NOT A BAD LEG.
INSTEAD OF THE RUSHING TOTALS?
>> OR WE COULD DO McCAFFREY
RECEPTIONS.
>> McCAFFREY RECEPTIONS, OVER
3 1/2, THAT'S A --
>> OH.
>> THAT'S THE LEGTY LEGTY.
>> WHAT'S THE NUMBER THERE?
>> I WOULD DO McCAFFREY
RECEPTIONS.
>> WHAT IS IT?
>> MINUS 650.
>> FOR THREE PLUS?
>> YEAH.
THIS COULD BE THE PLUS MONEY
ONE.
I'LL BE HONEST, I LIKE 5 PLUS.
I LIKE 6 PLUS.
>> HERE'S O'BRIEN.
>> 5 IS -- YEAH.
>> WHAT IS 5?
>> WHAT WOULD 5 DO?
>> 525?
>> THAT'S PRETTY GOOD.
READ IT OUT LOUD.
WE'LL GET TO THE CHAT.
>> OKAY, WELL -- WAIT.
I ACTUALLY KNOW.
WE HAVE 11 MINUTES.
SHOULD WE BE DOING McCAFFREY
RECEPTIONS WHILE WE ALSO HAVE
McCAFFREY RUSHING YARDS?
DO WE NEED TO FIGURE THAT OUT?
>> TAKE OUT --
>> IN THE CHAT, BYE-BYE STRICK,
GENO SMITH PASS ATTEMPTS OVER.
>> NO, YOU HAVE --
>> I'VE A FAN --
>> YOU DO HAVE A FAN.
>> SHOUT-OUT MY BOY, BAT HALF
BOY.
>> HE'S A LEGEND.
COMMUNITY LEGEND.
>> THEN WHATEVER BULL BRYSON
WANTS.
>> GENO, PASSING ATTEMPTS, I
LIKE THAT.
SEE WHAT THAT DOES.
>> LOOK AT THAT.
>> YOU CAN PROBABLY GET GENO 30
PLUS.
1,000% ULTRA MAXWELL HAMMER
HAPPY.
>> IT'S A --
>> SOME MIGHT SAY THERE'S A 0%
CHANCE THAT DOESN'T OCCUR.
>> OKAY, OKAY, OKAY, OKAY.
>> 30?
>> TAKING OUT McCAFFREY RUSHING
YARDS.
>> TAKE OUT THE RUSHING YARDS.
>> FOUR RECEPTIONS.
>> WHAT IS THAT, 500?
>> 5 PUTS US AT PLUS 500?
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S GOOD.
>> 525, 500 --
>>ER THAT MAKING IT --
>> 10 MINUTES.
>> ASK THE CHAT.
READ IT OUT LOUD, ASK THE CHAT.
>> GO FOR IT.
>> JUST GO.
>> LAST SHOW HE SAID PARLAY
SHOULD BE PLUS 500.
IT'S AT PLUS 500, NOW HE DOESN'T
WANT IT?
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> OKAY.
>> WE'RE 10 MINUTES BEFORE THE
GAME STARTS AND THE VIBE'S
ALREADY WAY OFF.
I NEED THE CHAT THUMBS UP OR
THUMBS DOWN ON THIS PARLAY.
RIGHT NOW IT IS SAN FRANCISCO
49ers MINUS 2 1/2.
BRANDON AIYUK OVER 29 1/2
RECEIVING YARDS.
TYLER LOCKETT 45 PLUS RECEIVING
YARDS.
CHRISTIAN McCAFFREY FIVE PLUS
RESUGGESTIONS.
GENO SMITH 30 PLUS PASSING
ATTEMPTS.
THE ONLY THING I WOULD CONSIDER
IS TEASING DOWN McCAFFREY
RECEPTIONS.
>> HERE WE GO.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> THE ONLY THING I WOULD
RECOMMEND IS TOTALLY CHANGING
EVERYTHING.
>> YOU SAID THAT.
>> I WANTED THAT?
>> HE SAID IT TWO MINUTES AGO.
>> IT'S AT 5.
>> YES, YES.
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT.
>> YOU SAID 4.
>> YOU'RE TRYING TO TAINT ME.
>> WE HAD 4.
>> WE LOVE --
>> YOU'RE TELLING ME YOU GUYS
DIDN'T LISTEN.
>> NO, YOU DIDN'T LISTEN.
>> YEAH, YEAH, OKAY.
>> NO, YOU'RE TRYING TO SWITCH
IT UP OVER THERE.
I'M TRYING TO GET TO --
>> THAT'S GOING TO GET US
DOWN --
>> YOU'RE TRYING TO GET US TO
GET RICH.
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET RICH.
>> TRYING TO WIN.
>> I WANT TO GET RICH TOO BUT I
WANT TO WIN BEFORE I GET RICH.
>> NO, NO.
WE'VE GOT BAT HATE BOY 99 WITH A
BUNCH OF THUMBS UP TO MY
ORIGINAL QUESTION ON THIS.
>> WHAT WAS THE ORIGINAL
QUESTION?
>> HOW DO YOU KNOW IT'S TO YOUR
ORIGINAL QUESTION?
>> THE MIGHT HAVE PLUS.
>> YOU WANT TO DO 5 PLUS?
>> LOOK AT THIS, PLUS 360 IF WE
TEASE IT DOWN TO 4.
>> PRETTY LOW.
>> I WOULD DO -- OKAY.
HOW ABOUT THIS.
IF WE'RE COOL WITH 30 PLUS FOR
GINO, WHAT IF WE BUMP UP TYLER
LOCKETT TO THE NEXT --
>> I ALWAYS WANT TO BUMP DOWN, I
NEVER WANT TO --
>> I WANT TO WIN.
TRYING TO WIN, BRO.
>> WE'VE GOT TO MAKE A DECISION.
>> NINERS PLUS 9 1/2.
>> OKAY, STOP.
>> THAT'S A LOT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE NEED TO HURRY UP.
>> WE NEED TO.
>> WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A POLL
RIGHT NOW.
RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU WANT FOUR
RECEPTIONS.
>> THAT'S THE ROOM.
>> RIGHT, RIGHT.
>> 49ers MINUS 2 1/2, OVER
29 1/2 RECEIVING YARDS FOR
BRANDON AIYUK, 45 PLUS RECEIVING
YARDS FOR LOCKETT, 30 PASSING
ATTEMPTS FOR GENO SMITH, FOUR
PLUS PASSING RECEPTIONS.
>> EASIEST LEG.
>> LOCK IT IN.
>> LET'S GO.
>> FEELING GOOD, BABY.
>> NINERS, BABY.
>> GAME TOTAL ON!
GAME TOTAL ODD!
>> ARE WE FEELING GOOD ABOUT OUR
PARLAY?
CAN WE GET THE VIBES TRENDING
THIS WAY THIS.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> I FEEL GOOD.
>> WE ALL HAVE TO COME TOGETHER
AFTER YELLING AT EACH OTHER.
NOW ON THE SAME SIDE.
>> I HAVE ONE MORE THING TO
BRING UP.
>> OH, HERE WE GO.
>> OFFENSIVE FIRST DRIVE.
>> I LIKE THAT.
>> SCORE OR NO SCORE?
>> NO SCORE.
>> I GOT PUNT.
>> I MEAN, JUST DEPENDS WHO GETS
THE BALL.
>> NINERS ARE GOING TO SCORE.
I'M THINKING THE SAME THING.
>> THAT'S ONE OF MY BETS.
>> WHAT'S YOUR --
>> GOT 45 BUCKS FOR ME?
>> DOES EVERYONE KNOW, LIKE --
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE SIX --
>> I HAVE $25 FOR YOU.
>> READ THE PARLAY ONE MORE TIME
FOR THE PEOPLE.
>> WE'RE GOING TO HAVE IT IN THE
APP BELOW THE LIVESTREAM.
>> READ IT ONE MORE TIME.
WE'RE GOING TO BE FIVE MINUTES
TO TAILOR THIS BET.
>> 49ers MINUS 2 1/2.
OVER 29 1/2 RECEIVING YARDS FOR
AIYUK.
45 PLUS RECEIVING YARDS FOR LOCK
QUET.
THE BRYSON LEG 30 PLUS.
GENO SMITH PASSING --
>> LOCKED IN.
>> I'M TRYING TO LOCK IT IN.
>> HOLD ON.
I'VE GOT TO GET IT IN.
YOU'RE NOT LISTENING.
WE'VE GOT TO GO AROUND THE HORN.
NO SCORE FIRST DRIVE?
IF WE THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
SCORE OR NO SCORE?
>> I'M GOING FIRST.
I'M GOING TO GO SCORE.
>> I'M SAYING NO.
>> NO SCORE?
>> NO.
>> NO SCORE.
>> RYAN?
>> PICK SIX.
>> I THOUGHT I WAS GOING TO GO
CONTRARIAN.
>> HE'S FLUSTERED.
>> I'M TRYING TO GET THIS IN.
>> TRYING TO GET THE PARLAY,
WHICH I RESPECT.
>> YEAH.
>> RYAN IS TRYING TO BET, AND
WHILE RYAN'S BET -- EVERYBODY
HERE PUT IN SOME INDIVIDUAL
PLAYS FOR THIS GAME.
EVERYBODY IN HERE --
>> OUR PRODUCER WANTS --
>> SPREAD IT AROUND.
>> PRODUCER MAX IN MY EAR ASKING
ME FOR ME TO PUT MONEY ON THIS
FOR HIM.
I DON'T HAVE THAT MUCH MONEY IN
MY DRAFT KINGS ACCOUNT.
>> RIGHT.
>> THE SPREADSHEET, WE CAN SEE
WHAT WE ARE ALL BETTING.
>> YES.
>> LET'S GO TO THE SPREAD SHEET.
>> THAT'S THE SPREADSHEET.
THESE ARE OUR BETS FOR TODAY.
YOU GUYS, TAKE A LOOK AT IT,
TAKE A GANDER, TAKE A HARTIGAN
DER.
TAKE A LOOK AT IT.
ANYBODY GOT SOMETHING THEY WANT
TO MENTION?
ANYBODY?
ANYBODY GOT SOMETHING THEY WANT
TO MENTION?
>> YEAH.
>> TO THE AUDIENCE?
>> YOU JUST ASKED ABOUT IT,
GREG.
I GOT FIRST DRIVERS PUNT AS ONE
OF MY FIVE PICKS ON THIS GAME,
MINUS 130.
IN THE MONSOON.
>> IN THE MONSOON?
I LIKE THAT.
>> ABSOLUTE IMPROV PLAYER, CAN
EVERYONE PICK, BESIDES
THEMSELVES, WHO THEY THINK IS
GOING TO HAVE THE BEST RECORD?
BESIDES YOURSELF, WHO'S GOING TO
HAVE THE BEST WINNING PERCENTAGE
UP ON THE BOARD?
>> THAT'S A GREAT, GREAT,
GREAT --
>> I'LL SAY LOGAN.
>> NICE.
>> I LIKE LOGAN'S PLAYS.
>> I WANT -- BEFORE THE GAME
STARTS, RITTER SPREAD SOME
NINERS 31-10 --
>> I LIKE SAM'S.
>> THE 31-10 THING --
>> LET'S GO!
>> I'VE BEEN WORKING IN OUR DMs
FOR TWO PLUS YEARS NOW, SEEING
ALL YOU GUYS HIT THESE.
I WANT TO JOIN IN THE FUN.
I REALLY LIKE THE NINERS TODAY.
I THINK THEY WIN.
I THINK IT STAYS UNDER.
THAT SCORE IS BELOW THAT TOTAL.
AND I THINK 31-10.
I THINK IT'S A NICE --
>> 65-1?
>> 65-1.
AND IT'S ODD.
>> EXACT SCORE, 31-10, NINERS
VICTORY, 65-1.
>> 65-1.
YEAH, THAT'S ONE OF THE --
>> REVISIT THIS WHEN THAT'S THE
FINAL SCORE.
>> WE HAVE YET TO MENTION
CHRISTIAN McCAFFREY, ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN.
>> ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN.
>> SUPER BOOST.
>> PUT THAT OUT THERE TODAY.
>> SUPER BOOST!
>> WE DEFINITELY BOOSTED THE
CHRISTIAN McCAFFREY.
>> THAT'S A REALLY GOOD BOOST.
>> THAT'S AN AMAZING BOOST.
>> I HAVE GOOD NEWS FOR
EVERYONE.
>> OH?
>> I USED THE DK BOOST AND I GOT
OUR PARLAY TO PLUS 460.
>> WHAT?
>> HEY!
>> REDEEMED HIMSELF.
>> FOR PRODUCER MAX AND BRYSON,
I GOT YOUR BET IN TOO.
>> RYAN GETS --
>> I DIDN'T USE THE BOOST FOR
YOU.
>> GET SOME FOR ME IN THERE,
TOO.
GET SOME FOR ME IN THERE.
I'LL TAKE SOME TOO.
>> TAKE SOME --
>> OF THE PARLAY.
>> OH.
>> DID YOU NOT DO IT?
>> YOU SEE OUR PARLAY RIGHT
THERE.
>>> WHATEVER YOU PUT ON IT FOR
ME.
>> OH.
>> I'M GOING TO GO READ SOME
COMMENTS.
LET'S GRADE SOME OF THESE
>> I CAN'T USE THE BOOST TWICE.
>> DON'T USE THE BOOST.
>> OKAY.
>> I'M GOING TO WIN 100 BUCKS,
THEN?
>> I DIDN'T USE THE BOOST.
>> I CAN ONLY USE THE BOOST FOR
ME.
THERE WAS A BACK WAGER
ASSOCIATED --
>> I GET THAT.
I WANT TO KNOW HOW MUCH I'M
GOING TO WIN, SO I KNOW HOW MUCH
TO FREAK OUT --
>> SCREEN SHOT, YOU ASKED FOR
25.
YOU'RE WINNING 115.
>> DUDE, LET'S GO.
>> OKAY.
>> I COULDN'T USE THE BOOST FOR
YOU!
I'M WINNING 115.
>> RYAN GETS A LOT OF FLACK BUT
HE'S WINNING RIGHT NOW.
>> I'M JUGGLING.
>> SANTA CLARA, CALIFORNIA,
WHERE THE GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE IS,
THE WORLD-FAMOUS GOLDEN GATE
BRIDGE.
>> I TOOK A WEATHER CLASS IN
COLLEGE.
YOU CAN'T PREDICT WEATHER MORE
THAN THREE DAYS OUT.
I'M CURIOUS, 59%, 79% HUMIDITY,
HOW'S THAT GOING TO IMPACT THE
GAME?
>> USUALLY THE MORE HUMID IT IS,
THE BETTER THE BALL FLIES.
>> WHO DO WE TALK TO ABOUT BEING
ABLE TO HEAR THE GAME AUDIO?
>> WE CAN DO THE COMMENTARY.
>> A SIDE BET --
>> WHO IS COMMENTING ON THE
GAME?
>> JOE DAVIS AND DARRELL MOUST.
>> DR. 87 SAYS, IF SEAHAWKS WIN,
I'M ON THE SHOW NEXT WEEK,
INVITE THE DOCTOR.
>> SOUNDS GOOD.
I AGREE.
>> THE DOCTOR WILL NOT BE ON THE
SHOW NEXT WEEK, I'M SO SORRY.
>> I FEEL GOOD ABOUT THE PARLAY.
>> ALSO --
>> I'M SUPER HAPPY BECAUSE I GOT
IT BOOSTED TO SOMETHING --
>> WHERE DID RITTER GO?
>> WE'VE GOT YOUR CHALK.
>> DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING, JUST
WALKED OUT.
>> NICE.
>> HE JUST LEFT.
>> SAM, TELL ME THAT -- I FEEL
SO GOOD ABOUT THAT.
>> I HAD THAT.
>> SEE?
>> 9 1/2.
>> YEAH, I FEEL GREAT.
>> I FEEL BETTER ABOUT PLUS
11 1/2, I WON'T LIE.
>> I FEEL GREAT WE DIDN'T HAVE
TO BUY TWO ADDITIONAL POINTS.
>> EVERYONE KNOWS, THIS IS THE
SEAHAWKS SORT OF BETTING RING.
>> DEFINITELY RIGHT HERE.
>> THERE'S A LITTLE PARTITION.
>> NINERS RIGHT THERE.
>> I'M ALL IN.
>> GAME TOTAL ODD OVER THERE.
>> WE'RE GOOD.
WE ARE LOCKED AND LOADED.
I'M FEELING GOOD.
>> I NEED SOME WATER.
>> FEELING GOOD ON OUR BETS --
ABOUT MY BETS.
MY BETS.
>> WAIT, I WAS TOO BUSY PLACING
BETS FOR HALF THE OFFICE HERE.
WHAT DID WE DECIDE ON WHO IS
GOING TO HAVE THE BEST RECORD?
>> ME.
>> ONLY RITTER KNOWS.
>> IT'S UP 30.
I'M GOING TO HAVE THE BEST
RECORD, I HAVE ONE BET THAT'S
GOING TO WIN.
>> I REALLY LIKE SAM'S PLAY.
>> DID ANYONE NOT SAY
THEMSELVES?
I COMPLETELY BLACKED OUT DURING
THAT CONVERSATION.
>> I DIDN'T VOTE.
>> YEAH, I DIDN'T CAST A VOTE
EITHER.
>> LET ME PULL UP THE
SPREADSHEET, I'LL GIVE YOU AN
ANSWER.
>> OKAY.
>> DYLAN, TELL RITTER TO UNCROSS
HIS LEGS OR THIS BET'S GOING TO
LOSE.
>> OH, MAN.
>> UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> I'LL NEVER BE ON THE SIDE --
>> CAN YOU ZOOM IN, SHOW OFF MY
CALVES?
>> I'M LUCKY MY SHOES ARE STILL
ON.
>> COMMUNITY LEGEND PLACED ON
PARLAY.
>> LET'S GO.
>> GOOD JIBES, GOOD VIBES.
>> I LOVE THAT.
>> THE CALM BEFORE THE STORM.
>> AFTER THIS BET I'M GOING TO
BUY A LA-Z-BOY RECLINER FOR NEXT
TIME I'M WATCHING.
>> YOU A RECLINER GUY?
>> PLAYOFF TIME.
>> I LIKE IT.
>> SO HOT.
>> MY LIFE IS ON THE LINE.
>> WHEN YOU'RE SWEATING BETS YOU
HAVE TO STAND UP?
I STAND BEHIND THE COUCH.
>> YEAH, I DEFINITELY -- AT THE
END, YES, 100%.
>> ANYBODY WANT TO BET ON WHO'S
GETTING THE BALL FIRST?
>> COME ON.
>> COIN BLIP?
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO BET ON
EVERYTHING, GUYS.
>> JUST AS GOOD AS YOUR BETS.
>> LET'S GO AROUND THE HORN.
>> YEAH.
>> EVERYONE'S SUPER BOWL PICK.
>> OH!
>> GREG FIRST.
>> NINERS/CHIEFS.
49ers WIN.
>> NINERS/BILLS, NINERS BIN.
>> NINERS/BENGALS, NINERS WIN.
>> BENGALS ARE LOSING TOMORROW.
>> WE CANNOT BACK THAT.
>> COWBOYS/BENGALS, COWBOYS WIN.
NO BIAS, NO BIAS.
>> CHIEFS/COWBOYS, CHIEFS WIN.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> CHIEFS/COWBOYS?
>> I MEAN --
>> YOUR SCENARIO, MY HEART IS
BROKEN.
>> CHIEFS SUPER BOWL, LAST LEG
OF MY FUTURES PARLAY.
>> THAT'S TRUE, YOU HAVE A NICE
FUTURES PARLAY.
>> YEAH, I THINK --
>> ALSO, I NEEDED WATER.
IT SHOWED UP.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO BE IN THE
BATHROOM IN THE SECOND QUARTER.
>> MY SUPER BOWL PICK,
CHIEFS/NINERS, CHIEFS WIN, BROCK
PURDY HAS THE BALL, 13 SECONDS
LEFT, OVERTHROWS A WIDE-OPEN
RECEIVER DOWN THE FIELD.
>> HAS THAT EVER HAPPENED
BEFORE?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S EVER
HAPPENED BEFORE.
IT WOULD BE PRETTY BAD IF IT
WOULD.
>> GAME'S ABOUT TO START, BABY.
>> LET'S GO.
>> IN MY VIEW, RIGHTFULLY SO,
EVERYONE'S OUT ON THE EAGLES.
>> LET'S GO.
>> FIRST DRIVE PUNT.
>> FIRST DRIVE PUNT, YEAH.
>> LOGAN LIKES SEAHAWKS HAVING
THE BALL FIRST FOR THE FIRST
DRIVE PUNT.
>> I SAID SCORE, DANG, I REGRET
THAT NOW.
IT'S A TOUGH BET.
>> IT IS A TOUGH BET.
>> LET'S GO, BOBBY.
>> DROPPING F-BOMBS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE SHOW, JESUS.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, WE'RE OUT.
>> WE HAVE TO BLEEP -- WE HAVE A
BLEEPER.
>> THAT'S A GOOD KICK.
>> HEY, HEY!
>> YOU KNOW WHO MADE THAT
TACKLE?
>> WHO MADE IT?
>> YOU KNOW WHO MADE THAT
TACKLE?
JORDAN MASON.
>> TEAM LEGEND.
>> JORDAN MASON.
>> FRIEND OF THE SHOW.
>> RESOFFERS IN THE END ZONE --
>> I'M A LITTLE CHILLED.
>> YOU NEED TO BE COLD, BROTHER.
>> ALL RIGHT, PLAY ACTION, PLAY
ACTION, PLEASE.
>> HERE WE GO.
GENO SMITH THREW FARE OVER 4,000
YARDS, 30 TOUCHDOWNS THIS YEAR,
WOW.
11 PICKS.
>> HE HAD A GREAT YEAR.
>> IT'S ALL OVER.
IT'S ALL OVER.
>> IS THAT.
>> THE BALL SHOULDN'T WENT TO
D.K. OVER THERE.
>> DROP THE SCREEN SHOT OF THE
PARLAY.
>> OH, YEAH, YEAH.
>> BROCK HASN'T SEEN THE FIELD
YET.
>> ABSOLUTE DISASTER START.
>> IT'S OVER.
>> WE'RE COVERING.
>> HERE COMES A LITTLE PLAY
ACTION.
>> NOT ON SECOND AND 1.
>> PLAY ACTION, 100%, LET'S GO.
NEVER MIND.
>> YOU SEE THAT, YOU SEE THAT,
YOU SEE THAT?
>> THAT'S PRESSURE.
>> LET'S GO, LET'S GO!
>> I'M IN ONE OF THOSE POSITIONS
WHERE I BET JUST ABOUT
EVERYTHING.
>> IN ALL SERIOUSNESS --
>> THE CURSE.
>> IS THAT FROWNED UPON?
>> YEAH, LET'S GO!
DEEBO.
>> PUT A CURSE ON ME?
>> WE'RE ALL HAVING REAL MONEY
ON THE SPORTS GAME.
>> PICK SIX.
>> YEAH, LET'S THROW IT.
>> GO GET IT, BOSA.
DELAY OF GAME.
>> THROW IT, THROW IT!
>> HIT HIM, HI HIT!
>> GO GET HIM!
>> THROW THE BALL!
>> UNDER.
>> HEY!
GO GUEST GET HIM!
>> THESE GUYS, I CAN'T TELL --
>> RYAN, WHY AREN'T YOU --PY I
LIKE BOSA.
>> THROW THE BALL!
-- I GOT TOO MUCH GOING ON RIGHT
NOW.
THAT'S ARMSTEAD.
>> WAS THAT BOSA?
NO?
>> WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> IT'S OVER.
>> RAY-RAY BACK HERE.
RAY-RAY BACK HERE.
>> NEED THAT NINERS TOUCHDOWN.
BROCK PURDY.
>> I DON'T THINK THEY CALLED IT
BUT WE LINED UP OFFSIDES.
>> I DO HAVE DEEBO --
>> DEEBO FIRST TD.
>> YEAH!
>> WE'RE BACK.
BRYSON, YOUR ASS IS IN THE
JACKPOT.
>> NO CURSING.
>> ASS ISN'T A CURSE WORD.
>> THAT'S TRUE, IT'S NOT ONE OF
THE WORDS YOU CAN'T SAY.
>> WHAT'S THE CHAT SAYING?
WHAT'S THE GAUGE?
>> T. GAMBINO IS VERY UPSET HE
DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO GET HIS
TICKET IN.
DYLAN WINN DOESN'T LIKE MY
COWBOYS PREDICTION, HE THINKS
TOM BRADY IS GOING TO COOK HIM.
HE'S WRONG.
>> IS THE CHAT RIDING WITH US ON
NINERS?
>> US MEANING LIKE HALF OF US?
>> THE PEOPLE THAT MATTER.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> OH, OH MY GOD, OH MY GOD.
OH!
>> DUDE, WHAT WAS THAT?
>> WHAT THE HECK?
>> THERE'S YOUR BOY.
>> BIG C. BROCK.
>> THAT WAS TOUGH TO SEE.
>> BROCK 13.
>> YOU KNOW IT'S -- THAT WAS
IOWA STATE BROCK PURDY RIGHT
THERE.
>> NOW YOU HAVE TO RUN ON THIS
PLAY, WHICH IS SO PREDICTABLE.
ONE YARD, IT'S THIRD AND 9, NOW
WE'RE PUNTING, THE GAME'S OVER,
WE LOST.
>> HEY, WE NEED --
>> MORE WATER.
>> IT'S ALL GOOD.
>> COACH ABOUT TO LET HIM THROW.
LET HIM SLING THAT THING, YEAH.
ARE YOU GOING TO SLING?
>> HEY!
>> OH!
>> WHAT'S THE PARLAY?
>> 30 PLUS.
>> WOW.
>> LOOK AT THE SCREEN.
>> ON THE SCREEN.
>> LOOK AT THAT.
>> WHAT A DIME.
>> WHY DO WE TAKE LOCKETT --
>> 45.
>> LOCKETT?
>> IT JUST TAKES ONE.
>> WE TOOK LOCKETT.
>> WE SHOULDN'T HAVE.
>> YOU WERE ON THAT.
>> YOU WERE SO IN ON THAT.
>> NO, I SAID DON'T BET ON
RECEPTIONS.
>> WE NEED 11 MORE.
>> WHAT DO WE TAKE FROM
McCAFFREY?
>> ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN.
>> NO, FOUR.
>> THIS IS THE DEEBO.
THIS IS MINE.
LET'S GO!
CHECK IT!
>> THAT'S ONE CHECK.
>> LET'S GO!
>> NOBODY CASHED?
>> ONE BET, ONE BET, ONE BET.
>> LAST TIME I WAS HERE I GOT NO
WINS.
>> GREAT BACK, GREAT BACK.
>> LET'S GO!
>> GOT A LITTLE GREEN MARK IN
THERE.
ALL RIGHT, I NEED --
>> WE NEED BROCK PURDY NOW.
>> LET'S GO, DEEBO!
>> A NINERS TOUCHDOWN IS THE
BEST THING THAT CAN HAPPEN.
>> OF COURSE, YEAH.
>> FOR EVERYTHING.
>> McCAFFREY, Y'ALL.
McCAFFREY HERE.
GOT TO WATCH THE PLAY CLOCK.
>> COME ON.
>> OKAY, OKAY.
TIME-OUT.
>> THANK GOD I DID THAT FIRST
TIME-OUT, THANK GOD.
>> WHO SAID NINERS FIRST TIME
OUT?
>> NOT ME.
I ALMOST TOOK SEAHAWKS.
>> I SAID IT, I DIDN'T BET IT,
THOUGH.
>> 1-0, THOUGH.
>> ONE CHECK MARK, BABY.
>> OH, MAN.
>> ME AND YOU BOTH, BABY.
>> YOU TOOK IT?
>> YEAH, I HAD --
>> HE HAS A PUNT?
>> YEAH.
>> LET'S GO, LOGAN.
>> THAT FIRST THROW TOOK TWO
YEARS OFF MY LIFE.
THAT WAS SO BAD.
>> HE IS KIND OF FLOATING IT.
>> YOU KNOW I ROCK WITH THE
THREE BY TWO.
>> WELL, THAT WAS HOW MANY
MINUTES OF GAME?
>> ARE WE 100% SURE THIS IS
MINE?
>> YEAH, MINE IS HERE AND IT'S
GONE.
>> FAIR.
>> ALL RIGHT, HERE WE GO.
>> TONY BONES SAID HE USED HIS
NO SWEAT BET.
>> TO RIDE WITH SINUS.
>> YES.
>> THAT'S AWESOME, I LOVE THAT.
>> WE'LL SEND YOU SOCKS.
>> YEAH, WE HAVE SOCKS.
YOU GUYS WANT SOCKS IN THE CHAT,
WE GOT SOCKS.
>> OH-OH, THEY LET HIM THROW,
TOUCHDOWN!
OH!
>> OH, NO, NO, NO.
THAT WASN'T --
>> THAT'S JUWAN --
>> I PUT MONEY ON THAT.
>> ON FIRST?
FIRST TOUCHDOWN?
>> I THINK ANY TIME.
>> NO.
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO DO FIRST.
>> JUWAN JENNINGS?
>> I TOOK HIS --
>> HE WAS --
>> 7 H-1.
>> HOW THAT IS NOT PASS
INTERFERENCE?
>> I TOOK HIS TOTAL.
>> REFEREE, WHAT ARE WE LOOKING
AT?
>> I DON'T WANT TO SETTLE FOR
FIELD GOALS IN THIS WEATHER.
>> YEAH, HE WAS WIDE OPEN.
>> THREW IT.
>> THE ELEMENTS, THOUGH.
>> WE HAVEN'T RAN IT.
>> DEEBO DEEBO.
>> LET'S GO, DEEBO!
TERRIBLE THROW.
>> OH!
>> MAKE THINGS HAPPEN.
>> OH, YEAH, DEEBO!
OH, YEAH!
>> HE IS THE BEST PLAYER IN THE
LEAGUE.
>> HE'S AMAZING.
>> HE'S LIKE TOP TEN BEST GUY.
>> McCAFFREY AND HIM --
>> McCAFFREY HASN'T TOUCHED THE
BALL YET, HAS HE?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
>> WE MIGHT NOT GET THERE, SAM,
BUT I HEAR YOU.
>> TWO PLAYS TO WORK WITH.
>> I DO HEAR YOU.
>> IN SHORTS.
>> 0-0 IS AN EVEN NUMBER,
EFFECTIVELY.
>> OH, THEY'RE LETTING THE YOUNG
MEN THROW, LETTING THE YOUNG MEN
THROW.
>> DEEBO, IT'S A HANDOFF.
>> McCAFFREY, McCAFFREY SLAM --
>> DEEBO!
OH!
>> OH MY GOD.
>> HE JUST ALMOST THREW A PICK.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> THAT'S WHY YOU RUN THAT
THERE, TO SET UP THE ABILITY TO
GO FOR IT ON FOURTH.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> I FORGOT THAT I HAVE THE
49ers TEAM TOTAL ON HERE.
>> YEAH, RAINBOWS HERE.
TERRIBLE DECISION.
>> REALLY BAD DECISION.
>> I'M VERY NERVOUS ABOUT THIS,
REALLY NERVOUS ABOUT THIS.
>> WHAT IS THIS?
>> IN THIS WEATHER?
>> IN THE ELEMENTS.
>> 34 YARDS, COME ON.
>> I DON'T LIKE THIS.
>> THIS IS AUTOMATIC.
AUTOMATIC.
>> I'M SO SURPRISED, 100% HE WAS
GOING TO MAKE THAT.
>> GOOD AS GOLD.
3-0.
WE SHOULD BE UP 7-0.
>> NINERS, STOP THE COUNT.
>> I THINK THAT'S A WIN.
THAT'S A WIN.
>> PLUS 11 1/2.
>> THAT'S A WIN.
TONY BUNS IS STILL UPSET ABOUT
THE JUWAN JENNINGS?
SAID HE SHOULD HAVE THREW IT
EARLIER.
>> I AGREE.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> HE'S A ROOKIE, THOUGH.
>> PERSONALLY, I WOULD HAVE
THREW IT EARLIER.
>> HE'S A ROOKIE.
>> I'M ALL IN, I HAVE NO MONIES
LEFT.
>> THE ELEMENTS.
>> HE'S A ROOKIE.
>> IN THE ELEMENTS.
>> HOW'S THE CHAT DOING?
>> THE CHAT, COME TALK WITH US,
WE'LL GIVE YOU SOCKS.
>> DROP SOCK EMOJIS.
>> I'M FEELING GOOD, GUYS.
>>.
>> I'D LIKE TO KNOW IF WE HAVE A
PLAYBACK OF THE HIGHLIGHT REEL
OF ME WITH THE POP-A-SHOT BEFORE
THE SHOW STARTED.
>> GET HOT?
>> NO, I DIDN'T GET HOT.
I STARTED HOT AND I STAYED HOT
AND I DON'T THINK I MISSED MORE
THAN THREE.
>> CONVENIENTLY, WE PROBABLY
DON'T HAVE IT.
>> I THINK WE DO.
>> FOR THE RECORD --
>> ALL THE FLAT BALLS IN THE
POP-A-SHOT, THERE'S NO AIR.
>> FIRST OF ALL, FIRST OF ALL --
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO PUT HARD
WORK INTO INFLATING BALLS.
THAT'S THE FIRST OF ALL.
SECOND OF ALL, WHAT DOES IT
MATTER?
>> IF IT'S RIGGED.
>> IS THIS DEFLATEGATE?
DEFLATEGATE 2.0?
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> JUST SAYING.
THAT DON'T ADD UP.
>> YEAH, I THINK 88%.
>> SENT AN ALERT ON THE CHAT --
>> WHAT'S THAT?
>> JUST TO GET THE PEOPLE IN.
>> HOW ARE WE FEELING ABOUT THE
PARLAY?
>> 19-YARD PASS.
CHRISTIAN McCAFFREY DIDN'T TOUCH
THE BALL ONE TIME.
SO --
>> YEAH, I'M TIRED.
>> BUT YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT GOING
TO CONTINUE.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
I JUST DON'T LIKE THE WAY PURDY
IS THROWING THE BALL RIGHT NOW.
>> DOESN'T LOOK GREAT.
>> NO.
THE ELEMENTS.
>> RAIDERS UNDER MIGHT BE LIVE.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO WIN THIS
BY DEFENSE, WHICH I'M FINE WITH.
>> SHOUT-OUT TO ANYONE WHO TOOK
49ers TEAM TOTAL UNDER 26 1/2,
MIGHT HAVE BEEN THE BEST BET OF
THE YEAR.
I DON'T KNOW WHO DID THAT.
>> IT'S PRETTY EARLY.
>> YEAH, BUT YOU KNOW.
>> BRIGHT SIDE, THOUGH --
PURDY'S NOT THROWING WELL BUT WE
ONLY NEED 10 YARDS FROM AIYUK,
FOUR CATCHES FROM McCAFFREY.
>> PERFECT FOR HIM --
>> WAIT, WHAT ELSE?
>> THOSE ARE DOUBLE DOWNS.
>> THE LOCKETT THING, I DON'T
KNOW HOW THAT -- DID ANYONE --
WHO SHOUTED THAT OUT AND SAID
LOCKETT?
>> THE CHAT WAS ALL OVER IT.
>> THE CHAT WAS ALL OVER
LOCKETT?
>> THAT WAS A CHAT PLAY.
>> WE CAN GET THAT IN ONE PLAY.
>> WE CAN.
THAT'S WHAT WE SAID.
>> WE TALKED ABOUT HIS
RECEPTIONS TOO.
>> WE SAID THE YARDS WHICH IS
PROBABLY SMART.
>> COME ON, WE KNOW SHANAHAN'S
GOING TO DIAL UP AT LEAST TWO
SCREENS TO McCAFFREY, AT LEAST.
>> I LIKE THESE KICKOFFS, MAN,
RIGHT AT THE NUMBER, RIGHT AT
THE ONE.
>> OH, GO!
>>OH, NO.
>> OKAY, THAT --
>> ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
>> WE LOVE THAT, WE LOVE THAT.
>> WHY DO WE LOVE THAT?
>> WE HAVE THE SEAHAWKS.
>> GREG AND I NEED THE NINERS.
>> AND I NEED NOTHING TO HAPPEN
THE REST OF THE GAME.
>> WE DON'T NEED THAT.
JUST SPECIFYING, THAT WAS GOOD
FOR VINCE AND I.
>> DON'T SAY LOGAN.
>> AND LOGAN.
THAT WAS A GOOD OUTCOME FOR
VINCE LOGAN.
>> DON'T SAY WE.
>> NOT WE.
>> ONLY WE CAN SAY WE.
>> GENO, THROW THE BALL.
THROW THE BALL!
>> YEAH, BUDDY!
HEY, I'LL TAKE IT.
>> YEAH, GET IN THERE, GREENLAW.
GET IN THERE.
>> COY BOY IS ASKING, WHO'S
STOPPING BOSA AND MACK?
>> NO ONE.
>> WHO'S THE MACK?
>> MATTRESS MACK, PROBABLY.
>> COULD BE MATTRESS MACK.
>> BOSA, KALIL --
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
>> OH, CHARGERS.
NOT THE GAME THAT'S ON OUR
SCREEN.
>> NO, WE'RE TALKING
SEAHAWKS/NINERS.
>> THROW THE BALL, GENO, THROW
IT.
PICK.
>> OH, NO.
DID HE --
>> THROW IT AGAIN.
>> WHAT WAS IT, AGAIN?
>> OVER 4 1/2 RECEPTIONS.
>> 29 TO GO.
>> THAT'S MY BEST BET.
>> NO WORRIES.
>> WHAT WAS YOUR BEST BET?
>> OVER 4 1/2 RECEPTIONS FOR
D.K.
>> EASY.
>> YEAH, JUST HIT ME.
>> RYAN, TO BE HONEST, THAT
SHOULD HIT.
>> THEY SHOULD BE TRYING TO FEED
D.K.
>> ROBBINS AND LEWIS SHARP --
>> CAN HE CATCH IT?
I DON'T KNOW.
THEY SHOULD BE TRYING TO --
>> NO, NO, HE CAN CATCH IT.
>> HE SHOULD HAVE AT LEAST 11
TARGETS.
>> HERE'S WHAT I WOULDN'T DO,
RUN THE BALL.
>> FALSE START, PLEASE.
>> THIS IS BOSA TIME.
>> COME ON, COME ON.
PLAY ACTION.
>> OH!
>> OH, YEAH!
OH, YEAH, GIBSON!
GET OVER THERE!
>> THIS DEFENSE IS JUST --
>> OH, YEAH!
WHY WE SO QUIET IN HERE?
>> TOO DAMN GOOD.
>> WHY ARE YOU SO QUIET?
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED?
>> I'M NOT TOO CONCERNED.
>> LOGAN'S NOT CONCERNED.
>> I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS.
>> I'M NOT.
I KIND OF WANT TO BET SEAHAWKS
MONEY LINE, OBVIOUSLY.
>> LIVE?
SEAHAWKS WHEN OF?
>> YEAH, WASTE THE MONEY, I'LL
TAKE YOUR BET.
>> HE'LL TAKE YOUR BET.
>> WITH ODDS?
>> WITH ODDS.
>> IT'S 11 1/2 RIGHT NOW IS THE
SPREAD.
>> I'LL TAKE YOUR BET.
I'LL PAY OUT WHATEVER IT IS.
>> JUST WEIGHT IT.
BUYING THE POINTS.
>> CLASSIC RYAN.
>> COME ON, BROCK, YOU GOT TO
LOOK BETTER.
>> CLASSIC RYAN, HE'S WINNING?
SEAHAWKS ARE PLUS 470 ON THE
MONEY LINE, IF ANYONE'S
INTERESTED.
>> ANYBODY?
ANYBODY?
>> I'LL TAKE THAT.
I'LL HOUSE THE BET FOR YOU.
>> YOU'LL HOUSE IT?
>> I'LL GIVE YOU A LIVE ODDS
BOOST.
>> BRYSON SUPPORTS BOOK.
>> SPRINKLE A LITTLE ON MONEY
LINE.
>> A LIVE BET.
>> WE HAVE A LIVE BET.
>> ON WHAT?
>> ALL RIGHT, I'M SPLITTING IT.
>> HOLD UP, OKAY, TIME-OUT,
TINLGOUT.
THIS MAN BETS LITERALLY 45
SECONDS AGO.
LOOKED OVER.
"I DON'T FEEL GOOD ABOUT THIS."
LIVE BETTING THE SEAHAWKS MONEY
LINE?
>> IT'S A ROLLER COASTER OF
EMOTIONS.
SEAHAWKS MONEY LINE.
>> HE'S GOT MONEY TO BLOW, I
GUESS.
>> THAT'S WILD, BRO.
>> JACK JUMPED IN HERE.
FRIEND OF THE SHOW.
KITTLE, ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT,
GREG?
>> I LIKE IT.
I LIKE IT.
NOW THAT WE SAW BROCK PURDY
THROWING THE BALL ON THE FIRST
DRIVE, I LIKE IT.
WOULD I BET IT?
I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S A LOT OF VARIABLES, RYAN.
IT'S ELEMENTS, ROOKIE
QUARTERBACK.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> WE SAW HOW HE WAS THROWING
THE BALL ON THE FIRST DRIVE.
>> NO OFFENSE, NOT GOOD.
>> I AGREE, I THINK BEFORE THE
GAME, THE IDEA OF KITTLE JUST
CONTINUING TO STAY HOT WAS GOOD.
HE WAS PLUS 1145, I THINK, ON --
PLUS 145 ON DRAFT KINGS.
>> WHAT'S NO OFFENSIVE SCORELESS
DRIVE, WHAT'S THE ODDS?
>> NO OFFENSIVE SCORE IS MINUS
170.
>> FOR NO?
WHAT IS TO SCORE?
>> WE COULD DO THIS.
>> THEY'RE GOING TO SCORE.
>> THE NINERS ARE GOING TO
SCORE?
>> WHY NOT?
SIDE BET?
>> NO.
>> TELL US WHAT -- YOU'RE
SWEATING, I DON'T KNOW.
>> THAT'S WILD ODDS AT THE 10
YARD LINE.
FOR A GUY THAT THREW THE BALL TO
THE OTHER TEAM TWICE LAST DRIVE.
>> I BELIEVE -- HONESTLY, I
AGREE.
>> YOU SAY NO?
>> NO.
>> YEAH.
>> I SAY --
>> MINUS ONE LIVE BET FROM ZINS,
THAT'S IT SO FAR.
>> WELCOME.
>> MINUS 178.
>> I'M IN THE LAB WITH LOGAN.
>> WHEN I WAS GETTING IN THE
LAB, PLACING BETS FOR
EVERYBODY --
>> I SAID LEAVE HIM ALONE, I'M
IN SUPPORT.
>> ONE LIVE BET.
VINCE AND BRYCE WAS TALKING
ABOUT NO OFFENSIVE SCORE ON THIS
DRIVE.
>> A HEAVY DOSE OF DEEBO IN THE
FIRST DRIVE.
THIS DRIVE, KITTLE.
>> YOU'RE WITH JACKHAM IN THE
CHAT.
>> I DON'T KNOW, BUT I THINK
LITTLE KITTLE'S GOING TO GET AND
YARDS.
>> OUR BOY KITTLE'S GOING TO
EAT.
>> AND CMC.
>> OH, VINCE.
HERE WE GO.
>> PLUS 750 ON THE MONEY LINE.
>> YOU CAN'T DO THAT, THAT'S
GOING TO BE A SPOILER OF WHAT
JUST HAPPENED.
>> OH!
>> THAT'S RULE NUMBER ONE.
WHEN YOU HAVE THE ODDS BOARD UP,
YOU CAN'T SAY IT OUT LOUD, IT'S
SPOILING.
>> NOT COOL.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> YEAH, RIGHT.
YOU'VE GOT TO GO IN TIME-OUT.
>> GO TIME-OUT.
>> GO IN TIME-OUT.
YOU'VE GOT TO MAKE THREE IN A
ROW BEFORE YOU COME OUT.
FIVE IN A ROW.
>> I'LL MAKE THE FIRST --
>> FIVE IN A ROW.
MAKE FIVE IN A ROW, THEN YOU CAN
COME BACK.
>> THAT'S HELL OF FUNNY.
THAT'S THE FUNNIEST.
>> IN A ROW.
>> ONE, TWO, THREE --
>> OH, NO.
>> FOUR.
FIVE, HE MADE IT.
>> WELCOME BACK.
>> WE MISSED THE FIRST PLAY.
DOESN'T MATTER, THOUGH.
WE'RE GOOD.
>> WHAT HAPPENED?
>> THAT WAS --
>> I DON'T KNOW, CHECK THE LIVE
ODDS AND TELL US BEFORE.
>> TACKLE FOR ELIJAH MITCHELL.
>> WHO WAS THE GUY WHO SAID NO
OFFENSIVE SCORE THIS DRIVE?
>> JESUS.
>> I DIDN'T SEE -- LOSS OF
YARDS?
>> IS THERE ANYTHING WORSE THAN
THE PERSON WHO SPOILS THE GAME
WHO HAS ODDS --
>> MITCHELL, WAS THAT MINUS 3?
>> THAT'S NOT GOOD FOR MY PRIDE.
>> DID WE GET POACHED BY
MITCHELL?
>> ARE PEOPLE SPOILING THE GAME?
>> NO, NO.
>> HERE WE GO.
>> THAT BOY PUT HIS SHOULDER
DOWN.
LET'S GO, SAM.
>> McCAFFREY!
>> THEY BROUGHT THE GAME TO ELI,
I'M SORRY.
>> BOOTLEG, BOOTLEG.
>> I FEEL YOU, I LIKE THAT.
>> WHAT WITH THE ODDS?
>> 25-1.
>> LOOK AT THE ROOKIE WORK.
CHECK HIS PROGRESSION.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
LOOK AT THE ROOKIE WORK.
>> WE REALLY NEED THAT.
>> THAT WAS HIS FOURTH OPTION,
BRYSON.
>> HERE WE GO, HERE WE GO.
NOWHERE IS McCAFFREY.
>> HERE WE GO.
>> STOP HIM, STOP HIM.
>> I TOLD YOU THEY WERE GIVING
IT TO ELI.
>> McCAFFREY TIME.
>> GET JORDAN MASON IN THERE.
>> YOU FAILED.
GET McCAFFREY IN.
>> WE NEED McCAFFREY BACK IN
THIS GAME.
>> WHO HAD 49ers FOR THE FIRST
TD?
49er PLAYERS?
>> I HAD CMC.
>> I GOT PURDY.
>> DEEBO.
>> KENNETH WALKER.
>> McCAFFREY?
McCAFFREY?
>> McCAFFREY AND DEEBO.
>> BOOTLEG, BOOTLEG.
>> SPLIT.
>> McCAFFREY, DEEBO.
>> WE'RE ALL ON McCAFFREY.
WE'RE ALL ON McCAFFREY.
>> THIS IS THE BOOST.
WHERE IS HE?
HE'S IN THE BACKFIELD.
>> WATCH 85.
>> NO, NO!
>> 85.
>> NO KITTLE.
>> DEEBO, DEEBO, DEEBO!
>> LET'S GO, LET'S GO!
>> OH MY GOD.
THAT WAS --
>> HEY!
>> LET'S GO!
LET'S GO!
>> I BET THE BOOST.
>> I KNOW, WHEN HE ROLLED OUT --
>> LET'S GO!
>> I THOUGHT YOU WERE --
>> EVERY TIME PEOPLE --
>> BOOST, BOOST.
>> THE BOOST DOESN'T HIT.
>> SEAHAWKS PLUS 11 1/2, STILL
COVERING.
>> WHOO!
MY HEART IS PUMPING SO FAST.
>> LISTEN, LISTEN.
>> GREAT.
>> SEAHAWKS PLUS 17 1/2.
>> LET'S GO, LET'S GO.
>> THE ROAD TO ARIZONA STARTS
TODAY.
>> STARTS NOW.
>> STARTS TODAY.
>> I NEED TO GO TAKE MY ASTHMA
INHALER.
>> THAT WAS JUST A RUN.
>> WELL, BAD BEAT FOR DEEBO.
>> ALL GOOD OR NEED ME FOR
ANYTHING?
>> NO.
>> I WAS GOING TO SEND PLUS 470,
BUT THEY'RE NOW 17 1/2 POINT
DOGS.
>> BOSA OVER A QUARTER SACK,
WHICH GREG, WE DIDN'T DISCUSS
THAT YOU HAVE 49ers MONEY LINE?
>> YES.
>> AND YOU HAVE BOSA OVER A
QUARTER SACK MINUS --
>> WHERE DO YOU GET MINUS 460?
MINUS 700?
>> I GET THAT YOU DON'T CARE
ABOUT THE ODDS.
>> IT'S SPRINKLED IN, WHAT DO
YOU MEAN THIS.
>> HEY, MAN.
>> BUT THAT DOESN'T --
>> VALUE'S VALUE.
>> I'M LOOKING FOR WINS.
>> THE NINERS ARE GOING TO WIN.
ANY AMOUNT OF MONEY ON THEIR
MONEY LINE IS GOOD VALUE.
>> THANK YOU, BRYSON.
ALL BOSA HAS TO DO IS GET HALF A
SACK AND I WIN.
GENO SMITH'S DOWN 10-0.
HE'S GOING TO BE THROWING THE
BALL IN THE ELEMENTS.
>> CAN I GET A TAKE FROM THE
CHAT ABOUT HOW WE FEEL ABOUT
BETTING 460 MONEY LINES AND
MINUS 275 DEFENSIVE BROCK PLAYS?
>> CAN WE GO TO THE CHAT?
>> 460 MONEY LINE IS SPRINKLED
INTO A PARLAY.
THEY ASKED ME FOR A BET, I GAVE
THEM THE NINERS MONEY LINE.
>> THE NICK BOSA THING --
>> THAT'S A PLAY.
>> VALUE.
>> MINUS 275.
>> ALL HE HAS TO DO IS GET A
HALF A SACK --
>> MINUS 275.
>> WE JUST HIT THE ANY TIME TD
BOOST.
>> TRYING TO PUT SHAME ON MY
BETS.
>> KUMBAYA, EVERYTHING'S FINE,
EVERYTHING'S GREAT.
>> EVERYTHING'S GREAT FOR YOU.
>> WE HAVE OUR ASS IN THE
JACKPOT ON THIS SIDE OF THE
COUCH.
>> YOU JUST WON THE BET ON THE
VERY LAST PLAY OF THIS GAME.
YOU WON A BET.
>> YEAH, THAT WAS PRETTY COOL.
>> YEAH.
>> I CAN'T LIE, THAT WAS COOL.
WE NEED GENO TO START THROWING.
>> HE'S DOWN 10 POINTS.
>> WHILE WEAR ON THE SUBJECT OF
THINGS, IN THE CHAT, I'M SETTING
LIVE LINE BRYSON STRICKER
SPORTSBOOK, 9 1/2 TIMES THAT
GREG USES "IN THE ELEMENTS."
>> YEAH, OKAY.
>> 9 1/2.
>> STARTING NOW?
>> WINNERS GET SOCKS.
>> THAT'S AN OVER.
>> OVER.
>> YEAH.
>> AND LOGAN HAD McCAFFREY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> I THOUGHT RYAN --
>> LOGAN, DID YOU HAVE
McCAFFREY?
>> YEAH.
>> I HAD DEEBO.
>> DEEBO, BAD BEAT.
>> SO IT'S JUST A STRAIGHT-UP
REACTION?
>> DID LOGAN WIN AGAIN?
OH, THAT'S --
>> COME ON, MAN, COME ON, MAN!
>> I'M TRYING TO GET CASH.
>> ALL RIGHT, WHO ALMOST
TACKLED?
>> I'M JUST HOPING --
>> THAT BOY JORDAN MASON.
>> ALSO ROOTING FOR GENO.
>> I HAVE SEEN NO SEMBLANCE OF
LIFE IN THE SEAHAWKS TO SCORE
POINTS.
>> DANG.
>> ONE PLAY.
ONE PLAY.
>> THAT'S WHAT WE SAID.
>> I'M GOING TO TELL THEM TO
CLIP IT.
I'M NOT GOING TO POST FOR
BETTING, I'M GOING TO POST ON MY
PERSONAL.
>> SHOUT-OUT SHOUT-OUT MELLY, W
HARD.
>> BOSA -- THAT WAS A FREAKING
FALSE START.
OH, I THOUGHT THAT WAS REPLAY
ACTION.
I DON'T LIKE THIS.
>> I SAW STRICK DROP IN THE
CHAT, KENNETH WALKER RUSHING
ATTEMPTS OVER, THAT'S WHAT WE
SHOULD HAVE TAKEN, TO BE HONEST.
>> I WILL SAY THIS, THIS GAME
SCRIPT IS SETTING UP TO NINERS
GET ONE MORE TOUCHDOWN, SEAHAWKS
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO ABANDON THE
RUN AND START THROWING IT.
>> THREE AND OUT, SO THREE
PASSES AT A TIME.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> STILL AT ONE PASS?
>> WE'VE GOT A LIVE BET IN THE
CHAT, DEEB BENEXT TD SCORE.
>> OH, THAT'S FUN, THAT'S FUN.
>> HEY, WATCH BOSA GET THAT
SACK.
ALSO, WE'VE GOT MORE PEOPLE HERE
IN THE CHAT.
>> LOVE THAT.
>> BAD PASS.
>> WELCOME, NEW CHAT MEMBERS.
>> YEAH, WELCOME.
>> TELL US WHAT YOU'RE BETTING,
GET IN THE CHAT, WE'LL SEND YOU
SOCKS.
>> LET US KNOW IF THAT WAS THE
MOST GROSS DISPLAY OF DPI YOU'VE
EVER SEEN.
>> 7-10 --
>> SEAHAWKS NOT SCORING.
>> I WOULD LIKE LESS POINTS.
>> GO GET HIM, BOSA!
THIS IS BOSA.
>> NINERS ARE COVERING.
>> THIS IS BOSA --
>> YES, YES!
>> WE'RE BACK.
>> WHY GO HIGH ON THE --
>> WE BET.
>> I SAID HE WENT TO KANSAS
STATE, WHY ARE WE BETTING ON
HIM?
>> WELL, I WOULD HAVE DROT UP
D.K. RECEPTIONS.
>> WE BET ON A BALD GUY FROM
KANSAS STATE, MAN.
>> PASS ATTEMPT COMING UP.
>> SHOUT-OUT D.C.
D.K.
>> OH.
>> SIX RUNS?
WE'LL TAKE IT, WE'LL TAKE IT.
>> WE SHOULD TAKE RECEPTIONS.
>> HEY, WE GOT OUR BOY IN THE
CHAT.
>> OH.
OH, NO.
>> IT'S BACK.
IT SAYS BACK.
>> NO, IT'S --
>> HAMMY.
>> JUST A CRUMP, JUST A CRUMP.
>> WE GOT DEPTH AT LINEBACKER.
I'M NOT SURE.
SAID GREG WOULD BE FUN TO WATCH
A GAME WITH.
>> I AGREE.
>> IT'S OKAY.
WHAT'S UP, BOYS, JUST CASHED CMC
ANY TIME.
>> LET'S GO!
LET'S GO!
>> YOU KNOW WHAT REALLY SUCKS IS
THE SUCKERS AND LOSERS BEFORE
THIS GAME WHO WERE CLOWNING US
ONLINE FOR THE CMC ANY TIME
BOOST.
>> YEAH, WE WON'T NAME NAMES.
>> NOW THEY'RE BOTH SAD AND
POOR.
>> AND POOR.
>> YEAH.
>> OH, OUR BETTING POST, THEY'RE
NOT -- YEAH.
IF I HAD THE POWER TO STOP
CHRISTIAN McCAFFREY FROM SCORING
A TOUCHDOWN, I WOULDN'T BE
BETTING $1,000 ON THE GAME TOTAL
S TO BE ODD, BROTHER.
MY GOD.
>> WE NEED MORE TROLL VOICE.
>> YEAH, I LOVE IT.
>> IT'S PRIMETIME!
I'VE GOT THE TWO FIRST
QUARTERBACKS TO COMPLETE A PASS,
OH MY GOD!
JESUS, MAN.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO, COME ON.
>> LET'S GO, LET'S GO!
>> CLMR. DIET COKE, SLEEPER PLA
NO TOUCHDOWNS SCORED WITH THE
SEAHAWKS.
>> NO.
>> NO, IT'S NOT A SUPER PLAY
ANYMORE.
THE VALUE -- IT'S LIKE --
>> I AGREE.
>> LET'S SEE, LET'S SEE.
>> ALSO, I THINK --
>> NICE.
>> NO SEAHAWKS TD.
>> BRIAN, ARE YOU ORDERING FOOD?
>> ONLY BET MY CMC BET BECAUSE
OF YOU BOYS SO SHOUT-OUT TO YOU
ALL.
>> THAT'S NICE.
>> WE'LL SEND YOU SOCKS.
>> YOU GOT SOCKS.
>> I THINK IT'S GREAT.
LET'S HAVE THE ONE GUY HERE WHO
DOESN'T HAVE A COMPANY CARD TO
ORDER THE FOOD.
>> THAT'S FAIR.
>> YEAH, FOR SURE, DEFINITELY.
>> I CAN'T SAY ANYTHING.
>> BUT -- WHAT ARE WE -- WHAT DO
WE WANT?
>> WHAT ARE WE FEELING?
>> I'M FREE PROMO, BY THE WAY.
A LITTLE ZA?
>> DUDES WATCHING SPORTS EATING
PIZZA.
>> YEAH, I CAN DO SOME ZA.
>> ZA?
>> WHAT DO I GOT TO DO --
>> TELL US WHAT TO ORDER IN THE
CHAT.
WHAT SHOULD WE GET FOR LUNCH IN
THE CHAT?
>> IT'S 5:00.
>> DINNER.
>> CEDRIC, SAD AND POOR, THREE
LAUGHING EMOJIS, THANKS FOR THE
350.
>> HEY!
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> WE.
>> LET'S ASK THE CHAT WHAT'S
BEST TO EAT WHEN YOU'RE DOWN
TREMENDOUSLY BAD.
>> TACO BELL.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
>> TACO BELL IS THE BEST.
>> WHY ARE YOU DOWN THAT,
THOUGH?
>> BET THE MONEY LINE.
>> IT WAS ALL MY FAULT, BY THE
WAY.
>> ALSO NOT COVERING.
>> SENT YOU DOWN THAT ROAD.
>> BOSA, COME ON.
>> I WOULD LIKE MORE --
>> DEFENSIVE PLAYER OF THE YEAR,
MORE DEFENSE.
>> OH!
>> YEAH!
>> I DO LIKE THE PHYSICALITY.
>> MICHAEL BOWLING WANTS TO KNOW
HOW MANY BATHROOM TRIPS FOR
BRYSON.
CURRENTLY ZERO.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
OVER/UNDER IS.
>> 1 1/2, HE TOOK 2 LAST TIME.
>> THE LINE SHOULD BE SET AT 2
TO GIVE THE SPORTSBOOK SAFETY AT
2.
PEOPLE GOT TO PUT IT TO THE
TEST.
>> ANOTHER RUN.
>> BRYSON --
>> STOP RUNNING THE BALL.
>> HE'S DRANK HALF A CUP OF
WATER SO FAR.
>> IT'S THE ELEMENTS.
>> THAT'S OUR SECOND D-LINE,
WAIT TILL THEY PUT THE
STARTERS -- I LOVE THAT EMPANADA
MAMA RACK.
>> EMPANADA?
>> EMPANADA MAMA.
>> I COULD DO EMPANADAS.
>> I COULD DO THAT.
>> THAT'S A LEADING CONTENDER.
>> WHO'S GOING TO PICK UP THE
DELIVERY?
SOMEBODY'S GOT TO LOSE A BET TO
HAVE TO DO THAT, RIGHT?
>> COULD BE.
>> I WANT TO KNOW, ME AND GREG
ARE BOTH 1-0 RIGHT NOW.
SO NOT US.
>> WATCH LOCKETT.
>> OH, OH!
>> GET HIM!
>> HEY, HEY, HEY!
>> GENO SMITH --
>> I LIKE THAT.
I'LL EAT THAT.
>> THAT'S GOT TO BE A SACK.
>> I GOT ME A PASS ATTEMPT.
>> ANY POINTS?
>> WE CAN'T GET GREEDY.
>> THAT'S OUR SECOND STREAM
D-LINE OUT THERE.
>> LET'S GET GREEDY.
>> HE'S GOBBLED.
>> BRYSON, JACKHAM SAYS YOU GUYS
ARE OVER AT 2.
HE'S TAKING YOUR OVER.
>> I RESPECT THAT.
IT'S ONE OF THOSE, BREAK THE
SEAL, ONCE IT RAINS IT POURS
TYPE SITUATIONS.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
HALFTIME, WE'LL HAVE A GOOD
TEMPERATURE.
>> ALSO, I DRINK WATER SLOWER
OUT OF CUPS.
LAST TIME I HAD BOTTLES.
>> OKAY.
>> HE'S NOT OUT.
>> THAT'S KIND OF INSANE.
>> HE PUT HIS WINNINGS FROM CMC
ON TYLER LOCKETT TO BE THE
SECOND TOUCHDOWN SCORER.
HE NEEDS TYLER LOCKETT HERE.
>> TYLER LOCKETT FROM HERE WOULD
GASH OUR BET OR CLOSE TO.
>> CLOSE TO TO HAVE.
>> I WOULDN'T HATE IT.
I ADMIT --
>> RIGHT HERE.
>> CASH A LEG, YEAH.
>> GO GET HIM, BOSA.
>> LOCKETT'S ONE UP.
>> IF DEEBO SCORES NEXT 49ers
DRIVE, I NEED 10 PUSH-UPS OUT OF
GREG OR RITTER.
>> ARE YOU COMMITTING TO THE 10
PUSH-UPS?
EITHER OF YOU?
>> I WILL BE CELEBRATING.
>> OH!
>> HEY!
>> GUYS, I SAID FOUR-PLUS
RECEPTIONS AND NO ONE LISTENED
TO ME.
>> HOW MANY YARDS IS THAT?
PROBABLY 12?
>> YEAH.
>> YEAH, YOU'RE ON --
>> HONESTLY, I ACTUALLY FEEL
REALLY GOOD.
>> YEAH, NO --
>> I FEEL REALLY GOOD ABOUT THE
PARLAY.
>> THE PARLAY I FEEL --
>> FOOD, YOU GOT A COMPUTER, YOU
GOT A PHONE --
>> I'M PROGRAMMING LIVE.
>> I'M GETTING VERY WORRIED
ABOUT MY $1,000 ON ODD, I'M
WORRIED ABOUT THAT.
>> HOW MANY PIZZAS DO WE NEED?
TWO PIZZAS?
>> PROBABLY TWO.
>> TWO LARGE PIES?
>> CMC ANY TIME.
>> TWO LARGE PIES.
>> IF ANYONE HAS A
RECOMMENDATION ON PIZZA IN NEW
YORK, PLEASE DROP THAT.
>> YEAH.
>> WHATEVER'S RIGHT HERE.
>> WINGS AS WELL?
I NEED A LITTLE CHICKEN WING.
>> JOE'S PIZZA.
>> OOH!
>> NEVER HEARD OF IT.
>> UPSIDE.
>> I'M DOWN.
SOUNDS GOOD.
>> BARBECUE?
>> EAST VILLAGE.
>> SOMEBODY WANT TO HOP IN THEIR
CAR AND DRIVE US TO JOE'S
BARBECUE?
THAT WOULD SLAP RIGHT NOW.
>> IT'S PRETTY COOL THAT WE HIT
THAT McCAFFREY BOOST.
>> YEAH, THAT WAS FUN, GUYS.
>> SHOUT-OUT DRAFT KINGS.
>> ABOUT TO HIT THE PARLAY.
>> THINGS GOING WELL.
>> THAT'S THE THING.
>> THE ONLY THING WE'RE NOT ON
PACE FOR IS THE GENO OVER,
CORRECT?
>> WELL --
>> LOCKETT WE'RE OVER PACE FOR.
>> AS LONG AS THE NINERS KEEP
SCORING, GENO'S GOING TO HAVE TO
THROW IT.
>> YEAH.
>> I'M HUNGRY.
>> OKAY.
>> HE'S GETTING HANGRY, FOLKS.
>> WHOPPER, WHOPPER, WHOPPER,
WHOPPER.
>> THAT WOULD BE SO GOOD.
>> ACROSS THE STREET.
>> BURGER KING?
>> PLAIN PIZZA?
>> WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
CLARIFY WHAT YOU MEAN BY PLAIN
PIZZA.
>> IS THAT A NEW YORK THING?
NEW YORKERS EAT PLAIN PIZZA?
>> IS THAT NOT A THING?
>> WAIT, WHAT?
>> PLAIN PIZZA?
>> LIKE CHEESE PIZZA?
>> YEAH, THAT'S A --
>> IS THIS REAL?
>> THIS IS A BET.
>> WHAT'S PLAIN PIZZA?
>> HE SAID PLAIN PIZZA?
OH MY GOODNESS.
>> ARE WE BEING SERIOUS?
THIS IS NOT A BET?
>> NO ONE HAS EVER SAID PLAIN
PIZZA.
>> ON WHAT PLANET DO YOU LIVE ON
THAT NOBODY HAS EVER SAID PLAIN
PIZZA?
>> NOBODY HAS EVER SAID PLAIN
PIZZA.
>> I'VE NEVER HEARD THAT.
>> PLAIN?
>> WE GOT YOU, RYAN.
>> PLAIN PIZZA IS NOT A THING.
NO ONE'S EVER SAID THAT.
>> THAT'S THE CHAT.
>> NO ONE HAS EVER USED THE WORD
PLAIN PIZZA.
>> MEANING THERE'S NOTHING ON IT
BUT WHAT IS REGULARLY ON A
PIZZA.
TOMATO SAUCE AND CHEESE.
>> CHEESE PIZZA.
CHEESE POSE WERE AND PEPPERONI
PIZZA.
>> I FEEL LIKE A CHEESE PIZZA IS
A REDUNDANT STATEMENT, AN
OXYMORON.
>> I THOUGHT YOU MEANT, SHOULD
WE GET A PLAIN PIZZA?
>> OR THE STORE WAS CALLED
"PLAIN PIZZA."
>> THIS IS JARRING TO ME RIGHT
NOW.
I ACTUALLY CAN'T BELIEVE THIS.
>> THEY GOT WILDCAT?
WE ABOUT TO STOP THIS.
>> WHAT?
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> IS THIS A JOKE?
>> WE'RE DOING ANYTHING BESIDES
THROWING THE BALL RIGHT NOW.
>> THAT'S WORKING, THOUGH.
>> WHY WOULD THEY RUN THE BALL
REALLY WELL?
>> EARNING EVERY YARD, BABY.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> IT IS WORKING.
>> IT'S GOING TO RUIN YOUR LIFE.
>> OKAY, I'M BEING YELLED AT IN
MY EAR, IT'S BECAUSE NEW YORKERS
BUILD THEIR PIZZA IN LINE.
THERE'S AN OPTION FOR TOPPINGS
AND NO TOPPINGS.
I DON'T BUILD MY PIZZA IN LINE.
I DIAL MY PHONE, I CALL, I SAY,
"HEY, CAN I GET A LARGE PLAIN
PIE?"
BLAZE PIZZA, MAYBE.
>> SHOUT OUT SAYING WE GOING TO
BE BETTING USFL THIS SUMMER?
BETTING XFL WHAT IS WE'RE
BETTING.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> CFL?
>> IS THERE CHICKEN WINGS?
>> THAT WILL DO IT.
>> NO CHICKEN WINGS?
>> OH, MAN, ARE WE GETTING HURT?
>> NO, NO?
>> ONE OF OUR LINEMEN.
>> OH.
>> WHERE WE AT ON THE CHICKEN
WINGS?
>> THERE'S SOME MUSIC.
>> HOLD ON HOLD ON.
>> IT'S JOE AND PAT'S PIZZA.
>> HEY, JOE AND PAT'S, YES.
>> THE ORIGINAL ONE'S STATEN
ISLAND.
NEW YORK ONE --
>> STATEN ISLAND.
>> NO, IT'S GREAT.
IT'S GREAT.
>> IT'S GOOD?
>> IF YOU LIKE A THIN CRUST.
>> SUPER THIN.
>> I'M A BIG THIN CRUST GUY.
>> YEAH.
>> I LIKE THE CRUNCH.
-- Y
>> YOU'RE NOT A THIN?
>> I'M A HUGE THIN, I DON'T LIKE
A DOHY CRUST.
>> THEY'RE ON THE MENU.
>> SCOPING OUT THE MENU.
>> BRYSON WAS CONCERNED ABOUT
THE WING SITUATION.
>> AND SALAD.
>> WHAT IF I WANT WINGS?
>> IS ANYONE CLOSE TO CASHING
ANYTHING?
>> 45 MINUTES AWAY.
>> OKAY, COOL.
>> WE WANT A PLAIN PIZZA, A
PEPPERONI PIZZA --
>> GET ME OUT OF HERE, DUDE,
TAKE ME BACK TO KANSAS.
>> YOU'RE ON THIS TRAIN TOO.
>> IT'S A CHEESE PIZZA.
>> WHAT DID THE CHAT SAY?
TONY BONES WHO LIED AND TOLD YOU
WE DON'T BUILD OUR PIZZAS.
>> TEXTBOOK, LOGAN PULLING THE
FIRST TD SCORE OUT OF A HAT
AGAIN.
>> HEY, WELL, YOU CAN --
>> YEAH, EVIDENTLY VISCA --
>> THAT'S ABSURD.
>> THAT'S PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
>> WHAT ARE THE ODDS?
>> LAVISCA WAS I THINK 15-1.
>> WHAT ARE THE OVER/UNDER --
WHATEVER TIME IT SAYS THAT IT'S
GOING TO ARRIVE, WE CHOOSE A
NUMBER.
EVERYONE HAS TO CHOOSE A NUMBER
BASED OFF THAT NUMBER, FURTHEST
AWAY -- OR WE DON'T EVEN GET THE
HIT NUMBER, BLINDLY GUESS.
>> I LINE THE BLIND GUESS.
>> THE BLIND GUESS CAN BE BRUTAL
WHEN IT'S TWO HOURS.
>> LET US KNOW WHEN YOU PUT THE
ORDER IN SO WE CAN LOCK IN OUR
BETS.
>> I'LL LET YOU GUYS KNOW.
>> RYAN, DO YOU NEED MY
CORPORATE CARD?
>> PROBABLY.
>> PLEASE THROW THE BALL.
>> FIRST DOWN.
>> WE'RE DEAD.
>> GOING TO LET THEM RUN RIGHT
DOWN OUR THROATS.
>> GARLIC BREAD?
>> YEAH.
>> A LITTLE SPRINKLE, YEAH.
>> GARLIC BREAD, MINUS 500.
>> THIS IS SUCH BULL -- DUDE.
THEY'RE LIKE -- IT'S NOT FAIR.
>> WE'RE GOOD.
>> LIKE AN EIGHT-MINUTE DRIVE.
>> THEY'RE RUINING MY LIFE.
>> ANY TIME, BABY.
>> YEAH.
>> LET'S GO, BABY.
>> HE LOOKS LIKE HE'S LOOKING
BACK.
>> WE'RE BACK.
>> NO.
>> NO, HE WAS LOOKING BACK.
>> WE'RE BACK.
2-0.
>> IT'S ALL OVER.
>> 2-0, RITTER, YOUR PREDICTION
IS LOOKING GOOD.
>> WE'RE STILL LIVE ON MINE.
>> JUST WAIT.
HERE COMES THE MISSED P.A.T. TO
GET US ALL OFF THE --
>> I AM GOING TO FREAK OUT.
>> DID HE GO AT 3-0 DOWN?
>> IS THEY A WHOLE --
>> YES.
>> BIG-TIME.
CHARLES CROSS.
>> THIS IS BULL.
>> WE'RE BACK.
WE'RE PLUS 410 RIGHT NOW, NICE.
>> I KNOW PLUS 9 1/2, SO WE'RE
RIGHT BACK.
>> RIGHT BACK IN IT.
>> RIGHT BACK TO THE BEGINNING.
>> GOT TO MAKE IT.
>> PLAYER MISSED.
OH MY GOD.
>> NEED THOSE POINTS.
>> SHOULD WE GET A LIVE BET?
>> SHOUT-OUT.
>> YOU'RE LIVE BETTING FEED BACK
HERE.
>> WHY DO YOU GET A LIVE BACK
GAME?
>> WE'RE FEELING IT.
>> I DO LIKE THAT -- WHOEVER WAS
TOSSING OUT THE DEEBO NEXT
TOUCHDOWN.
>> WHAT'S THE CHAT SAYING?
>> ODDS WOULD HAVE BEEN NICE.
>> SEATTLE SCORE VIBES ARE LOW.
>> YEAH, CHECK --
>> VIBES ARE LOW?
>> VIBES OVER HERE, HIGH.
>> YOU GUYS ARE QUIET.
THIS IS HOW I COPE, ALL RIGHT?
>> LIVE BETTING --
>> NO, I LOVE LIVE BETTING.
LITTLE SPRINKLES.
>> LIVE TD SCORES, OKAY.
>> NEXT TD SCORED, SOMEBODY SAID
DEEBO PLUS 700?
>> IS THAT WHAT IT IS?
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S PRETTY GOOD.
>> BROCK PURDY GOT TO COME OUT
AND LOOK GOOD, SAM.
>> A LITTLE PRESSURE.
>> THIS IS PROBABLY THE MOST
BORED I'VE BEEN, TO BE HONEST.
>> THAT WAS WAY TOO EASY.
THAT WAS KIND OF SECRETARIY.
AND WE KNEW THEY WERE RUNNING
EVERY SINGLE TIME.
>> THAT WAS A LONG DRIVE.
>> I'M GOING DEEBO NEXT
TOUCHDOWN SCORE LIVE, 7-1.
>> >> THAT'S FUN.
HAS UFC STARTED?
I'VE GOT UFC BETS I'VE GOT TO
WORRY ABOUT.
>> PARLAYED WITH ODD.
>>> OH, IT HAS, OH MY GOD.
LET'S GO!
>> LET'S GO.
>> WHOO!
>> CASHING.
>> LET'S GO!
>> THAT'S GOT TO BE BIG.
>> YEAH, THE ROUND ONE --
>> NO, MY GUY THAT I HAD MONEY
ON WON IN THE FIRST ROUND BY
SUB.
>> DYLAN WINN 2 --
>> I'LL TYPE IT IN.
>> MAYBE I SHOULD HAVE JUST
BOUGHT THIS PIZZA.
NOT HAD YOU DO IT.
IN HINDSIGHT.
>> DYLAN WINN 2.
WHAT'S HE SAYING?
>> HE'S THE ONE THAT WAS
RECOMMENDING --
>> SHOUT-OUT DYLAN WINN 2,
SOCKS.
>> WE'LL GET SOME SOCKS FOR YOU.
I JUMPED ON DEEBO.
>> AND ALSO, OFF THE RECORD
SHOW, UNDER BETTORS ON GREG
IVORY SAYING, "IN THE ELEMENTS,"
LOOKING PRETTY GOOD.
BEEN A MINUTE.
>> WE HAVEN'T GOT THE BALL YET.
QUARTERBACK'S GOING TO COME OUT.
>> THIS IS WHERE AWARE GOING TO
DIG DOWN DEEP.
>> THIS HINDSIGHT WE SHOULD HAVE
GOTTEN A BUNCH OF WHOPPERS.
>> WE SHOULD HAVE.
>> IT'S A LONG GAME.
>> I WOULDN'T CALL THAT
HINDSIGHT.
>> 20/20.
>> THAT COULD BE THE MOVE FOR
THE JAGUARS GAME.
>> RIGHT.
>> THIS IS HORSE -- SHOULD BE UP
35-0.
>> ABOUT TO GO UP 17-7.
HE'S LIMPING?
NO, HE'S NOT LIMPING.
>> SEVEN MINUTES, 14 PLAYS.
>> I WANT TO GET SOME PLAYER TO
CATCH A PASS ON THIS DRIVE
GOING.
THAT'S A FUN BET.
>> CATCHING THE PASS ON THIS
DRIVE.
>> WHAT ARE THE LINES LIKE?
>> I USED PLUS 200.
>> WATCH THE SLANT.
>> LOCKED.
>> WITH THIS?
THIS NEEDS TO BE LIKE A LONG,
JAM IT DOWN THEIR THROAT TYPE OF
DRIVE.
>> METHODICAL.
>> WE ESTABLISHED WE'RE
FIVE-STAR MEN AND THEY'RE
LOSERS.
>> GOLDEN GODS.
>> YEAH.
>> WHO'S WATCHING ESPN PLUS
RIGHT NOW?
SAYS I'M ON MY STREAMING LIMIT.
YOU KNOW WHAT, I BET K.U. IS
PLAYING ON ESPN PLUS, MAN.
>> PROBABLY.
>> THIS IS THE WORST THING
THAT'S EVER HAPPENED TO ME.
IOWA STATE.
OH, MAN.
>> THAT'S KITTLE.
THAT'S AIYUK.
AIYUK, AIYUK!
AIYUK!
>> LET'S GO, BABY.
>> BOP, BOP.
>> I DON'T KNOW, IS IT POSSIBLE?
>> ON THE GRAPHIC WHERE IT SAYS
THE PARLAY, CAN WE PUT A CHECK
TO THE LEGS THAT HAVE ALREADY
PLAYED?
>> MIGHT BE GOOD.
>> IS THAT POSSIBLE?
I DON'T KNOW.
>> I MEAN, I WOULD SAY NINERS BY
2 1/2.
>> MAKE A GREEN TEXT OR
SOMETHING.
>> I LIKE THE GREEN TEXT.
>> LOVE THAT.
>> NICE.
>> I DON'T LIKE THAT.
KEEP THE BALL IN PURDY'S HANDS.
>> JUST AN IDEA.
>> KEEP THE BALL IN G-13'S HANDS
RIGHT NOW.
>> NO ONE IS GOING TO BE -- I'M
TALKING TO THE PRODUCER, MAX.
>> IT'S UP THERE.
>> WE DID IT THIS.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> I SEE IT.
>> NICE!
>> OKAY, THAT WASN'T THAT HARD.
>> OKAY, OKAY, FAIR, FAIR.
>> THROWING TO McCAFFREY RIGHT
HERE, PERFECT CHECK DOWN.
PERFECT, PERFECT.
>> AIYUK, AIYUK!
>> OVER 6 1/2 YARDS!
>> WHOO!
>> GIVE HIM --
>> DID YOU LOCK THAT IN?
>> EVERY BET WE WON -- HEY, ALSO
TOO --
>> THAT WAS A LOCKDOWN.
WE SHOULD HAVE PUT IT IN THE
PARLAY.
>> DEFINITELY WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED, YEAH.
>> THE STATS WERE --
>> DIDN'T WE DIP OUT OF THE
McCAFFREY RUSHING IN THE FIRST
QUARTER?
>> THERE WAS -- ONCE WE SAW THE
STATS --
>> WE HAD HIM CATCH IN THE LAST
SEVEN WEEKS.
>> STUTTER STEP IN THE ELEMENTS?
>> DID THE LITTLE FAKER, THE
HEALTH HESITATION, HESSY.
>> BROCK PURDY IS WHO -- IS LIKE
WHAT MAJOR AMERICA WANTS JOE
BURROW TO BE.
BROCK PURDY IS JOE COOL.
>> JOE BURROW IS
SIGNIFICANTLY --
>> LET'S GO, BROCK!
>> OH, NO!
>> OH!
>> WHAT WAS THAT?
>> THE RECEIVER CAME BACK.
>> HE'S A ROOKIE, HE'S A ROOKIE,
RECEIVER CAME BACK, BROCK WAS
LOOKING BIG.
>> IN THE ELEMENTS?
>> AIYUK.
>> I KNOW, BUT THEY WERE SHOWING
DEEBO, THE ROUTE WAS SUPPOSED TO
GO TO HIM.
>> HE MUST HAVE FELL.
>> OH, OH MY.
>> BRUTAL.
>> THAT'S -- THAT'S BRUTAL.
>> I LIKE THAT BROCK --
>> HE'S COMMANDING.
>> I DO LIKE THAT.
>> YEAH, RUN.
>> ALSO, YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
MOVE FORWARD IN FRONT OF THE
SNAP.
AIYUK IS BASICALLY CFL SPRINTING
UP THE FIELD BEFORE HE SNAPPED
THE BALL.
>> I DON'T LIKE THIS.
CALL A TIME-OUT, SHANAHAN.
>> HEY.
>> KITTLE, GET UPFIELD, BOY,
YEAH!
>> EASY, EASY.
>> THAT WAS RISKY.
>> EASY.
>> I WOULD HAVE -- MAN.
THAT'S RISKY.
>> PAID OFF.
>> SECOND-BEST TIGHT END IN
FOOTBALL.
>> LET'S GO, BABY.
BROCK PURDY, HE MIGHT BE THE
FIRST.
>> BROCK PURDY BETTER THAN
MAHOMES AND KELCE.
>> I THINK THEY BLEW A SELL, I'M
ASSUMING SOMEONE'S HURT.
>> I HOPE NO ONE'S HURT.
SOMEBODY MIGHT BE HURT BECAUSE
THEY TAKE HECK OF LONG TO GET
BACK TO THE PLAY.
>> MAYBE NOT.
>> SEATTLE PLAYER.
>> SEATTLE.
>> WHOA.
>> OH, WOW.
>> BROCK, BROCK.
>> I MEAN, I'M JUST READING THE
CHAT.
>> THAT IS WHAT THE SIGN SAID.
>> THEIR WORDS, NOT OURS.
>> YEAH.
>> HOW WE FEELING, GUYS?
>> EVERYBODY'S DOWN IN THEIR
PHONES.
>> I WOULD LOVE A NINERS
TOUCHDOWN HERE.
>> DEEBO.
>> THAT CAN MAKE --
>> WHAT IS THE ETA FOR FOOD?
>> AN HOUR?
>> WE'RE SUPPOSED TO GUESS,
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO GUESS.
>> WHAT ARE YOU YELLING AT?
LET'S GO OVER/UNDER.
>> WE HAVE SOMEBODY BRINGING IT
TO US.
SO WE'RE --
>> NO PUNISHMENT.
>> WELL, MAN, FIRST CLASS
SERVICE.
CAN I GET SOME MORE WATER?
>> SHOUT-OUT TO ALLEN.
>> HALFWAY, BRYSON, CAN I ABOUT
IT SOME --
>> CMC, THE STORY, DOING THAT
THING FOR ME WHERE IT DOESN'T DO
IT, THROW A FIRE SLIDER UNDER IT
OR SOMETHING, TAG DRAFT KINGS.
>> ON IT.
>> OH, MAN.
>> WHOPPER, WHOPPER, WHOPPER,
WHOPPER.
>> PAUL GIAMATTI, WHAT DO YOU
THINK OF?
>> THE WIRE, ALWAYS.
>> BFL.
>> THE BLUE SCENE IS LIKE --
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> THAT'S "AVATAR 2:THE WAY OF
WATER."
>> UNREAL.
>> STRUTTING OUT TO IT.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHO SINGS THAT
SONG?
>> NO.
>> FOR $10, CAN YOU NAME WHO
SINGS THAT SONG?
>> WHO SINGS WHICH SONG?
>> "HUNGRY LIKE THE WOLF."
>> LITTLE BABY?
>> CLOSE.
>> TIME LIMIT?
>> 30 SECONDS STARTING RIGHT
NOW.
>> HE'S LOOKING IT UP.
>> CAN YOU GIVE US AN ARROW?
>> SOMEONE IN THE CHAT IS
TELLING YOU.
>> DURAN --
>> DURAN DURAN.
>> DID THEY SAY IT IN THE CHAT?
>> OH, HOLD ON.
>> TIME TO BE REAL.
>> DURAN DURAN.
>> MAX SAID IT IN YOUR EAR.
>> THAT IS NOT TRUE.
>> HOLD ON, HOLD ON, HOLD ON.
YOU OFFER --
>> NO.
>> YOU CHEATED.
>> I AGREE.
>> SO WE JUST -- WE'RE NOT MEN
OF OUR WORD HERE?
>> YOU ARE GOING --
>> CHEATING.
>> HOW DID I CHEAT?
>> ARE YOU A MAN OF INTEGRITY?
>> I AM.
>> SAYS WHO?
>> YOU'RE NOT A FIVE STAR.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
>> YOU'RE LOSING YOUR FIVE STAR.
>> I LITERALLY POSTED SOMETHING
THAT YOU SAID THE OTHER DAY AND
YOU SAID IT WAS PHOTOSHOPPED.
>> IT WAS PHOTOSHOPPED.
>> DEEBO, DEEBO, DEEBO --
>> I SAID NO SUCH THING.
>> WHERE'S MY GUY DILLON WINN 2?
>> DEEBO IN THE BACKFIELD.
>> HE'S WIRED IN.
>> HE'S CHANGING THE PLAY.
TOSS -- OKAY.
>> OH!
>> THAT'S ANOTHER, THAT'S
ANOTHER, THAT'S ANOTHER.
>> TWO, ALL RIGHT.
>> THAT'S ANOTHER.
>> WHAT A PLAY.
THAT LOOKED TERRIBLE, BUT IT WAS
PERFECT EXECUTION.
>> THAT WAS A GREAT PLAY.
>> TELEGRAPHED.
>> THAT LOOKED SCARY.
>> GENO IS GOING TO RUIN
CHRISTMAS FOR EVERYONE.
>> DUDE, IN WHAT WORLD IS GENO
NOT GETTING 30 PASS ATTEMPTS?
>> I THINK WE'RE AT SEVEN.
>> THEY'RE LOSING BY 70.
>> EVERYONE STAY CALM, STAY
CALM.
>> THEY'RE GOING TO RUN THE BALL
TILL THE END OF THE HALF.
>> SHOUT-OUT TO ADAM LEFCO WHO
SAID MY KHAKIS ARE TIGHT.
>> HEY!
>> LEFCO, WHAT DO YOU WANT IN
THIS GAME?
>> LEFCO COMES AND COMMENTS ON
YOUR PANTS?
>> THOSE KHAKIS ARE TIGHT WITH A
LAUGHING FACE.
>> OH!
>> HE DIDN'T MEAN IT LITERALLY.
>> HE MEANT, THOSE THINGS ARE
TIGHT!
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT MY
PANTS?
>> OH, THAT'S TOUGH.
>> THOSE ARE KIND OF TIGHT,
THOUGH, NOT GONNA LIE.
>> AUBURNS THAT YOU'RE WEARING?
>> BIRD DOG, BIRD SOMETHING.
>> THAT'S TOUGH.
>> CAN YOU SQUAT IN THOSE?
>> HE MEANS IT LITERALLY.
>> UP AND DOWN IN THESE.
THEY'RE FLEXIBLE.
>> OH!
>> THEY LOOKED AT HIM FIRST.
>> GET READY, GET RID OF IT.
>> NO!
>> THE SUN IS OUT.
>> SUN'S OUT, YEAH.
>> SUN'S OUT.
>> TRYING TO HIT KITTLE RIGHT
THERE, THAT WASN'T OPEN.
>> DEEBO, FIRST LOOK.
>> THROW TO IT THE GROUND.
>> LEFCO SAID, I MEANT IF YOU
FARTED YOUR SHOES MIGHT POP OFF.
WOW.
GREAT RESPONSE.
>> THAT'S TOUGH.
>> LEFCO, BY THE WAY, NOTICE --
A VERY ODD BRAND, VERY ODD BRAND
FOR PHILADELPHIA.
>> OH, WHAT IS THIS?
>> THEY RUN THE DRAW TO
McCAFFREY.
>> ROBBIE GOULD'S ABOUT TO CASH
THE OVER 2.
>> I LOVE -- I DON'T WANT TO
BRING THIS WITH ME.
>> I REALLY DON'T LIKE THAT
PLAY.
>> TURN IT UP.
>> YEAH.
>> ROBBIE GOLD'S ABOUT TO CATCH
THE OVER 1 1/2.
>> I OVERESTIMATED.
>> WHAT'S THAT BACKDROP?
>> ARE YOU STILL RECOVERING FROM
THAT BURN?
>> I'M PROBABLY NEVER GOING TO
GET OVER THAT.
I DIDN'T NEED TO CALL THAT OUT.
I COULD HAVE LET THAT LIVE IN
THE CHAT, NO ONE WOULD EVER
KNOW.
>> SHOUT-OUT, MALY.
>> THE PANTS THING?
>> YEAH, THE PANTS.
>> SORRY.
>> THEY'RE FLEXIBLE.
>> CMC RUSHING YARDS OVER, CMC
TOUCHDOWN.
>> THEY LOOK TIGHT BECAUSE YOU
HAVE THEM UP TO HERE.
LET THEM HANG, BRO.
>> I CAN SQUAT.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO LET THEM HANG,
BRO.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
WHAT ELSE IS HE SAYING?
LEFCO, I DON'T CARE WHAT YOU'RE
ON ANYMORE, I DON'T.
SINCE YOU DROPPED IT IN HERE,
I'M ON CMC RUSHING YARDS OVER
CMC TOUCHDOWN, CONGRATES AND
CASH, HOOP DEDO.
>> KITTLE TOUCHDOWN.
>> HAVEN'T SEEN THAT MANY ELI
MITCHELL APPEARANCES, WHICH IS
GOOD.
>> NOT GREAT FOR MY BET.
>> ELI DOESN'T GET STARTED TILL
THE SECOND HALF.
>> MINE ARE PROBABLY TIGHTER
THAN YOURS.
>> HE'S A LITTLE BANGED UP.
>> YOU LOST THREE YARDS ON THE
CARRIES.
>> THAT'S LIKE GOLF, THESE ARE
LIKE GOLF PANTS.
>> THAT'S PRETTY GOOD.
>> YEAH.
>> THIS IS THICKER MATERIAL.
BUT ALSO --
>> WE'RE NOT DOING GREAT IN THE
RUSHING DEPARTMENT.
>> NO.
>> SQUAT-OFFS.
>> SHALL WE SQUAT?
>> YEAH.
>> WHAT WAS THE RUSHING YARDS
OVER FOR LEFCO?
>> FOR KITTLE?
>> FOR McCAFFREY.
>> DOWN 6 WITH 2 1/2 TO GO.
>> YOU'RE STANDING IN THE WAY,
BY THE WAY.
>> NOT GREAT.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE RUSHING
YARDS OVER/UNDER WAS FOR
McCAFFREY?
>> 165 PLUS.
>> 65, YEAH.
>> I CAN'T REMEMBER WHO, I THINK
IT WAS YOU THAT PASSED ON IT.
>> WHO?
>> YOU.
>> HOW MANY RECEPTIONS --
>> WE SENT RECEPTIONS.
>> I THINK WHEN EVERYONE
LEAVES --
>> IT'S THE NERVES.
>> WHAT IS HE ON?
YEAH.
>> DID WE MISS A FIELD GOAL?
>> YEAH.
>> ON AN EVEN NUMBER.
>> IT WON'T STAY LIKE THIS.
>> LEFKOW SAYS GREG IS RIGHT,
MITCHELL IS A GREAT LIVE BET
RIGHT NOW.
TO SCORE.
>> I STILL HAVE MY DEEBO WET,
I'M RIDING WITH THAT.
>> WILL YOU CONFIRM THAT I WAS
RIGHT?
>> I'M SAYING, YOU'VE GOT
SUPPORT.
>> HEAD OF COIS GOING FOR THE
JACKPOT.
>> CAN YOU TELL IF MY MIC'S BACK
ON?
THANK YOU.
>> WHAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> LOOK AT PASSER RATINGS BY
BROCK.
HE'S INCREDIBLE.
>> BOSA GOT TO WAKE UP.
HE NEEDS TO PLAY LIKE THE
DEFENSIVE PLAYER OF THE YEAR.
>> I GOT AN IDEA.
NINERS, FIVE YARDS -- NOT
NINERS.
SEAHAWKS, FIVE YARDS AT A TIME.
PICK SIX IN THE END ZONE.
>> I LIKE IT.
>> WE GET LIKE SEVEN PASSES AND
A PICK SIX, WE ALL WIN, EXCEPT
RYAN WITH HIS --
>> I DON'T LOVE THAT, TO BE
HONEST.
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT WE ALL WIN.
>> PLUS 11 1/2 IS NOT GREAT.
>> PARLAY, YES.
>> OH, WHOA!
>> THAT FELT AGAINST THE RULES,
MAN.
>> HE DOESN'T TRIP, MAN.
>> YEAH, THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
REALLY BAD.
>> IF YOU HAVE A McCAFFREY
RUSHING OVER, IT'S AT 72 RIGHT
NOW.
HE'S AT 72 RIGHT NOW.
IT WAS 74 1/2.
>> HE'S ALREADY AT 72?
>> YEAH, WHICH IS KIND OF --
>> FOUR RUSHES.
>> ON FOUR RUSHES.
>> THAT ONE, THAT ONE --
>> YEAH.
>> 60, HIT THE BOOST, WE HIT THE
BOOST.
>> GOING TO --
>> HERE WE GO.
WE GOT THE --
>> WE NEED TO GET A SPONSOR,
WATER, SPONSOR OUR SHOW WITH
DRAFT KINGS SO WE CAN USE THEIR
WATER AND I CAN HAVE A NEW
SUPPLY OF WATER.
>> D.K., IT'S GOING TO BE A
PASS --
>> LET'S GO.
>> OH!
>> WHOO, I LIKE THAT, I LIKE
THAT.
>> 7.
>> I LIKE THAT HINGE, RIGHT?
LIKE THAT.
>> THREE AND OUT, NINERS
TOUCHDOWN, GET TWO-MINUTE DRILL
GINO TO DRIVE DOWN THE FIELD.
SIX PASSES, SEVEN PASSES.
>> HOW ARE WE AT SEVEN PASSES,
MAN?
>> SHOUT-OUT TO RAHIM, WHO WANTS
US TO START BUILDING --
>> MY BOY RAHIM?
MLG RAHIM?
>> I HAVE NO -- RAHIM 42?
WE CAN'T EVEN HIT FIVE.
HE WANTED NINE LEG.
>> THE STRAIGHT BETS ARE NOT.
>> WE CAN'T HIT FIVE --
>> OH!
>> NICE.
>> LET'S GO!
>> HEY, HEY, HEY.
>> SEAHAWKS.
>> DUDE, THIS IS --
SEAHAWKS.
>> FLY TOGETHER RESERVE.
>> WE DIDN'T THINK THIS GAME --
>> WE'VE GOT TO DO THE BIRDS ARE
ALWAYS SUNNY.
>> THIS IS OUR THIRD TIME
PLAYING THEM.
>> ALL RIGHT, YEAH.
>> WE'RE GOING TO NEED 40,
RIGHT?
>> 45.
>> 13 YARDS ON TWO CATCHES,
THAT'S WILD.
>> COME ON.
>> NICE.
>> DON'T NEED THAT.
>> THAT WAS AN ILLEGAL SHIFT.
WALKER IS WALKING FORWARD.
>> YEAH, THEY'RE SLIDING ON THAT
TURF.
>> RAT PANTS NOW IS THE NEW
NICKNAME, RAT PANTS.
>> NOT RAT PANTS.
>> OH, MAN.
>> HE LIPPING, THAT'S A GOOD
THING.
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
KENNETH WALKER IS LIMPING.
>> WHOA, WHOA, WHOA!
>> MELLY SAID, I KNOW GREG'S
CHAIR IS UNCOMFORTABLE, CAN YOU
CONFIRM, GREG THIS.
>> YEAH, IT IS KIND OF
UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> GET UP!
>> OH, YEAH!
>> RIGHT HERE.
ONE PLAY, ONE STOP.
>> BOSA, GET UP, BOSA.
>> RIGHT HERE.
>> LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> YOU'RE TALKING TO ME ABOUT
THIRD AND 3.
>> IT'S A MONSTER DOG PLAY.
>> I'M TELLING YOU GRAB PANTS.
>> THIS IS IT.
>> COME ON, BOSA.
>> PLAY LIKE A DEFENSIVE PLAYER
OF THE YEAR.
>> BALL COMING BACK.
>> GO GET HIM, BOSA.
>> WATCH 29, WATCH 29 UP TOP.
>> PICK SIX.
PICK SIX WOULD BE SO BEAUTIFUL
HERE.
>> NO DELAY OF GAME?
>> GET THAT.
>> D.K.!
D.K.!
WHOO!
LET'S GO!
MONSTER DON TOUCHDOWN.
>> LET'S GO, LET'S GO!
>> SO BAD.
IT'S OVER.
>> FLY TOGETHER, BABY.
>> LET'S GO.
>> WOW.
>> WHOO!
>> TURN YOUR MIC ON, GREG.
>> HOW ABOUT THAT!
WOW.
>> HOW ABOUT THEM SEAHAWKS?
>> WOW.
>> YEAH, D.K. RECEPTIONS?
>> YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
>> DID I CASH IT?
NO.
>> SHOULD HAVE BEEN THREE.
>> OH, MAN.
WE'RE GOING TO NEED 21 PASS
ATTEMPTS FROM GENO SMITH THE
SECOND HALF.
>> AND THE CLOSER THIS GAME
IS --
>> YEAH.
>> I DON'T KNOW, IF THEY'RE
GOING TO KEEP LEAVING HIM OPEN
LIKE THAT, THAT WAS HUGE.
THAT WAS HUGE.
>> WHAT'S THE --
>> 65-1.
NOT GOING TO BE 31-10 TODAY.
>> IF WE CAN GET A NICE LITTLE
CLOSEUP OF SAM'S FACE RIGHT NOW,
I THINK THE AUDIENCE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THAT.
>> IT'S OVER.
>> I JUST WANT TO SAY SOMETHING
TO YOU, BRO.
IMAGINE IF YOU'D TAKEN FIRST
HALF MONEY LINE.
THAT WAS LOOKING GOOD.
>> WE SHOULD HAVE.
>> SHOULD HAVE, COULD HAVE,
WOULD HAVE.
>> WE'RE NOT GOING TO LIVE IN
THAT WORLD, BRYCE.
>> THAT'S ONE OF MY FAVORITE
THINGS TO DO IN COLLEGE
BASKETBALL, A HEAVY FAVORITE
GOES DOWN EARLY, THE LIFELINE IS
NOT THAT GOOD.
THE FIRST HALF LIVE MONEY LINE
WILL BE LIKE PLUS 500.
>> HOW DO WE LOSE TO THE --
SEAHAWKS?
>> YEAH.
-- YEAH.
>> OH, MAN.
>> TOUGH TO BEAT A TEAM THREE
TIMES.
>> WHAT DO WE SAY?
WE SAID THAT, RIGHT?
>> MY TOTAL, 42 1/2.
I DID NOT NEED THAT.
>> THAT WAS A DIME.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT WAS BEAUTIFUL.
>> ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY'VE
ESTABLISHED THE RUN.
THIS HAS BEEN ALL SEASON.
RUN, RUN, RUN, BOMB TO LOCKETT.
>> LOOK AT THAT.
>> I DIDN'T THINK THEY WOULD
ESTABLISH THAT.
>> AND TO THEIR CREDIT, THEY
DIDN'T ABANDON THE RUN AFTER THE
FIRST TWO DISASTERS.
>> HAPPY PETE CARROLL.
>> THIS IS RIGHT -- PLAYING
RIGHT INTO HIS HANDS.
>> WE DID TALK ABOUT THIS,
THOUGH.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON THAT EITHER
MONEY LINE PARLAY OF
NINERS/BILLS, OR THEY TEASED IT
AND WE SAID NO CHANCE.
>> YEAH.
>> AND THIS IS -- IT'S GOING TO
BE RIGHT OFF THE BAT.
EVERYONE'S GOING TO LOSE RIGHT
OFF THE BAT.
>> THE BOOKS WILL COOK EVERYONE
EVERYBODY'S GOING TO CHASE THE
COWBOYS ON MONDAY.
>> ROBBIE GOULD FOR THE WIN.
>> UNBELIEVABLE.
>> NOT GREAT.
>> GIVE ME A QUICK TOUCHDOWN
HERE.
>> SAM HAS PREGAME?
OH, WOW.
NOW NINERS --
>> IS THAT THE RIGHT TIME FOR ME
TO REMIND PEOPLE --
>> NO.
>> THAT I HAVE A NINERS FUTURE?
>> ALL RIGHT, COME ON, DUDE.
>> IT'S KIND OF CHILLY.
>> OUR DEFENSE ISN'T PLAYING
LIKE --
>> THIS SEEMS TO BE THE LAST
POSSESSION OF THE HALF.
>> BROCK KNOWS HOW TO RUN A FOUR
MINUTE --
>> BROCK PURDY'S NOT PLAYING --
>> OUR DEFENSE ISN'T PLAYING
LIKE THE NUMBER ONE DEFENSE.
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN FOR THE LAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS.
THE FIRST TWO DRIVES, ALL RIGHT,
THEY'RE DOING IT.
THEN THEY GOT --
>> AND WE GOT TO SCORE
TOUCHDOWNS, NOT FIELD GOALS.
>> I AGREE.
>> I DON'T LIKE THAT.
>> YUCK.
>> THIS COULD BE REALLY -- OH,
THIS IS --
>> I MEAN, IF WE HAVE TO PUNT
AND THE SEAHAWKS GET THE LAST
HALF, THAT WOULD BE REALLY BAD.
>> I AM GOING TO GO UNHINGED ON
KYLE SHANAHAN SHORTLY.
I USUALLY RESERVE THAT UNTIL HE
CHOKES AWAY AN NFC CHAMPIONSHIP
GAME.
BUT I AM SO SICK AND TIRED OF
HEARING ABOUT HOW GOOD A COACH
KYLE SHANAHAN IS, A GURU.
>> HE IS A REALLY, REALLY GOOD
COACH.
>> I DON'T CARE.
>> THEY'RE ON THEIR THIRD STRING
QUARTERBACK AND THEY'RE THE BEST
TEAM IN THE LEAGUE.
>> GET THE JOB DONE.
>> I HEAR YOU.
>> I ALSO HEAR SAM TOO, HE IS A
GOOD COACH.
BUT I HEAR YOU.
>> THIS IS THE GAME.
>> COME ON, BROCK.
I FEEL CONFIDENT WHEN THE BALL
IS IN HIS --
>> OH!
>> LET'S GO!
>> HA HA!
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> THIS IS BAD.
>> DO WE START TO ENVISION THE
REALITY WHERE TOM BRADY --
>> YOU STOP IT!
>> OH, NO.
>> IS A 49er --
>> OH, A 49er.
I THOUGHT YOU MEANT --
>> HE'S GOING TO BE A FREE
AGENT.
>> WHOA, WHOA.
>> WE'RE GOING TO SAVE THAT
CONVERSATION.
>> SHOUT-OUT.
>> WE WERE ON THE SAME SIDE FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN MAYBE HUMAN
HISTORY.
AND THIS IS THE VIBES YOU WANT
TO BRING RIGHT NOW.
>> I MEAN, LISTEN.
>> FAKE IT.
>> I'M JUST THINKING AHEAD, ALL
RIGHT, RYAN?
>> STAKE IT.
>> YOU'RE THE ONE WHO'S --
YOU'VE GOT ALL THIS PENT-UP
BETTING HISTORY.
>> THAT'S ON THE DEFENSE.
>> HOW ABOUT YOUR COWBOYS?
>> DID YOU GET ON NINERS THIS.
>> NO.
>> WHAT ARE YOU UPSET ABOUT?
>> NOTHING, I JUST NEED TO GO
UNDER.
>> YEAH, THAT'S TRUE, YEAH.
YOU DO, YEAH.
>> I DON'T NEED THIS TO BE A
CLOSE GAME.
>> ALSO, UNDERRATED RIGHT NOW,
NINERS MINUS 2 1/2 IN OUR PARLAY
IS GETTING COOKED.
>> YO, RYAN.
>> THAT WOULD SUCK.
>>> YO, WHAT'S GOING ON, MAN?
>> EVERYTHING IS OVER.
>> TIME OUT.
>> I SAW THAT.
>> YOU HAVE A FUTURES BET ON THE
49ers TO WIN THE CHAMPIONSHIP.
>> YES.
>> THAT'S GOING TO MAKE YOU MORE
MONEY THAN THE BET THAT YOU
PLACED TODAY.
>> IT'S GOING TO MAKE ME A LOT
OF MONEY, YOU'RE RIGHT.
A LOT OF MONEY.
>> YET YOU'RE HAPPY THAT THE
49ers AREN'T ABOUT TO WIN --
>> WE'RE GOING TO STOP HIM HERE.
>> OH, I WOULDN'T SAY I'M HAPPY
THE 49ers ARE LOSING.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO COMMIT TO THE
PLAY.
>> I WOULD SAY I'M HAPPY THE
SEAHAWKS ARE COVERING.
THERE'S NO WAY THE NINERS DON'T
WIN THIS GAME.
RIGHT, SAM?
>> 0%?
>> 0% CHANCE THE NINERS DON'T
WIN.
>> IT'S LOOKING GOOD, GOT THE
STREAM UP.
COMMUNITY'S LOOKING FOR MBA
LOCKS.
>> MBA LOCKS?
>> IMAGINE LOOKING FOR MBA LOCKS
ON SUPER LOCK SATURDAY.
>> COULD BE US.
>> COULD NOT BE.
21 MORE PASSES, HONESTLY, I CAN
LIVE WITH THIS.
THEY'RE GOING TO RUN THE BALL
FIRST PLAY.
GIVE ME A FALSE START OR
SOMETHING, A HOLD.
>> WE NEED SOME PASS ATTEMPTS,
COME ON.
>> THE HIGHLIGHT RUN.
>>> HOW WE FEELING?
VIBE CHECK.
>> WE'RE GOOD, WE'RE GOOD, GOOD
VIBES.
>> IT'S OVER.
>> WE'RE GOOD, GOOD VIBES.
>> D.K.!
>> CASH IT, RYAN, GEEZ.
>> JUST RAN THAT BOY OVER.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THAT WAS
FOUR, HOLD ON, HOLD ON.
>> I THINK FOUR.
>> WAS THAT FIVE?
>> JESUS.
PAST 24 HOURS, I FOUND OUT TOO
MUCH ABOUT RYAN, MAN.
THAT WAS THE FINAL STRAW.
>> IS THAT NOISE?
>> NO, THAT WAS HIS FOURTH.
ONE MORE, ONE MORE.
THE BEST BET, IT WAS ALWAYS
GOING TO HIT.
THE BEST BET.
COME ON, ONE MORE.
>> GET OFF THE TRACKS WHEN THE
TRAIN IS COMING THROUGH.
>> DO YOU WANT TO CONFIRM?
ELI MITCHELL?
>> RAN THE BALL TWICE.
>> ELI HAS --
>> THEY'RE SAYING --
>> NEGATIVE YARDS.
HE DROVE IT -- BUT THAT WAS A
RECEPTION, I THINK.
>> TACKLE!
THANK YOU.
>> NEGATIVE 4 RUSHING.
>> OKAY, OKAY.
>> BAD BEAT.
>> WHOA ARE WHOA, WHOA, WHOA!
>> ONLY 42 TO GO.
>> ARE THEY SAYING A RED?
>> HEY, HEY, HEY.
PLAY WITH PASSION.
CALM DOWN, BROTHER.
TAKE A DEEP BREATH.
>> ALL RIGHT, WE'RE OKAY.
IT'S NOT OVER.
>> YO, GREG, WHAT ARE YOUR
INSIDE SOURCES ON THE NINERS?
WHAT ARE THEY SAYING RIGHT NOW?
I NEED SOME VIBES.
>> MAN.
I DON'T KNOW, BRO.
THE WAY THEY'RE RUNNING THE
BALL, I DON'T LIKE IT.
>> THEY LET D.K. GO DEEP LIKE
THAT?
THAT'S BAD, THAT'S NOT GOOD
VIBES.
>> IT'S OVER.
JACKHAM, D.K. PUSHING WARD RIGHT
NOW.
>> WHAT IS HE DOING?
ONE OF THE BEST IN THE LEAGUE,
GETTING DESTROYED.
>> THE ATTEMPTS AT TACKLING ARE
JUST --
>> YEAH.
>> THIS IS A SAD PREMISE.
SAD.
>> D.K. WAS DUE FOR SURE.
>> IF I CAN CASH THIS D.K.
RECEPTIONS BET BY HALFTIME, I
MEAN --
>> YOU'RE FEELING GOOD?
>> NO, I'D BE FEELING GREAT.
I'D BE FEELING GREAT.
GREAT.
>> DID YOU HEAR THE WHOPPER
COMMERCIAL?
>> SHOULD WE GET THE SPREADSHEET
UP TO SEE HOW WE'RE TRACKING?
>> LET'S DO IT.
RITTER, YOU --
>> IT'S DONE.
>> DEEBO, NEXT TD --
>> I KNOW YOU'RE NOT COMPLETELY
DONE.
>> LOGAN.
>> CAN WE GRADE THIS?
CAN WE GRADE THIS?
>> IT'S OVER.
>> NO, IT'S OVER.
>> HOW MANY RECEPTIONS --
>> YOU'VE LOST.
>> I DID CMC.
>> KENNY WALKER, LET'S GET A
GREEN OVER THERE.
>> REDS UP THERE ALREADY.
>> LET'S GET A GREEN BEAN NEXT
TO KENNETH WALKER --
>> YOU READ OUT NINERS TO WIN
THE SUPER BOWL SINCE THAT'S
ALREADY LOST?
>> NO, I HAVE IT IN MY NAME TOO.
>> I MEAN, IT'S OVER.
>> WE'RE STILL FINE, SAM.
WE'RE GOING TO WIN.
>> IT'S OVER.
EVERYTHING IS OVER.
>> I HAVE TELL TOTAL.
TEAM TOTAL.
>> FIRST DRIVE WAS A PUNT, MAN.
>> DYLAN WINN IS TRYING TO TALK
IT OUT.
>> THAT PUNT IS INCREDIBLE.
>> DID THE NINERS DEFENSE LOOK
SO GOOD.
>> BROCK PURDY IS A SECOND HALF
BEEN.
HE HAS SO MUCH CONFIDENCE, HE'S
ABOUT TO SHOW IT.
>> I'M NOT WORRIED.
>> NEITHER AM I.
OUR 49ers GUYS ARE GOING TO WIN.
>> 49ers VIBES?
>> IT'S OVER.
>> THOSE AREN'T GENUINE VIBES.
>> YEAH, I MEAN --
>> THOSE AREN'T GENUINE.
>> WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT?
I MEAN, DON'T MAKE ME DO THIS.
>> THIS IS A HUGE --
>> YOU'RE BEING THAT GUY RIGHT
NOW.
THERE'S NOTHING WORSE THAN THAT
GUY.
THAT'S THE GUY.
>> DRAWING YOUR NEGATIVE VIBES
OVER INTO THIS REALM.
>> PICK SIXES WOULD BE SO EASY.
>> THERE'S NO NEGATIVE VIBES.
LET'S GO!
GET IT!
>> THAT'S BIG, SAM, THAT'S BIG.
>> TIMEOUT, CALL TIME-OUT, I
WANT THE BALL BACK.
CALL TIME-OUT.
>> KYLE SHANAHAN DOES THAT WEIRD
STUFF, BRO.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> WE'RE GOOD, THOUGH.
WE'RE GOOD, WE GOT ROBBIE GOULD.
>> SHOULD HAVE BEEN A FOUR YARD.
>> YEAH, ROBBIE WALK-OFF.
>> WE'RE ONLY GOING TO NEED 19
PASSES IN THE SECOND HALF.
THAT'S DOABLE, I GUESS.
>> THIS IS IT.
EVERYTHING IN FRONT OF US RIGHT
NOW.
>> GO GET 'EM.
>> ONE PLAY.
>> D.K., THIS WOULD BE SO BIG.
>> PLAY UNTIL 1 SECOND ON THE
CLOCK AND THEY MIGHT RUN IT.
>> I'M UP, COME ON!
>> D.K., BOTTOM OF THE SCREEN.
D.K.
>> I TOLD YOU THEY'RE GOING TO
RUN IT.
>> BOSA.
TIME-OUT, TIME-OUT, TIME-OUT,
TIME-OUT!
>> HE CALLED IT.
>> THIS IS CLASSIC.
>> HE BURKED IT.
>> WHAT A --
>> CLASSIC.
>> WE'RE TRYING TO WIN THIS
GAME.
>> CLASSIC.
>> THIS IS -- I'M -- HE WANTS TO
WIN PLAYING LIKE THIS.
THE PASS ATTEMPTS, IT'S DEAD.
>> THAT'S A HORRENDOUS --
>> YOU WANT TO WIN, HERE WE
ARE --
>> THIS IS HOW WE GET PASS
ATTEMPTS BACK.
WE GET A FIELD GOAL, UP TWO,
SCORE A TOUCHDOWN FIRST TIME IN
THE SECOND HALF, THAT WAY --
>> WHAT ARE WE AT?
10?
>> OH MY GOD.
HERE'S WHAT THEY ARE.
>> THE PASS ATTEMPTS, THE 49ers
MINUS 2 1/2.
>> OH, STOP IT.
>> WHY ARE YOU WHISPERING?
>> YOU'RE WHISPERING INTO A LIVE
MIC.
>> I DON'T WANT TO BE ACCUSED OF
BAD VIBES.
>> YOU HAD THE 49er FUTURE.
>> LOCK THIS.
>> IT AS LITTLE --
>> TURNING INTO A NINERS --
>> HE HAS THE 49er FUTURE, HE'S
OVER THERE MAKING -- THE MINUS
2 1/2 --
>> I'M JUST SAYING IT DOESN'T
LOOK GREAT.
>> THE REAL QUESTION IS --
>> THEY DO PASS ATTEMPTS AGAIN?
>> NO, DUDE, THE GUY IN THE
CHAT --
>> YOU PUSHED THAT OUT THERE --
>> LOOK AT THE CHAT.
>> WE'VE GOT TO KEEP THE VIBES
UP.
I DON'T WANT TO BE THAT GUY,
KEEP THE VIBES UP.
>> SWITCH SPOTS.
>> I'M TELLING YOU.
WE GET RIGHT HERE, WE SCORE
BEFORE THE FIRST DRIVE OF THE
SECOND HALF --
>> McCAFFREY, THOUGH, McCAFFREY.
>> LET'S GO!
LET'S GO!
>> LOOKS GREAT.
LET'S GET SEVEN, EIGHT.
>> THREE IS FINE.
>> EIGHT.
>> STAY ODD.
>> I NEED A WEEKEND AID CONTROL.
>> THEY GET THE BALL AT HALF.
>> HEY, I THINK THAT TOOK ME
OVER MY -- RYAN, CAN WE LOOK AT
THE --
>> I WENT OVER, TRIED TO
CELEBRATE --
>> I GOT OVER -- I DON'T KNOW.
>> THEY'RE DOING SOME SHADY --
BACK THIS.
>> YEAH, NO --
>> YOU DO YOU.
>> WE'RE NOT WORRIED, SAM.
>> HEY, HEY.
>> THEY MIGHT ACTUALLY KILL ME.
>> I FEEL LIKE WE'RE BLOCKING
EVERYBODY ELSE, WHO CARES.
SEAHAWKS GUYS ARE IRRELEVANT
RIGHT NOW.
>> WE'RE GOOD, WE'RE ALL GOOD.
>> McCAFFREY, McCAFFREY!
>> 6 SECONDS THERE.
>> HE LIKE PAT MAHOMES BACK
THERE.
>> OH, STOP IT.
>> YES, THEY BOTH PLAY THE
QUARTERBACK POSITION, ONLY
SIMILARITY.
>> WELL, BOTH HAVE OVER 100
PASSER RATINGS IN THEIR FIRST
FIVE CREW STARTS.
>> LET THEM KNOW, SAM, LET THEM
KNOW.
>> YOU NEED THREE.
>> BOTH LOST A LOT OF GUYS.
>> THAT'S WHERE WE'RE AT.
IT WENT FROM IT'S DEAD, IT'S
OVER, TO COMPARING HIM TO
MAHOMES.
>> I MEAN --
>> NO, I AGREE.
>> SO AM I.
>> YOU'RE NOT WRONG.
>> I AGREE, HE IS PATRICK
MAHOMES.
>> THANK YOU.
>> COME ON, COME ON.
>> DAK ISN'T.
>> NO, DAK IS NOT, NOWHERE NEAR.
>> TOO MUCH OF THAT.
>> LOCK IN, BRO.
>> HE DOES NOT HAVE IT TODAY.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO LOCK IN.
THIS IS THE PLAYOFFS.
>> HE DOES NOT HAVE IT.
>> GET THE SMALL SEED.
>> LOCK IN BRO.
HE'S PLAY LIKE HE'S AT IOWA OR
SOMETHING.
>> I DIDN'T WANT ANY PART --
>> LOCK IN, BRO.
>> DUDE, HE HAD HIM.
>> SUCH A BAD THROW.
>> I GET IT.
>> LOSING GOING TO HALF
AGAINST --
>> I THINK IT'S A GOOD POINT
TOO.
BUT ALSO ALSO THE SUN IS OUT.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO MAKE A PLAY
NOW, 13.
>> YOU HAD THE EXCUSE FIRST
QUARTER.
>> OH MY GOD, OH MY GOD.
>> SAMUELS.
>> DUDE.
>> HUGE PLAY, HUGE PLAY.
>> LET'S GO.
>> WHEN THE NINERS WIN THE SUPER
BOWL, WE'LL LOOK BACK AT THAT AS
THE PLAY THAT CHANGED IT ALL.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO LOCK IN, THIS
ISN'T IOWA.
>> STTHAT IS SUCH A BIG PLAY.
>> IMAGINE THAT OFFENSIVE WEAPON
ON THAT TEAM --
>> AT 10-0 I WAS --
>> RAY, YOU WERE MAKING JOKES.
COMPARE MAHOMES AND PURDY'S
NUMBERS IN THEIR FIRST COUPLE OF
GAMES.
>> THAT'S AN IRRELEVANT STAT,
THOUGH.
>> I'M JUST SAYING.
>> GET RID OF IT, THROW, THROW,
THROW!
>> ROOKIE MOVES.
ROOKIE, ROOKIE, ROOKIE.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> THREW IT AWAY.
>> I GOT MY BAND-AID, THANK YOU.
>> YOU GOT SUSHI?
>> HE'S GOT TO KNOW WHEN TO BAIL
ON PLAYS.
>> IT'S OVER.
>> THAT IS A BIG 12 QUARTERBACK
PLAY.
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT --
>> AT LEAST HE THREW IT AWAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> OH!
>> WHOA!
>> HE GOT ATTACKED.
>> WHAT THAT IS?
>> SHOULD BE 15.
>> FLAG.
>> I DON'T WANT TO BE A
CONTRARIAN BUT THAT LOOKED
CLEAN.
>> HONEST, YOU'RE A GUY OF
INTEGRITY, I LIKE YOU.
>> I DON'T LIKE --
>> A MAN OF INTEGRITY.
>> WE'RE OVER SEVEN.
>> SOMETIMES THEY CALL THAT
THERE.
>> I DON'T THINK INTEGRITY IS
SOMETHING YOU HAVE A LITTLE OF.
YOU EITHER HAVE IT OR YOU DON'T.
BAKED INTO YOUR DNA.
>> SIDELINE, DOWN ON THE GROUND.
>> A MAN OF INTEGRITY, I LIKE
THAT VINCE.
>> WHAT ARE WE --
>> AMUSING.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE INTEGRITY.
>> THIS IS WHY THE BUCS ARE A
GREAT PLAY.
>> ARE YOU DOING THIS NOW?
>> FIRST DRIVE OF THE SECOND
HALF --
>> I DIDN'T HAVE TO SAY
ANYTHING --
>> YES.
>> 37 THOUGH, SAM.
>> NO TIME-OUTS?
WHAT HAPPENED TO OUR TIME-OUTS?
>> TALKING WITH TOM.
>> THE BIG, YEAH.
>> THAT'S HUGE.
>> ALL RIGHT, TE HAVEN'T SHOWED
BROCK'S PARENTS ALL GAME, I WAS
WORRIED THEY WEREN'T THERE.
WE'RE BACK NOW.
>> GET RID OF IT, GET RID OF IT!
>> HE'S MAKING TIME A FACTOR.
>> OH MY GOD, WHOO.
>> HE'S GOOD, HE'S WASTING TIME.
I DON'T LIKE HE ROLLS TO THE
LEFT EVERY TIME.
>> HE ROLLS THE WRONG WAY.
>> MOCK USED TO ROLL THE WRONG
WAY.
>> I WOULD HAND IT OFF, GET SIX
YARDS, A FIELD GOAL.
>> THE FIELD GOAL.
>> TAKE THE SACK.
>> NO TIME-OUTS.
>> SO CLUELESS.
>> CHECKED OUT ON McCAFFREY.
>> AIN'T GOT NO TIME-OUTS.
>> PLEASE, GOD, NO.
>> IF WE CHECK DOWN, WE'VE GOT
TO RUN ON THE FIELD AND KICK DID
FIELD GOAL, NO TIMEOUTS.
>> A FIRE DRILL FIELD GOAL
COMING.
>> 23 SECONDS IS NOT FIRE DRILL,
THERE'S TIME.
>> WE'VE GOT A DELAY OF GAME, DO
NOT GET A DELAY OF GAME HERE.
>> McCAFFREY.
>> WATCH OUT.
>> GO!
OH!
>> WHAT A PLAY.
>> DEEBO ALMOST HAD THAT BOY.
GO KICK IT.
MAN, WE NEED TOUCHDOWNS, WE NEED
TOUCHDOWNS, WE NEED TOUCHDOWNS.
>> YEAH, I DON'T KNOW, THE
CONDITION --
>> THIS WALL, IT DOESN'T --
>> UNLESS THE GRASS --
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S REAL.
I DON'T THINK IT'S REAL.
I REALLY DON'T.
>> IS THERE A WIND CHECK?
CAN WE DOPPLER THAT?
>> THAT WAS A TODDY, BRO.
>> SEE WHAT THE CHAT IS SAYING
BEFORE WE GET INTO HALFTIME.
>> HEY, SAM.
>> HEY!
>> HE SAYS GOOD.
>> HONESTLY.
>> THAT'S BIG.
>> GOOD AS GOLD.
>> RIGHT ON.
>> LET'S GO.
>> GOOD AS GOLD, BABY.
>> THAT'S HUGE, HUGE.
>> IS OUR PIZZA HERE YET?
>> SO HUNGRY.
>> BANG BANK NINER GAME.
>> EXCUSE ME, BROTHER.
>> BANG BANG NINER GAME.
>> THAT LINE TOTAL HURT ME.
>> SEAHAWKS COVERING, NINERS
WINNING, THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT I
WANTED.
I EXPLAINED THE SITUATION TO
YOU.
>> STRESSING ME OUT, GUYS.
>> BROCK PITT, PURDY'S RUINING
MY --
>> RUN IS OVER.
>> I DON'T LIKE CONTINUOUSLY
SETTING --
>> WHY BRETT SO ICED?
I DON'T KNOW WHO THAT IS.
HE'S SO ICED ON THE SIDELINES.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> IT WOULD BE REALLY GOOL IF
GENO SMITH THREW THE BALL.
HE'S NOT GOING TO BUT IT WOULD
BE COOL.
GET A DECENT RETURN TO THE 45,
THAT WAY YOU HAVE --
>> OH MY GOD.
>> I DON'T LIKE THAT AT ALL.
>> I LOVE THAT, I LOVE THAT, I
LOVE THAT.
>> GO DOWN!
OH!
>> NOW THEY GET -- OH!
>> WE HAVE THREE TIME-OUTS.
>> WE HAD THREE TIME-OUTS?
>> WE'RE GOOD.
>> PASS ATTEMPTS, PASS ATTEMPTS,
PASS ATTEMPTS.
>> WE'RE GOOD, WE'RE GOOD.
>> IF ANYTHING --
>> WE'RE GOING TO GET AT LEAST
TWO MORE.
>> THE HAIL MARY IS WHAT I'M
SCARED OF.
>> NO, WE NEED LOCKETT.
>> WE DON'T CARE ABOUT YOUR
PROPERTY.
>> WE NEED LOCKETT.
PASS TEAMS AND LOCKETT.
>> BANG BANG NINER GAME.
>> HONESTLY, AN INCOMPLETE PASS,
THEN A CHUCK OF THE BALL --
>> HE'S A BETTING CHAMELEON.
NAVIGATING HIS WAY IN AND OUT OF
EVERYONE'S --
>> I DON'T LIKE IT.
>> RAT.
>> HE IS RATTING.
HEAVY RAT STUFF.
>> THIS SUCKS.
>> A LITTLE SNAKEY IS ALL.
>> HERE WE GO.
GO GET 'EM, 97.
>> THIS IS WHERE WE GET THAT
SACK.
>> D.K., OH!
OH!
>> OH, OH!
>> OH MY GOD --
>> OH MY GOD.
OH --
>> JIMMIE WARD, WHY WOULD YOU DO
THAT?
>> IT'S STILL 50 PLUS.
55.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> THAT WAS LITERALLY THE
WORST -- LIKE IF YOU'RE GOING TO
LIST OFF ALL THE THINGS THAT
COULD HAVE HAPPENED ON THAT
PLAY, THAT IS THE WORST POSSIBLE
SCENARIO.
>> IT WAS SO -- SEAHAWK NATION
JUST -- WE'RE ALIVE AND WELL.
>> WORST POSSIBLE SCENARIO.
>> WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT, BRO?
SO UNNECESSARY.
>> IMAGINE YOU GRABS SEAHAWKS
LIVE MONEY LINE PLUS 10,000, 2
SECONDS AGO.
>> THAT'S WHY YOU DON'T -- THEY
>> ANYTHING BUT RUNNING THE BALL
THERE --
>> HEY, GUYS, YOU KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE PLAYING IN.
THEY'RE PLAYING IN THE ELEMENTS.
>> NO WAY.
NO WAY.
BRO, HE'S KICKING FROM THE LOGO.
PEOPLE DON'T DO THAT IN SANTA
CLARA, I'M TELLING YOU.
THERE'S OCEAN BREEZE.
>> SO THIS WOULD BE THE FIRST
TIME --
>> THERE'S STORM SURGE.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> AM I HEARING THAT RIGHT?
>> THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN IN SANTA
CLARA?
HAS IT EVER HAPPENED BEFORE?
>> YOU TELL ME, RYAN.
>> WHAT YOU'RE SAYING HAS WHEN
NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE.
>> ARE WE WATCHING HISTORY?
>> GOOGLE.
GO TO YOUR COMPUTER AND FIND
OUT.
>> COME ON.
>> WHERE'S A FAN?
GET A FAN, WE NEED A FAN.
>> YEAH, HOLD IT.
>> WE'RE GOING TO BLOW.
>> YEAH.
WIDE LEFT.
>> IT'S OVER, DUDE.
LOST TO SEATTLE.
>> HE'S PULLING THIS.
>> CRAIG, YOUR OFF CAMERA.
>> WHO CARES?
IT'S ALL ABOUT THE BLOW.
>> WELL, IT DOESN'T MATTER.
>> I'M GOING TO ROCK 'N' ROLL.
>> I'M GOING TO GET OUT OF THE
WAY.
I'M JUST GOING TO GET OUT OF THE
>> WIDE RIGHT!
IT'S GOOD!
>> HE MADE THE SHOT.
THAT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
>> WHOO!
>> THAT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
>> WE'RE GOOD, WE'RE ONLY DOWN
ONE.
WE'RE ABOUT TO GO INTO THE HALF
AND GET OUR ASSES CHEWED OUT BY
SHANAHAN AND COME BACK.
>> I KNOW, I KNOW.
>> THAT'S CRAZY.
>> SEAHAWKS LIVE MONEY LINE WAS
LIKE PLUS 5,000.
>> THEIR TEAM TOTAL IS LIKE 13.
>> I KNOW.
I'M SAYING AFTER THE NINERS
SCORE WITH 9 SECONDS, 12
SECONDS --
>> YEAH, THAT'S JUST BRUTAL.
>> THAT'S WILD.
>> NINERS GET THE BALL.
>> YEAH, THEY DO.
>> WE'RE GOOD, WE'RE ALL RIGHT.
NOT WORRIED.
>> MIDDLE RANGE.
>> NOT WORRIED.
NOT WORRIED.
>> YOU COULD CUT THE TENSION
WITH A KNIFE.
>> YEAH, YOU WANT TO GRADE SOME
BETS, LOGAN?
TALKING ABOUT THIS WEEKEND'S
BET.
>> TALK ABOUT OUR PICKS.
TALK ABOUT HOW THINGS ARE GOING.
>> THIS WEEKEND.
>> THAT IS SUCH A BAD OMEN.
I TRULY BELIEVE THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO LOSE THAT GAME.
>> THAT'S UNREAL.
>> LIKE, WHY?
WHY DID HE DO THAT?
SQUIB KICK.
>> 8 SECONDS LEFT WHEN THEY
KICKED OFF.
>> IT'S OVER.
>> WOULD IT BE POSSIBLE TO RALLY
THE VIBES FOR A FEW MINUTES TO
GREAT SOME BETS?
>> OF COURSE.
>> GIVE SOME WEEKEND LOCKS?
>> GIVE OUR PICKS FOR THE WILD
CARD WEEKEND.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> WHAT ARE THE --
>> M. DIESEL, I HAVE A KITTLE
TD, MUCH-NEEDED FOR MY TD
PARLAY.
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW TO GRADE
THAT.
IT'S A CURVE BET.
>> GEORGE KITTLE WILL SCORE A
TOUCHDOWN IN THE GAME THAT WE'RE
WATCHING.
>> HE'S TAKING THAT LIVE?
>> HE ALREADY HAS IT.
>> I LIKE IT.
>> WE GOT A COUPLE OF KITTLE
TDs.
>> YEAH, DOES ANYONE HAVE FOUR
LETTERS PLUS ON THEIR PHONE OR
SOMETHING?
>> HM?
>> FOUR LETTERS PLUS?
COME ON.
SOMEONE, PLEASE?
17 SECONDS LEFT.
>> I GOTCHA.
>> LET'S GRADE SOME MORE BETS.
>> I MEAN, JUST IMMEDIATELY GOT
SHUT DOWN ON KITTLE'S TD, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
>> I MEAN --
>> WERE YOU GETTING THAT
F-MINUS?
MINUS LIVE?
>> M. DIESEL --
>> WE HAVE TO BASE THAT ON THE
QUARTERBACK PLAY.
>> ARE WE SENDING AN ALERT?
LOGAN, ARE WE SENDING AN ALERT?
>> YEAH.
>> PLEASE DON'T --
>> WHAT'S THE --
>> EVERY OTHER THROW NOW IS
GREAT.
>> I THINK THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION.
THAT MAYBE SHOULD BE RAISED AT
THIS CURRENT MOMENT.
WHAT IS OUR CONFIDENCE METER IN
BROCK PURDY IN THE SECOND HALF?
>> ZERO.
>> SO OVER.
>> ZERO?
>> THE GAME IS OVER.
>> OKAY.
>> I WILL GRADE FUTURE BETS.
SOMEONE WANTS TO TALK
CHARGERS/JAGS?
>> YEAH, NO --
>> WE'LL GO --
>> I WAS TRYING TO PUSH THAT.
>> I'M GOING TO GET SOME AGUA.
>> LET'S GET SOME PEOPLE A
COUPLE TO GET INTO THE CHAT.
>> WE COULD DOWN THE
BUCS/COWBOYS WHILE WE HAVE TIME
TO KILL.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, IF YOU WANT --
>> IF THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT.
>> I DON'T THINK WE NEED TO DO
THAT.
>> YEAH.
>> CHARGERS/JAGS.
I'M ON CHARGERS MONEY LINE.
>> I LIKE CHARGERS TOO.
>> WOW.
>> YOU GUYS ARE SIGNED UP --
>> 5-2-2.
>> I LOVE IT.
>> EVERYONE IS VERY IN ON THE
JAGS RIGHT NOW.
AND THEY GOT OUTPLAYED BY JOSH
DOBBS AND THE TITANS.
AND THEY GOT NEGATIVE 1 YARDS IN
THE FOURTH QUARTER.
TRAURLS LOOK AWFUL.
TREVOR LAWRENCE LOOKED AWFUL.
THAT'S A GAME IF YOU'RE A REAL
CONTENDER WHICH THEY'RE NOT,
YOU'D WIN EASILY.
>> THE CHAT WHAT THEY'RE ON IN
JAGS/CHARGERS.
IN THE MEANTIME OR -- THIS
WEEKEND IN GENERAL.
IN THE MEANTIME, DOES NO MIKE
WILLIAMS SCARE YOU?
>> IT DOES.
THAT'S THE BIGGEST CONCERN.
YOU KNOW, I'VE SAID IT A LOT.
I THINK HE IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THAT OFFENSE, MORE SO
THAN JUST THE TYPICAL STAR
RECEIVER ON HIS TEAM.
HE'S REALLY THE ONLY DEEP
THREAT, GO BALL, JUMP BALL, YOU
KNOW.
EVERYONE ELSE THEY HAVE DOESN'T
REALLY HAVE THAT CAPABILITY.
KEENAN ALLEN'S GREAT.
HE'S GOING TO GET YOU SEVEN
YARDS ON THIRD DOWN.
BUT IT REALLY ALLOWS THE -- THE
JAGS ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
PACK IT IN.
AND THAT'S JUST A SCARY THING.
SO WOULD HAVE FELT A LOT BETTER
IF HE WAS PLAYING.
I STILL THINK THEY WIN.
BUT I DO THINK -- I THINK IT'S
BIG FOR THEM TODAY, I DO THINK
IT LIMITS THE CHARGERS' CEILING
THE REST OF THE PLAYOFFS.
>> P. SKILE LETTER, TWO THINGS.
MIKE WILLIAMS WAS HIT OR MISS
ALL YEAR.
ALSO SAID HE'S ON CHARGERS MONEY
LINE, HE'S TAILING YOU.
>> LOVE THAT.
>> ALSO A QUESTION IN THE CHAT,
WHO SCORES IN JAGS/CHARGERS?
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
>> EKELER.
>> YEAH, EKELER.
>> I THINK KEENAN ALLEN.
MINUS 160.
>> JAY ROCHA SAYS, CHRISTIAN
KIRK, EVAN ENGRAMS SCORING FOR
THE JAGS.
>> EVAN INGRAM'S BEEN A LITTLE
TOO MUCH.
>> THAT'S NOT REALLY
DETERMINED --
>> YEAH.
AS A GIANTS FAN, I'M VERY OUT ON
EVAN INGRAM AND WATCHING THIS
RENAISSANCE.
I DO LIKE JOSH PALMER STEPPING
UP.
>> NO, MIKE WILLIAMS, I'M TAKING
KEENAN ALLEN ALL DAY.
>> I DO LIKE THAT.
>> CHARGERS ALL-IN WITH GREG.
>> YEAH, THE TD -- YEAH, THE TD
MIGHT BE --
>> I USED TO BE A BIG TREVOR
LAWRENCE, WHEN HE WAS PLAYING
COLLEGE DAYS AT CLEMSON.
YOU CAN SEE THAT TONIGHT -- WHAT
IS EVERYONE'S FAVORITE BET FOR
THE REST OF THE WEEKEND?
GO AROUND THE HORN.
CAN BE TONIGHT, CAN BE WHATEVER.
>> FAVORITE BET FOR THE REST OF
THE WEEKEND?
I LIKE THE CHARGER TONIGHT.
I GOT THEM ON MY PARLAY, I'M
ROCKING WITH IT.
>> NICE.
>> RAVENS PLUS 10.
NOW IT'S 8, 8 1/2.
>> BACK DOWN?
>> DO WE WANT TO --
>> WE CAN DO THIS.
DO YOU WANT TO DO THE
BENGALS/RAVENS TALK?
>> DO YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT WE DISCUSSED?
>> SO LET'S SET THE STAGE.
RAVENS/BENGALS.
SO YOU HAVE A RAVENS FUTURE,
ONE.
YOU ACTUALLY LOVE THE RAVENS
THIS WEEKEND THIS.
>> I DO.
>> AND THE PUBLIC IS ALL OVER
THE BENGALS.
I WOULD SAY MOST OF THIS ROOM,
MAYBE NOT ALL OVER THEM, BUT
VERY MUCH LIKES BENGALS OVER
RAVENS.
I WOULD VENTURE TO SAY MOST OF
THE PEOPLE IN THE CHAT PROBABLY
THINK BENGALS.
>> THE DEFENSE IS THE MOST
UNDERRATED UNIT IN THE LEAGUE,
IN MY OPINION.
AND THEY'VE DONE A REALLY,
REALLY GOOD JOB OF KEEPING
PRETTY MUCH EVERY GAME CLOSE
EVEN WHEN THEY'VE KIND OF
OBVIOUSLY LOST SOME GAMES
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T SCORE.
>> RIGHT.
>> EVEN LAST WEEK THEY LOST BY
DOUBLE DIGITS.
BUT THEY HAD FOUR TURNOVERS.
THEY ALSO, WITH THE THIRD STREET
QUARTERBACK, THEY SAT MARK
ANDREWS.
VANILLA GAME PLAN, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO SHOW THEM ANYTHING
BECAUSE WE'RE TO PLAY THEM NEXT
WEEK.
THEY OUTGAINED FROM THE BENGALS,
TURNED IT OVER FOUR TIMES.
I THINK THE RAVENS DEFENSE IS
REALLY GOOD, I THINK THEY KEEP
THEM IN THE GAME.
RAVENS PROBABLY AREN'T GOING TO
SCORE ENOUGH IN THE RODE ZONE TO
WIN THE GAME, THOUGH I THINK
IT'S POSSIBLE.
I DON'T COMPLETELY WRITE THEM
OFF LIKE I THINK EVERYONE ELSE
IS.
IF YOU CAN GET THEM 9, 10
POINTS, TO ME, THAT'S MY
FAVORITE OF THE WEEK.
>> I HAVE A BENGALS FUTURE.
I AM COMPLETELY RUNNING THE
RAVENS OFF BECAUSE THEY STINK.
>> THEY DON'T STINK.
>> NO, NO, STINKY POO.
THEY STINK.
LIKE POO.
AND NOBODY IN THE NFL COVERS THE
SPREAD LIKE JOE BURROW.
SO THE BET THAT WE HAD MADE --
>> GIANTS.
>> THE GIANTS.
>> 14-3.
>> YEAH, GO OFF.
>> YEAH, PLEASE?
>> HOW ABOUT THIS, NOBODY IN THE
AFC COVERS THE SPREAD LIKE JOE
BURROW.
>> GOOD COVER.
>> THE BET THAT WE MADE FOR
THOSE WHO TUNE IN EVERY WEEK
WITH THE SHOW WITH GREG SAM AND
I WAS THAT WHOEVER LOSES THE
COVER, RAVENS OR BENGALS, HAS TO
SHOW UP FOR NEXT WEEK'S SHOW
WITH A STRAIGHT MOUSTACHE.
SAM TRIED TO WEASEL OUT OF IT.
>> THERE'S NO PROOF WE MADE THAT
BET.
>> IT'S CRAZY.
>> I -- OH, IT'S CRAZY THAT YOU
DON'T THINK I HAVE A VIDEO.
>> THERE'S NO PHYSICAL EVIDENCE
THAT THAT BET WAS MADE.
>> I REALLY DON'T REMEMBER THAT.
>> NO?
>> I REALLY DON'T.
>> OKAY.
>> I'M IN EVERY SHOW, I THINK
I'M IN EVERY SHOW.
>> YEAH.
>> NO, NO, WE MADE THIS AT
DIPPER LAST NIGHT.
>> OH, OKAY.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY, I DON'T
REMEMBER CALLING IT DURING THE
SHOW.
>> ROB DOG SAYS RAVENS MONEY
LINE.
LET'S GO.
>> RAVENS MONEY LINE?
>> DON'T DO IT, SAM.
>> THIS IS -- I WILL SAY THIS IS
ONE OF THE MORE -- WHAT'S THE
SITUATION?
>> CONFIDENT BETS I'VE SEEN YOU
PLAY.
THE OTHER TIMES YOU'VE BEEN LIKE
THIS, YOU'VE BEEN RIGHT.
>> THIS RAVENS BET?
>> GREG AND I GAVE OUR FIFTH,
WHAT'S YOUR FAVORITE?
>> THIS IS THE -- SO THEY JUST
SHOWED THIS GAME UP HERE.
THE VIKINGS/GIANTS.
I THINK I'M GOING TO END UP
TAKING THE GIANTS.
I THINK THAT THAT IS A PRETTY --
I THINK EVERYONE IS KIND OF ON
THAT BECAUSE EVERYONE AGREES,
STRIKE ACTIONS STINK.
I THINK THE VIKINGS OFFENSIVE
LINE IS AWFUL.
AS A KIRK COUSINS MVP BETTOR
THIS YEAR, HE IS OFFENSIVE LINE.
JUST SET HIM UP FOR FAILURE
COME.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT THE NUMBER 5 ON THE NEW
YORK GIANTS?
TEARING IT UP LATELY.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO FEAST.
I KNOW THE JGIANTS ARE NOT THE
SEXY TEAM TO WATCH, BUT IN THE
TYPICAL, WE CAN GET RID OF THE
VIKINGS, WE DON'T HAVE TO WATCH
MORE VIKINGS FOOTBALL.
I'M GOING TO TAKE THE POINTS,
I'M NOT GOING TO TAKE GIANTS
MONEY LINE.
I'M GOING TO ROLL.
>> KWAN DATIVE RESEARCH WAS ON
THIS WEEK.
>> IS THIS GOING TO BE EVEN/ODD?
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
QUARTERBACK STARTING IN THE
PLAYOFFS FOR THE FIRST TIME
DEFENSE A VETERAN QUARTERBACK
WHO'S STARTED IN THE PLAYOFFS --
I BELIEVE VETERAN QUARTERBACKS,
84% STRAIGHT UP.
AND LIKE 68% AGAINST THE SPREAD.
>> WERE ANY OF THOSE
QUARTERBACKS KIRK COUSINS?
>> I'M NOT SURE.
>> ALSO, THE GAME STARTS AT 4:00
EASTERN.
THE SUN WILL BE SETTING.
FIRST HALF, KIRK, IF YOU LIKE
THE VIKINGS, TAKE THE WITH THE
FIRST HALF.
THEN TAKE THE GIANTS AFTER THAT.
YEAH, I TRIED TO GET THERE.
I TRIED TO THINK, THAT LINE
HASN'T MOVED.
I'M SURE PEOPLE ARE GOING THE
OTHER WAY WITH THE VIKINGS.
I THINK THE GIANTS -- I ALSO
THINK THE GIANTS HAVE BETTER
COACHING TOO.
>> STEP UP.
>> YEAH.
>> VIKINGS DEFENSE IS HORRIBLE,
OFFENSIVE LINE IS TERRIBLE.
THE BIGGEST THREAT IS JEFFERSON.
MAYBE THE BEST PLAYER IN THE
NFL.
HE CAN TOTALLY CHANGE THINGS.
I'M GOING WITH THE JOINS.
I'LL JUMP IN HERE.
OBVIOUSLY, GIANTS GUY.
I'M GOING TO APPLY THE EMOTIONAL
HEDGE.
>> HEY!
>> SO I'M ON THE VIKINGS.
WITHOUT A DOUBT THE GIANTS ARE
THE LEAST-TALENTED TEAM IN THE
PLAYOFFS, RIGHT, FROM A TALENT
ON THE ROSTER PERSPECTIVE.
>> I AGREE.
>> MAYBE ONE OF THE LEAST T
TALENTED TEAMS TO EVER MAKE THE
PLAYOFFS, REALLY A TESTAMENT --
>> DEBATABLE.
THE COWBOYS.
>> YEAH.
>> YEAH, THAT'S GOOD.
NO, I COULDN'T BE MORE EXCITED
FOR THE FUTURE WITH THIS
COACHING STAFF.
PLAYING WITH HOUSE MONEY.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, I THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE A VERY CLOSE
GAME.
AND I KNOW THE WAY THE VIKINGS
HAVE OPERATED, A PRETTY POOR
OFFENSIVE LINE.
THEY'VE FOUND WAYS TO SOMEHOW BE
ON THE LUCKY SIDE OF THESE
WINDS.
THAT'S ALSO BEEN THE GIANTS'
M.O. IN RECENT HISTORY.
HAVING A SPRING OF HEART
BREAKING LOSSES IT FEELS LIKE IT
WILL COME DOWN TO THE LAST
POSSESSION.
I THINK THEY'RE PROBABLY GOING
TO LOSE IN A VERY CLOSE GAME.
I'M GIVING MYSELF THE HEDGE.
I COME OUT WITH A WIN EITHER
WAY.
SO I FEEL LIKE IT'S NOT OFTEN
THAT YOU CAN POSITION YOURSELF
UP LIKE THAT.
>> ARE YOU SAYING VIKINGS MONEY
LINE?
>> NO.
NO, NO.
I WILL GO VIKINGS.
>> HAVE YOU CONSIDERED THE
SCENARIO IN WHICH --
>> OH, NO.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY.
>> GIANTS LOSE BY 2?
>> UH --
>> IS CAROLINA GOING TO BE BACK
WHEN THAT HAPPENS?
I'M WORRIED ABOUT YOU, VINCE.
>> YEAH, I DON'T -- NO, I
HAVEN'T.
SO THIS IS --
>> OH GOD.
>> GIANTS LOSE?
>> DO WE HAVE THE GIANTS LOSE BY
2?
NO, BECAUSE I THINK --
>> BUT YOU HAVEN'T CONSIDERED
IT, THOUGH?
>> THERE'S NO WAY IT HAPPENS.
YOU THINK VIKINGS WIN BY ONE OR
2, PLUS 1,500, PLUS 2,000?
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
NO WAY.
>> I'M BRINGING UP THE
SCENARIOS --
>> 0% CHANCE.
>> I'M NOT SAYING IT HAPPENING.
JUST CONSIDER IT.
>> YOU NEED TO SCORE.
>> WE NEED A TWO-POINT
CONVERSION.
>> SO THE CONVERSATION, WHERE'S
OUR FOOD AT?
>> IT SHOULD BE 10 MORE MINUTES.
>> 3.
>> 3 MORE MINUTES?
>> MHB 4, PARLAY GIANTS PLUS
5 1/2, VIKINGS PLUS 5 1/2.
>> YOU CHOOSE -- OKAY, YOU KNOW
WHAT?
>> I LIKE WHERE HE'S AT.
>> NO, THE FACT THAT HE'S
BASICALLY SAYING NO ONE'S GOING
TO LOSE BY FIVE -- WIN MARGIN --
>> I'VE GOT TO ASSUME THIS GROUP
HAS NO INTEREST IN THE DOLPHINS
BASH SHRIL
DOLPHINS/BILLS GAME?
>> NO INTEREST.
>> WHAT IS THAT LINE NOW?
WHAT'S THAT LINE?
14.
>> JAMES O. SAID, PUT --
>> ALL RIGHT, WE'RE BACK.
>> IRA, WHATEVER.
>> WE'LL SAY COWBOYS.
>> OKAY, WE'LL END THE SHOW WITH
THAT.
>> THAT WAS SO HUGE.
>> FOR SICKING OFF, NINERS GET
THE BALL FIRST.
>> THAT IS, LIKE, GAME CHANGING.
>> TOUCHDOWN, TWO-POINT
CONVERSION.
>> PLEASE.
>> NO MORE SCORING.
>> I'M STILL SCARED.
BECAUSE THEN SEAHAWKS ARE GOING
TO SCORE AND GO FOR TWO.
WE REALLY NEEDED TO BE UP TWO.
>> I DON'T THINK THEY'LL SCORE
AND GO FOR TWO.
>> END OF THE GAME RRLS IF WE'RE
UP SEVEN --
>> THOUGHTS ON BILLS, PLUS 180
ON DRAFT KINGS.
>> I DON'T HATE THE.
>> THAT'S ABSURD THAT MINUS 9 IS
PLUS 178.
>> YOUR WIFE DOESN'T LEAVE YOU,
EVERYONE WINS.
>> EVERYONE'S LEAVING ME, IT'S
OVER.
>> LET'S GO!
>> A TOUCHDOWN ON THIS PLAY.
>> IT'S BAD VIBES FOR ME TO SEE
THE LIVE ODDS -- THANK YOU.
>> WE DON'T WANT YOU TO GET IN
TROUBLE AGAIN.
>> I FEEL LIKE BEFORE -- IF THE
BOARD SAYS LIGHTEN UP, IT'S A
SEA HABS PICK SIX --
>> YOU GOT TWO, TWO WINS?
I SEE YOU, BOY, I SEE YOU,
LOGAN.
>> I ALWAYS DO WELL ON THESE
LIVESTREAMS.
>> YOU DO?
>> YEAH, BIG CROWD.
>> THAT WAS THE FIRST ONE, ME
AND YOU --
>> BIG LIVESTREAM GUY.
>> YOU AND I CLEANED.
>> LOOK AT BROCK PURDY'S
NUMBERS.
>> NEED A LITTLE JUWAN.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE IOWA STATE,
BROCK.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO HIT -- THIS
IS GOING OVER FOR SURE.
>> OKAY, I LIKE THAT.
I LIKE THAT.
>> I LIKE WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE.
>> I LIKE THAT.
>> I LIKE IT.
FOR ALL THE PENNIES.
>> AS THEY GAIN 10 YARDS.
>> KPAT12 WANTS TO KNOW IF
YOU'RE SWEATING?
>> IS THAT KELSEY?
>> IT IS KELSEY.
>> SHOUT-OUT KELSEY.
>> NOT YET.
>> NOT YET?
>> ASK KELSEY IF SHE HAS ANY
PARLAYS SHE HIT.
>> THAT'S THIRD AND INCHES.
>> GO QUARTERBACK SNEAK HERE.
>> SNEAK IT SO WE DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT IT.
>> I WANT TO WIN SAYS, YO, WHAT
ARE SAM'S PICKS FOR THIS
WEEKEND?
>> RAVENS, RAVENS, RAVENS.
>> RAVENS, CHARGERS --
>> HE LEARNT THAT FROM JIMMY!
>> RAVENS SPREAD.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE IT AT?
>> RAVENS SPREAD?
10.
>> 10.
YOU'VE GOT A LITTLE CLV.
>> OTHER TAKES, TOTALLY STAYING
AWAY --
>> DIDN'T YOUR QUARTERBACK HURT
HIMSELF ON THE QUARTERBACK
SNEAK?
>> WHAT'S UP?
DID DAK HURT HIMSELF ON THE
QUARTERBACK SNEAK BEFORE?
>> VIKINGS/GIANTS ARE TWO TEAMS
I DON'T BELIEVE IN VERY MUCH.
>> A QUARTERBACK SNEAK?
I DON'T THINK SO.
>> HE SAYS THANK YOU.
>> RAVENS BACKS, THIS GUY
FIGHTING THE UFC, SAME LAST NAME
AS YOU.
>> OH, REALLY?
>> YEAH.
>> YOU DON'T FIND TOO MANY
RIBEROS AROUND.
>> KELSEY SAID SHE DID HIT A
PA
PARLAY.
>> HEY!
>> I SAW THAT.
>> I DON'T LIKE THAT.
IF WE'RE GOING TO RUN THAT, RUN
THAT WITH ELI.
McCAFFREY NEEDS TO BE OUTSIDE.
>> CAN WE THROW THE BALL TO
McCAFFREY?
>> OUR FOOD IS HERE.
>> NICE.
>> TWO RECEPTIONS?
>> IS SOMEONE GETTING THE FOOD
FOR US?
>> YEAH.
>> I'M HANDLING IT.
>> HE'S HANDLING.
HE'S PRODUCER RYAN.
>> THROW THE BALL TO McCAFFREY.
McCAFFREY'S OPEN.
>> JUWAN.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> LET'S GO!
>> KITTLE.
>> YEP.
KITTLE.
>> YEAH, WHEN HE HAS THAT MUCH
TIME.
>> HEY, RYAN, YOUR LONG DISTANCE
COUSIN IS GETTING COOKED.
>> HE'S GETTING COOKED?
>> I'M ASSUMING LONG DISTANCE.
>> YOU HAVE A LOT OF FAMILY
MEMBERS THAT POP UP IN THE CHAT.
>> I DO, YEAH.
>> THEY CARE ABOUT YOU, LIKE
WATCHING YOUR STUFF.
>> BROCK PURDY'S GOOD.
>> THE GUY YOU COMPARED TO
MAHOMES EARLIER?
>> HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO WIN
THIS GAME FOR ME TO REALLY --
>> SHOUT-OUT IN THE CHAT, PLEASE
TELL ME WHAT WE WANT TO DO FOR
NEXT TOUCHDOWN.
I'LL TAIL YOU AGAIN.
>> ELI, HE'S IN, THAT'S FOUR
YARDS, WE'LL TAKE THAT.
>> THAT WAS GOOD.
>> I FEEL LIKE I KIND OF WANT TO
GET AT ELI.
SECOND HALF ELI.
>> YOU SHOULD, THEY'RE FUN.
>> I FEEL LIKE YOU'VE GOT TO
DO --
>> SAM, AVERT YOUR EYES.
>> DON'T TELL ME ANY ODDS.
>> WE'RE GOOD, WE'RE GOOD.
>> I FEEL LIKE YOU SHOULD BE
BETTING ON SOMEONE WHO'S ON THE
OTHER TEAM.
>> DUDE.
>> BETTING ANY TIME, YOU SHOULD
BE BETTING SOMEONE WHOSE TEAM IS
ON DEFENSE RIGHT NOW.
OTHERWISE YOU'RE LOSING A TON OF
VALUE.
>> YOU THOUGHT THIS WAS GOING TO
BE A BLOWOUT.
>> THIS IS GOING OVER TOO.
>> I NEED JUWAN JENNINGS ALSO.
>> OH!
>> WHAT A TAG.
>> TOUCH SOMEBODY 81.
YOU LOOKING BACK, LIKE TOUCH
SOMEBODY.
>> SHEESH.
>> YEAH, WE HAD IT SET UP.
>> 81 DIDN'T TOUCH NOBODY,
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
LOOK IT.
>> THAT WAS SUCH WELL SET UP AND
HE COMPLETELY WHIFFED.
>> HOW -- OH!
>> WOW.
>> OH HO HO!
>> THAT WAS SCARY FOR A SECOND.
>> THAT IS SO GOOD.
>> HEY, THAT'S DEEBO.
IT'S HARD TO TACKLE.
HE'S LIKE SAQUON AS A WIDE
RECEIVER.
>> YOU KNOW WHO DEEBO REMINDS ME
OF?
TUUKKA WILLIAMS.
>> THAT WAS LIKE --
>> RIGHT THERE, RIGHT THERE.
>> TUUKKA WILLIAMS.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
>> MY LIFE IS ON THE LINE.
>> THAT IS VERY SAQUON-LIKE.
>> THAT WAS A NICE THROW BY
BROCK.
>> WHO DOES THAT LOOK LIKE?
WHO DOES IT LOOK LIKE?
>> I TOLD YOU.
YOU SAW THAT?
A LITTLE DROP-DOWN?
>> YEAH.
>> OH!
>> OH, NO!
>> CAN WE GET A FLAG, REF?
WHAT ARE THEY DOING?
THEY'RE IN IN A HUDDLE.
>> GOT TO TUSSLE.
>> RAY-RAY, THROW HANDS --
>> THAT WAS DEEBO?
>> WHAT HAPPENED?
>> RAY-RAY.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT DOING IT AS
ONE OF MY PLAYS.
>> OH, MAN.
>> IS HE HURT?
IS HE GOOD?
WHAT HAPPENED?
I NEED TO KNOW.
>> IMAGINE YOU GET THE CATCH,
DREW RUNS BACKWARDS --
>> JOHNSON STYLE.
>> YEAH.
>> OH!
>> OH, THAT'S -- YEAH.
>> WE DON'T ROCK WITH THAT.
>> IS HE OKAY?
>> EVEN BIRD DANG DOESN'T ROCK
WITH THAT, OOF.
>> YEAH.
>> COME ON.
>> 23?
>> OH, IMAGINE THAT.
>> ABRAM, HE'S DIRTY.
>> THE WORST FOOTBALL PLAYER TO
EVER --
>> HE'S LOSING -- THE RED HAIRED
DUDE ON THE RAIDERS FROM LAST
YEAR, RIGHT?
>> THEY CAME OUT.
>> LEGITIMATELY ONE OF THE WORST
FOOTBALL -- I COULD TALK FOR
HOURS ABOUT HOW BAD HE IS.
>> THAT'S SO DIRTY, BRO.
>> I KILOGRAM ON FOREVER.
HIS FIRST GAME EVER, HE TRIES TO
COMPLETELY DO THE SAME THING.
>> OH, THAT'S SO DIRTY WHAT
ABRAMS JUST DID.
>> YEAH, THAT HURT.
>> THAT'S DIRTY.
>> HE'S BACK IN.
>> STILL GOT THAT RAIDERS --
>> I DON'T THINK SO --
>> I DON'T LIKE DIRTY PLAYS.
>> WE'RE GETTING BRADY.
>> HE NEATS A FLAGRANT ONE, NO,
PLAYING WANT TWO -- HEY!
>> PIZZA!
>> FOOD GOD.
>> WE BACK?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHO YOU'RE
ROOTING FOR OR WHAT YOU'RE
DOING --
>> I SAID WE.
>> JUST PUT IT DOWN.
>> PUT THE FOOD DOWN.
>> YOU'RE OUT OF FRAME, MAN.
>> OH, NO.
>> WE'RE GOOD, WE'RE GOOD.
>> COME ON.
>> WE'RE, LIKE, SO DEEP IN THE
DEAD ZONE, IT'S SCARY.
>> SAM, I KNOW ONE THING.
>> SAM, I NEED A SLICE.
>> WE NEED A TOUCHDOWN.
>> WE'RE GETTING PLAYS.
>> THAT LOOKS GOOD.
>> WHO CHOSE THIS PLACE?
>> I DID.
>> THIS IS TERRIBLE, RYAN.
>> NO, STOP, BRO.
>> NO, NO.
IT'S GOOD, TRUST ME.
>> I'M JUST MESSING AROUND.
>> THANK YOU.
>> FOR CONTENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> SOMEONE -- THEY WANT TO SEE
THE PIZZA.
>> WE'LL SHOW IT.
>> THEY CAN SEE IT.
>> TOP CAM.
>> GOOD, GOOD, GOOD, GOOD.
PUSH, PUSH.
>> McCAFFREY.
>> UH, NO.
>> I THINK HE STILL HAS TWO
RECEPTIONS.
>> THAT BOY BE UP THERE SCARFING
ONE OF THEM THINGS, HUH?
>> YOU GOT -- I'M HUNG OVER.
HUNG OVER.
>> NOT FULLY CUT HALF THIS ROOM
IS PRETTY HUNG OVER STILL.
>> TOUGH FOR ME.
>> IT'S NOT PROPERLY CUT.
I DON'T TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THAT.
THIS DRIVE IS TOO LONG.
>> McCAFFREY TO SCORE TWO
TOUCHDOWNS.
>> OH, NO.
>> DIDN'T GET IT.
>> HE GOT IT.
>> YEAH.
>> DID HE BREAK --
>> HE GOT IT.
>> MUST HAVE NOT BEEN THAT
CRAZY, THOUGH.
>> THAT'S BULL.
>> BROCK PURDY.
>> YEAH, ANY TIME OR HIS FIRST?
>> JUST FIRST.
>> I THINK HE GOT IN.
>> TOUCHDOWN, BRO.
>> WE GOT TO MAKE THE
TWO-POINTER.
>> WOW.
>> WAIT, WOW.
>> WOW, DUDE.
>> McCAFFREY, TWO-PLUS TOUCHDOWN
BETTORS JUST GOT ROBBED.
>> YEAH, MAYBE IT WASN'T
ALWAYS --
>> WHO LEFT, LOGAN?
WE NEED DRINKS.
>> NO.
THAT WAS A JOKE.
>> ARE WE NOT GOING FOR TWO?
>> I GUESS NOT.
>> CAN WE GET SOME SPICE AND AND
WATERS?
>> THAT'S A GOOD TAKE.
>> WHY ARE WE NOT GOING FOR TWO?
WHY ARE YOU EATING ALL THE
PEPPERONI WHEN YOU WANTED PLAIN?
Y'ALL WANTED PLAIN PIZZA, YOU'RE
EATING PEPPER RO ENEMY.
>> I DIDN'T SAY THAT'S THE RIGHT
NAME.
>> HAND ME BACK THAT PAPER
TOWEL.
>> BREAK OPEN THAT CHEESE, I'LL
EAT THE CHEESE.
>> I'M DONE.
>> HEY, THE DEFENSE GOT TO DO
WHAT THEY BEEN DOING ALL YEAR.
IF THAT DON'T HAPPEN, I DON'T
KNOW --
>> I NEED THAT, PAPER TOWEL.
I NEED THAT.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
>> DOUBLE.
>> YEAH, GOOD MAN.
>> BIG NAPKIN GUY.
ALWAYS OVERUSE NAPKINS.
ALSO JUST DON'T BUY NAPKINS,
JUST BUY PAPER TOWELS.
YOU'RE LOOKING RIGHT IN.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> COULD USE LIKE A WATER BOTTLE
DELIVERY.
>> YEAH.
>> WHAT IS THAT?
>> OH, WE GOT GARLIC BREAD.
>> OH!
>> THROW THAT ON A PLATE RIGHT
HERE.
>> SOMETHING WET.
RANCH.
>> IS THIS GOOD CONTENT?
JUST US EATING AND NOT TALKING?
>> SAME THING.
>> ARE THOSE WINGS?
OH, YEAH.
SOMEONE GOT A HERO?
IT'S OPEN.
>> THAT'S THE GARLIC BREAD,
OKAY.
>> I GUESS JUST TEARING INTO
THIS.
>> MAX, IS THIS GOOD CONTENT?
>> COULD USE SOME MARINARA.
>> THAT LOOKS SO NASTY.
>> JOE AND PAT'S.
>> DIPPING SAUCE.
>> #CONTENT.
>> IS IT GOOD?
>> IT'S FINE.
>> I SHOULD HAVE HAD SOME
MAR
MARINARA.
>> WHAT IS THAT, BRYSON?
>> RANCH, I ASSUME.
>> PARLAY?
>> WE SHOULD DO A PARLAY
CHECK-IN.
>> DID THEY GO FOR TWO?
>> WE'RE SO DEAD.
>> WE'RE GOING TO LOSE BY ONE.
>> WE NEED GENO TO START
THROWING THE BALL.
>> WE NEED, LIKE -- WE NEED THEM
TO THROW THE BALL A BUNCH THIS
DRIVE AND NOT GET ANY -- WE NEED
A PICK SIX.
IF THEY GET DOWN A LOT AND WE
HAVE TO THROW, WE'LL BE FINE.
>> GOING TO HOP IN THE CHAT AND
SEE WHAT MY GUY DILLON'S TELLING
US OUR NEXT TOUCHDOWN BETTOR IS
GOING TO BE.
>> LET'S ASK THE CHAT, FLATS OR
DRUMS?
>> FLATS.
>> BONES ARE BONELESS.
>> DON'T DO THIS, DON'T.
>> BONELESS YOU SAID?
>> NO.
DON'T PUT THAT ON.
DON'T YOU PUT THAT ON THERE.
>> THE WINGS ARE FINE.
>> SAM C. IS ON TWO RECEPTIONS.
>> GET ME THAT TD.
>> 17 RUSHING YARDS.
>> SORRY, THOUGH.
>> MATT 24 RATE, HE'S ON GAME
DAY -- AMEN, BROTHER, AMEN.
>> OH, MAN.
>> WE NEED A LOT OF GENO SMITH.
DANG, HE ONLY GOT 10?
>> YEAH, GENO ATTEMPTS ARE GOING
TO DO US.
>> WITH ALL -- RESPECTFULLY,
WE'RE NOT LOOKING GOOD WITH THE
GENO PLAY.
THIS IS WHAT WE NEED TO STOP,
THOUGH, SAM.
>> WE'LL TAKE THAT.
>> THAT HAS TO STOP.
>> THE OVER CACHE IS ON THE NEXT
SCORE.
>> NEXT SCORE IN GENERAL?
>> YEP, LOSS OF THE SAFETY.
>> UNLESS IT'S A SAFETY.
>> WE NEED ODD SO BAD.
>> HEY, THEY'RE TRYING TO RUN
THE BALL.
>> LOOKING GOOD RIGHT NOW IF
THERE'S ONE MORE SCORE.
>> GENO SMITH, 30 PASS ATTEMPTS?
WAS THAT AN ALTERNATE LINE?
WAS THAT HIS ACTUAL LINE?
>> HIS ACTUAL LINE.
>> THROW THE BALL, LOCKETT!
>> OH, GREAT.
>> THIS GAME'S ABOUT TO GET OUT
OF HAND.
>> DOES ANYONE KNOW THE NUMBER
OF PASSES D.K. NOW HAS CAUGHT?
>> IT'S FIVE.
>> SOMEBODY'S 82 ON THEIR BEST
BETS HERE.
>> YEAH?
>> SOMEBODY IS.
I WON'T SAY WHO.
CODE NINERS.
>> DO YOU JUST PICK WHICH BETS
COUNT TOWARDS THE RECORD?
>> RIGHT?
>> HE DEFINITELY DOES.
BECAUSE WE SHOULD HAVE A CLASSIC
OF HIS BEST BETS IF IT WAS 8-2,
BUT WE DON'T.
BECAUSE IT'S FRAUD.
>> YEAH, I GOT NO PROBLEM.
IF YOU DON'T THINK I HAVE A CLIP
OF EVERY BET I'VE MADE.
I'M LIKE CVS WITH THESE
RECEIPTS.
>> IF YOU LOVE CHIPPING SO MUCH,
START CLIPPING THE SHOWS SO I
DON'T HAVE TO DO IT.
>> NOT MY JOB ANYMORE, BROTHER.
>> MOVED ON TO GREENER PASTURES.
>> YEP, MOVING UP IN THE WORLD.
>> OH MY GOD, WATCH OUT!
>> OH MY GOD.
>> DOES THIS MEAN NINERS ARE NOT
GETTING THE PRESSURE WE THOUGHT
THEY WOULD?
SEAHAWKS LINE IS PLAYING PRETTY
WELL.
>> BOSA GOT ONE SACK.
>> YEAH.
I'M TELLING YOU GUYS, THIS
PARLAY HITS IF WE CAN GET A GENO
PICK SIX RIGHT HERE.
>> NO, BRYSON.
THAT'S GOOD VIBES.
>> JUST BECAUSE G EENO WILL HAV
THE BALL LONGER?
>> AT LEAST THAT WAS A THROW
ATTEMPT, THOUGH.
>> HE'S ON 12, 13 NOW?
>> IS THAT 13?
>> I THINK IT'S 13.
>> I THINK THAT WAS 13.
>> IT WAS 10 WHEN THEY GOT THE
BALL.
>> YEAH, IT'S 13.
>> IT'S A TIME-OUT.
>> BIG PLAY.
>> YEP.
>> ALL RIGHT, THAT'S NICE.
>> THAT'S NOT -- YEAH.
>> 35, SAM, I DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS
THAT BIG OF A PLAY.
>> I'M GOING TO GRAB DRINKS,
ANYBODY WANT SOMETHING?
>> GET A BUNCH OF WATER.
>> OH, OH, GREG, GOT TO TAKE THE
LABELS OFF.
>> DRINKS COMING?
>> OUT OF SIGHT.
>> RYAN TELLS ME WHEN I'M UP.
>> THESE ARE -- I THINK THESE
ARE THE SMALLEST FLAGS I'VE EVER
SEEN.
>> THESE ARE.
>> DID WE ORDER THE MINIS?
LOOK AT THAT FLAT.
>> BIGGEST PLAY.
>> HEY, MAN.
>> AWESOME.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU GUYS ALL DESERVE RAISES.
>> SHOUT-OUT, THANK YOU, GUYS,
APPRECIATE THAT.
>> SHOUT-OUT TO THE BOYS.
>> THEY PUT ME ON THE FINANCE
TEAM, YOU GUYS ARE ALL GETTING
RAISES.
>> COME ON.
>> THROW A PICK SIX RIGHT HERE.
>> MOODY MAYBE WITH THE WILD
COMMENT.
>> WHY ARE THEY SO FAR BACK?
LOOK AT ALL THAT SPACE.
WHAT THE HELL IS THAT?
>> LOCKETT.
>> THAT WAS AN UNDERRATED GEM.
THAT WAS REALLY FUNNY.
THAT WAS REALLY GOOD.
>> HE'S AT LIKE --
>> BRYSON, ARE YOU IN THE CHAT?
>> NO.
>> MOODY BABY HAS A PERSONAL.
>> WHAT?
>> PERSONAL MESSAGE.
IF I WANTED TO LOOK AT BRYSON'S
MM WHILE HE SAID DIPPING SAUCE,
I'D JOIN HIS ONLYFANS.
>> I SHOULD START ONE.
THAT WAY I CAN AFFORD MY
THOUSAND-DOLLAR BET.
>> NICE.
>> STOP HIM, STOP HIM.
>> LET HIM KEEP PUSHING.
>> REALLY GOOD BANTAMWEIGHT
FIGHT GOING ON BACK HERE, GUYS.
>> GOT IT PULLED UP?
>> YEAH.
THE LAST DUDE, WHAT DID THEY
JUST STARCH THE HELL OUT OF
SOMEONE?
ON THE GRAPHIC.
>> 23-14, IMAGINE HOW IT WOULD
BE DIFFERENT.
>> SEAHAWKS FIELD GOAL.
NINE RS --
>> DID THIS THEY COVER REGULARLY
I'M ALSO COOL WITH THAT.
>> HOLD ON, PLEASE, PLEASE --
COME ON!
>> NO WAY.
WOW.
>> THAT'S STILL -- THEY JUST
SAVED SIX YARDS THERE.
>> ATTEMPT.
>> THAT'S HUGE.
>> BIG DRIVE FOR THE ATTEMPTS
CREW.
>> GOING TO BUMP THEM OUT OF
FIELD GOAL RANGE, SAVE YOUR
UNDER.
>> THAT AIN'T HAPPENING.
>> JACK M. SAYS, I NEED LOCKETT
40 PLUS.
>> WHERE WE AT WITH LOCKETT
RIGHT NOW?
>> WAIT.
>> I GOT THE STATS RIGHT HERE.
>> 20.
>> 20?
OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
>> FEELS LIKE MORE.
>> IT DOES.
>> YEAH, THIS IS BIG.
WE NEED A STOP HERE.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S NOT A GUARANTEED FIELD
GOAL.
>> I JUST DON'T KNOW --
>> LOOK AT ALL THAT SPACE.
>> HE'S ALREADY HIT --
>> HE NEEDS TO TAKE HIS MARINERS
HAT OFF.
>> OH!
LET'S GO!
>> BIG, THAT'S BIG, THAT'S BIG.
THAT'S BIG.
>> A MISSED FIELD GOAL -- NOT
BUENO.
>> IF THE COWBOYS WIN THIS WEEK,
CAN WE DO ANOTHER ONE OF THESE
ON THEIR GAME?
>> I'M ALWAYS DOWN.
>> WHY DID WE NOT TAKE THAT?
>> THAT WAS A -- THAT WAS A
MISS.
THAT WAS A BIG MISS.
>> WOW.
>> WE TOOK TYLER LOCKEN --
>> THESE A CHECK FOR ME, BUT
ANYWAY.
>> THIS PIZZA'S GOOD.
>> THROWING PATS -- NICE, NICE.
>> GOOD THROW.
>> THROWING THE BALL, LOCKETT,
THINGS HAPPENING.
>> A GOOD GAME FOR US HERE.
>> WHY DID WE NOT GO FOR TWO?
>> DON'T LET HIM SCORE A
TOUCHDOWN.
>> TAKE A FIELD GOAL AND WE'RE
GOING TO LOSE BECAUSE OF IT.
>> PERFECT SCENARIO.
>> NINERS, 2 1/2 --
>> I LIKE THIS, I THINK WE CAN
GET --
>> SEVEN TIMES ON THIS DRIVE --
>> YEAH, OBVIOUSLY --
>> NINERS 2 1/2 IS GOING TO BE
WHAT WE LOSE.
>> IF WE HOLD THE SEAHAWKS TO A
FIELD GOAL --
>> THAT'S NOT HAPPENING.
>> STAY UP BY THREE --
>> YOU'RE VIBE CHECKING ME FOR
THE FIRST HAUR AND A HALF --
>> SORRY MY EYES WORK --
>> DON'T APOLOGIZE, JUST BE
BETTER.
LET'S GO.
WE HAVE A GAME TO WIN HERE.
>> IT'S OVER.
>> HE'S TROLLING.
>> HOW AM I TROLLING?
>> SOMETHING IN THE CHAT IS
ASKING OUR OPINION ON TEASERS.
>> BRYSON?
>> I'M A 14, 13 POINT TEASER
GUY.
>> DID YOU DO THE BILLS/49ers?
>> I FIGURED SOMEONE'S GOING TO
BLOW ONE OF THOSE UP, I CAN'T DO
IT.
I CAN'T DO IT.
NO DRINKS.
>> THIS GAME IS KIND OF FLYING
BY.
>> BECAUSE WE'RE HAVING FUN.
>> LOSING MONEY.
>> MHB 4, WHO LIKES COWBOYS?
I LIKE THE COWBOYS.
>> NO, NO.
>> NO, I LOVE THE COWBOYS.
LOVE THE COWBOYS.
WHO'S LAWSUITING THE GAME THIS.
>> I LIKE THE COWBOYS IN THAT
GAME.
>> EYES ON THE SUPER BOWL?
>> YOU HIVE THEM SUPER BOWL?
>> PRESEASON PREDICTION WAS
CHARGERS/COWBOYS, SUPER BOWL.
>> I BET ON THE COWBOYS TO WIN
THE SUPER BOWL.
>> CHECK THE CHAT.
>> 14-1.
YEAH:
>> YOU'RE ALL OVER THE PLAY,
BOY.
>> I'M ALLOWED TO --
>> NFC, ALL YOUR FUTURES?
>> BENGALS IN THE AFC.
>> I'M NOT SAYING YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED, I'M SAYING YOU'RE ALL
OVER THE PLACE.
>> I'M SAYING I HAVE A DECENT
AMOUNT OF MONEY, NOT THE
THOUSAND-DOLLAR PLAY --
>> I FLEX ON YOU.
>> YOU SAY YOU HAVE A DECENT
AMOUNT OF MONEY.
>> ON THE 49ers TO WIN THE SUPER
BOWL.
>> THAT'S STILL FLEXING.
>> ALSO -- YES, TO YOUR FIRST
POINT.
>> YOU GIVE BENGALS/COWBOYS THE
AFC CHAMPIONSHIP GAME?
ARE YOU HEDGING?
>> BENGALS/COWBOYS, THE AFC
CHAMPIONSHIP GAME.
>> TO THEIR CHAMPIONSHIP GAME.
>> BRYSON, YOU'RE BACK HERE
DRIPPING GREASE.
>> SOMEONE I KNOW --
>> BAD VIBES ARE INCOMING.
>> BOTH CHAMPIONSHIPS, LOST BOTH
SOMEHOW.
>> CAN WE NOT?
I JUST -- CAN WE JUST NOT?
>> YEAH --
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW I SHOULD --
>> HOW FAR APART -- I WAS FRAMED
HERE.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHY, THIS WAS A
GOOD DRIVE FOR THE PARLAY.
GENO'S THROWING THE BALL.
>> WE'RE GOING TO HAVE --
>> THEY'RE GOING TO KICK --
>> I THINK HE JUST GOT
ANOTHER --
>> WAIT, MAYBE YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> LOCKETT IS AT 30.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT WE NEED, WE
NEED A BOSA TO MAKE A PLAY, COME
ON, BOSA.
COME ON, BOSA.
>> LOCKETT AGAIN?
>> LET'S GO, NICE.
>> CHIPPING AWAY.
>> ANOTHER SEVEN YARDS.
>> WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE ROUGHING.
>> ROUGHING OR HOLDING?
>> HOW IS IT ROUGHING?
HE GOT RID OF THE BALL --
>> YOU JUST KNOW.
>> HOLD IT, BRING IT BACK, BRING
IT BACK.
HOLDING.
>> THAT MIGHT BE -- NO WAY IT'S
ROUGHING, NO WAY.
>> HOLDING.
>> LET'S GO!
>> WOW.
>> YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
>> IN MY OPINION -- LOOK OUT.
>> BAD PARLAY VIBES.
>> THE CATCH AND THROW.
>>> OH, SORRY, THE PARLAY?
MY BAD.
>> WE'RE TRACKING, THOUGH.
>> WE'RE TRACKING EVERYTHING.
>> WE'RE TRACKING.
>> HONESTLY, THE SEAHAWKS
GETTING STOPPED HERE --
>> YOU KNOW IT HAPPENS.
>> VINCE, I KNOW YOU REALLY WANT
THE COVER BUT --
>> HEY, YOU DON'T THROW IT HERE,
GUYS.
>> YEAH.
>> GET HIM, BOSA.
>> I CAN SEE A RUN HERE.
>> THAT'S LIKE A WIN-WIN.
HELL, NO.
OH!
HELL NO, SAM!
>> WE WON, PLAY WITHOUT A
FLAG --
>> DROPPING DIMES.
DROPPING DIMES.
>> HE, LIKE, ALMOST GOT TO THAT.
>> HE DID OH MY GOD, OH MY GOD.
>> IT'S CRAZY.
>> PICK SIX.
>> IS HE OUT OF THE GAME?
WHERE IS D.K.?
I DON'T THINK HE'S IN THE GAME
UNLESS HE'S UP TOP.
THAT'S ALL WE GOT TO WORRY IS
ABOUT D.K.
>> IS THAT HIM?
I DON'T THINK IT IS.
>> BRYSON, YOUR END ZONE
TURNOVER.
>> GO GET HIM, BOSA!
>> THERE HE IS.
>> OH, OH!
>> DIDN'T SEE THE BALL FOR LIKE
TWO MINUTES.
>> WOW.
>> BANG BANG NINER GAME.
>> LOVE THAT.
>> WOW, THEY FINALLY GOT TO HIM.
>> YES.
IS BOSA IN THERE?
NO?
HE GOT THE RECOVERY, THOUGH.
HE GOT THE RECOVERY.
LET'S GO, THAT'S BIG.
COME ON, BROCK.
DOWN THE FIELD.
WE NEED SEVEN.
>> HEY.
I'LL TAKE EIGHT.
EIGHT.
>> NINE.
>> WORST-CASE SCENARIO.
>> HOW'S USC?
>> I GOT THIS ONE.
THAT'S A GOOD PLAY.
>> WE'RE FINE.
>> 9 1/2, RIGHT?
KICK A FIELD GOAL OR SCORE
TOUCHDOWN --
>> I THINK SO, YEAH.
>> I THOUGHT THOSE WERE THE
PAY-PER-VIEW?
>> NO, NOT APEX, THOUGH.
THEY'RE SOMEWHERE.
>>> I'M AWARE OF THE SITUATION.
>> ELI MITCHELL STILL AT MINUS
FOUR YARDS?
>> ONE SECOND.
>> LOVE THAT FOR YOU.
>> ELI MITCHELL IS AT MINUS ONE
YARDS.
>> ARE YOU TRYING TO COVER --
>> PUMPED IT, MAN.
>> ZERO.
>> I TRY.
>> NO, NO --
>> I'LL TAKE IT LIKE A SIX.
JUMP FROM A ZORRO TO A SIX.
>> ON -- LIKE HOW BACK YOU ARE
RIGHT NOW?
>> SIX.
>> SIX?
YOU THINK IT'S THE SAME?
>> SAME.
>> OKAY.
>> PROBABLY A ONE.
MAYBE ANOTHER SCORE DOESN'T
HAPPEN IN THIS GAME.
IT WOULD BE THE GREATEST UNDER
HIT OF ALL TIME.
>> BECAUSE OF YOUR LIVE BETS?
>> I FEEL LIKE THE MOMENTUM IS
LONG --
>> I FELT IT LAST DRIVE.
>> SCOP STOP THE COUNT, STOP THE
COUNT.
>> YOU BACKED IT ON THE RIGHT
SIDE.
>> WHAT IS THE --
>> IT'S THE LIVE LINE DRIVE.
>> GET BACK IN ON THE RIGHT
SIDE.
>> NOBODY MAKING A LIVE --
>> THE ODDS ARE PLUS 7 1/2 RIGHT
NOW.
>> OH, THEY JUST DROPPED TO PLUS
2 1/2.
>> OH, DAMN, DID THEY GET THE
BALL BACK?
>> WAIT, GET OVER THE THING, GET
OVER THE THING, PLEASE.
>> BAD JOKE.
THAT'S A BAD JOKE.
>> YOU REALLY GOT ME.
>> GET THE ODDS OFF, GET IT OFF.
>> STRAIGHT TO JAIL, STRAIGHT TO
JAIL.
>> I WAS LIKE, OH MY GOD.
>> YO, AMAZING.
>> OH-OH.
>> OH-OH!
>> IT'S RIDICULOUS.
THAT IS.
>> BRYSON, CLEAN UP AFTER
YOURSELF!
>> MAN, I COULD MAKE SOME JOKES
BUT I AIN'T GOING TO MAKE THEM.
>> DON'T MAKE THEM.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO MAKE THEM.
>> HOT DAMN, MAN.
YOU WOULD THINK I LOST MY BET, I
DIDN'T LOSE YET.
>> I FEEL LIKE IT'S GOING TO
EVEN --
>> A LOT OF BALL LEFT.
>> SO MUCH BALL LEFT.
>> A LOT OF BALL LEFT, GUYS.
>> SLANT.
>> DEEBO.
>> DEEBO!
>> OH MY GOD.
>> I WILL SAY THIS IS VERY GOOD
FOR THE PASS ATTEMPTS.
>> YEAH.
IT'S TRUE.
>> THAT WAS GOOD FOR THE PARLAY.
WE GOT THE MINUS 2 1/2.
>> DUDE.
McCAFFREY'S IN TROUBLE, BRO.
FOUR POINT RECEPTION --
>> NO, NO, THE SCREEN --
>> NOT LIKE THE NEXT ONE?
>> SHANAHAN'S GOING TO DIAL UP A
SCREEN, DON'T EVEN TRIP.
>> THERE'S GOT TO BE A WAY TO
EDGE THIS.
>> PASSING ATTEMPTS ARE BACK
FROM THE DEAD FOR SURE.
>> 9-1 WOULD COVER --
>> DO YOU THINK 9-1 RIGHT HIM
FOR HIM IS A LITTLE RIDICULOUS?
>> WHO?
>> D.K. TO SCORE IS 9-1.
>> IF HE SCORES, THAT'S HOW I
LOSE THE OVER/UNDER BET.
>> THAT'S HOW THEY NEED THE RUN
McCAFFREY, SAM.
>> STAY UP, STAY UP!
>> THAT'S HOW THEY NEED --
THAT'S HOW Y'ALL WIN McCAFFREY!
COME ON, SHANAHAN.
LET'S GO WIN THIS GAME, MAN.
SO WE CAN GET HOME.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> GARLIC BREAD, YOU GOOD?
YOU WANT SOME MORE?
>> IT'S KIND OF WEIRD.
>> IT WAS WEIRD.
>> YEAH, IT'S WEIRD.
>> YOU GET THE SAUCE?
>> LOOKING BACK, GARLIC KNOTS
PROBABLY.
>> YEAH, GAR HICK KNOTS.
>> THEY DIDN'T HAVE THEM, IT WAS
GARLIC BREAD.
>> THAT'S SURPRISING.
>> YEAH.
>> I LIKE THE PIZZA, GOOD PIZZA.
>> WE'LL TAKE IT.
>> HOUSE THAT THING, HOUSE THAT
THING.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> MAN, LET'S GO.
>> FIELD GOAL.
>> IT'S OVER.
>> I'M GRABBING D.K.
>> YEAH, JUST LIKE THAT --
>> BRO, WE LITERALLY JUST NEED
McCAFFREY --
>> THAT'S SOMETHING TO WORRY
ABOUT.
>> GENO'S LIKE HALFWAY.
>> HE'S AT 18.
>> GENO'S GOING TO GET THERE.
>> IF THEY SCORE A TOUCHDOWN
HERE --
>> 13.
>> 13 IN A QUARTER.
>> 12, HE'S 18.
>> THEY'RE GOING TO BE DOWN.
>> YOU THINK HE'S NOT THROWING
THE BALL 12 TIMES IN THE FOURTH
QUARTER?
>> HONESTLY --
>> WHATEVER HAPPENS HERE --
>> YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A DRIVE
WHERE HE'S THROWING THE BALL
FOUR TIMES?
>> SCREENING McCAFFREY.
>> A BARE MINIMUM, THE LAST
DRIVE THE SEAHAWKS GET --
>> IF THEY'RE DOWN TWO, YEAH.
>> GO TO THE FOURTH QUARTER.
GO NOT FOURTH QUARTER.
HEY, FOURTH QUARTER!
FOURTH QUARTER!
>> FOUR'S IN THE AIR, FOURTH
QUARTER!
>> ALL RIGHT.
VIBE CHECK ON THE PARLAY.
HOW DO WE THINK WE'RE DOING?
>> I'VE BEEN IN A WORST SPOT
BEFORE.
>> WE'RE TRACKING.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO --
>> NOT TOTALLY DEAD.
>> IF THE NINERS THROW, GENO'S
GOING TO HAVE TO THROW.
HE'S AT 18.
>> OVER, OKAY --
>> HE'S BEEN HITTING LOCKETT.
>> LOCKETT'S ON 30.
>> 30, THAT'S PRETTY GOOD.
>> I MEAN, THE NINERS ARE
ALREADY UP MINUS 2 1/2.
>> 2 1/2 LOOKS GOOD.
>> D.K. IS STILL ON TWO --
>> I TOOK D.K. TWO.
>> AS A HEDGE ON THE --
>> LIVE BET?
ANNOUNCE IT.
>> TWO LIVE BETS, BOTH RITTER
AND I ON D.K. METCALF TO SCORE
ANOTHER TOUCHDOWN.
>> 9-1.
>> WHAT?
>> 49ers ARE GOING TO SCORE
HERE.
>> THOSE ARE THE VIBES?
>> I LOVE THE IDEA --
>> NO --
>> THERE IS NO MIDDLE GROUND.
>> NO KITTLE, NO AIYUK, NO
DEEBO?
>> NO WAY POINTS DOCTORING TO
SCORE FOR RITTER TO LOSE --
>> WHAT'S THE VALUE?
>> HOW MANY VALUE PLAYS DO YOU
ACTUALLY WIN?
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY VALUE?
>> IT'S LONG-TERM, MAN.
>> WHATEVER YOU MEAN --
>> IT'S THE GET RICH PLAN.
THE GET RICH PLAN IS --
>> YEAH, I'M NORMALLY ON TEAM
GET RICH.
BUT WITH OUR CHATS PARLAYS, I'VE
BEEN STARTING TO LEAN TOWARDS
TEAM LET'S HIT THEM.
>> THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
>> I'M SORRY.
>> MY PERSONAL LIFE, I'M TEAM
GET RICH.
>> REMEMBER WHEN MATTHEW
McCONAUGHEY WON BEST ACTOR AT
THE ACADEMY AWARDS?
>> WACKO SPEECH?
>> HE WAS LIKE, PEOPLE ASK ME
WHO MY HERO IS, I SAY, "MYSELF
TEN YEARS FROM NOW."
IF THE GET RICH PARLAY DOESN'T
HIT IN THE MOMENT, WE CAN ASPIRE
TO IT.
>> IS EVERYONE DONE?
>> YEAH.
>> GREG, YOU'RE BEING STRAIGHT
UP ON CAMERA --
>> WE CAN SAY WE TRIED, RIGHT?
>> HE CUT IT, YOU CAN SEE IT,
WATCH.
HE CUT IT OFF.
WATCH WHEN YOU GO RIGHT ACROSS
THE SCREEN HERE IN A SECOND.
YOU CAN TELL.
>> HE CUT IT, THOUGH, THAT'S A
GOOD CUT.
>> OH, MAN.
>> MELLY'S GOOD.
>> SHOUT-OUT MELLY.
>> SHOUT-OUT MELLY, THAT'S ME.
>> I WAS JUST ABOUT TO SAY, YOU
KNOW WHAT I HAVEN'T SEEN, ELI
MITCHELL.
I'M GLAD HERE IN THE GAME.
RUN IT HERE.
RUN IT HERE, SAM.
KEEP THAT CLOCK MOVING.
BROCK, MAKE A PLAY ON THIRD
DOWN, IF HE DOESN'T, GO, GO --
>> WE'VE GOT TO GET ONE MORE
FIRST SO WE CAN KICK THE FIELD
GOAL.
>> NO MORE SCORING.
NO MORE SCORING.
END THE GAME.
>> HE'S OPEN.
>> YES!
>> OH!
DID HE GET TOUCHED?
>> I THINK HE GOT TOUCHED.
>> THAT'S GOT TO BE THE OVER.
>> WAIT, I THINK TOUCHDOWN.
>> HE GOT TOUCHED.
>> MIGHT NOT, MIGHT NOT HAVE.
>> HOW FAR WAS THAT RECEPTION?
>> WHAT DO YOU HAVE?
>> OVER 17 RECEIVING YARDS.
>> THAT WAS LIKE 30, LIKE 40
YARDS.
>> WHAT IF THEY DIDN'T TOUCH
HIM?
>> LIKE RIGHT HERE, TOUCH.
>> LET'S GO.
>> NICE.
>> JUST NEEDED ONE.
>> TOUCHDOWN TWO.
>> THAT'S A GOOD BET, RITTER.
>> THERE WE GO.
>> I LOVE EVERY TIME I HEAR -- I
ALWAYS THINK OF --
>> THAT LOCKS IN ODDS, LOCKS IT
IN, ODD.
>> I NEVER LOOK.
>> THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN -- THAT
WAS A SCREENPLAY.
>> I TOLD YOU.
>> IT WAS OPEN.
>> DUDE.
>> HE WASN'T OPEN.
>> THAT WAS --
>> NO MORE SCORING.
>> GOING FOR A STRIKE THERE.
>> SCARY THE WAY HE DID THAT.
>> THAT WAS A LITTLE TOO ISKY.
>> HEY, MY BOY.
>> HE'S BEEN TALKING ABOUT
MAHOMES, TRYING TO PLAY LIKE
MAHOMES.
>> GIVE ME EIGHT.
NEED EIGHT.
>> I NEED IT.
THEY GET EIGHT, THAT IS --
>> BROCK PURDY TRIBUTE, STEVE
WEBBER, WILD.
>> ZACH WEBBER?
>> SO OPEN.
>> GET RID OF IT, GET RID OF IT.
>> HE'S ALL RIGHT.
>> OH!
>> HE'S ALL RIGHT, HE KNOWS HOW
TO GO THROUGH THE FIRST.
BROCK PURDY!
>> NEGATIVE ONE YARD?
>> BROCK PURDY --
>> WHOA, WHOA!
>> GET OUT OF IT, DEEBO!
>> WE'VE GOT TO GET TWO.
>> YEAH, DEEBO!
>> WOW.
BRUISE THE OVER.
>> I DIDN'T REALIZE.
>> I WAS DOWN.
>> HE LOOKED LIKE -- WHO DOES HE
LOOK LIKE?
WHO DOES HE LOOK LIKE?
>> GUYS, THE SEAHAWKS ARE NOT
GOING TO KICK A FIELD GOAL
ANYMORE.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GO FOR TWO.
THEY'RE GOING TO GO FOR TWO --
IT'S GOING TO COME DOWN TO
WHETHER OR NOT THE SEAHAWKS GO
FOR TWO THE FIRST TIME THEY
SCORE A TOUCHDOWN.
>> LET'S GO, BROCK.
>> THEY KICK THE P.A.T. --
>> LET'S GO, GET THE TWO, GET
THE TWO!
>> THIS IS HUGE FOR US.
>> THAT MADE BY EXTENDING THE
PLAY.
>> I HONESTLY DON'T WANT HIM TO
GET IT.
HEY, GUYS.
IT'S GOING TO STAY EVEN.
IF THEY GET THIS, IT'S STAYING
EVEN.
>> I THOUGHT YOU SAID YOU WANTED
THE TWO.
>> I DID THE MATH IN MY HEAD.
I NEED THEM TO NOT GET THIS SO
BAD.
>> GOT IT.
THAT'S IN.
>> YEP.
>> THAT'S HUGE.
SORRY, BRO.
>> GOT THAT IF THE FOOTTY.
>> MAVS HARD.
IF IT'S AT 48 --
>> I WAS THINKING THE 15.
>> YOU NEED ANOTHER SCORE.
YOU NEED THIS NOT TO BE THE
FINAL SCORE.
>> THERE'S NO WAY IT IS.
>> YOU DON'T THINK SO?
>> LET'S GO, BABY.
LET'S GO, LET'S GO!
>> WE'RE GOING TO GET IT.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET IT.
>> YEAH.
>> YES, SIR.
>> HM.
>> WHAT UP, BRIAN?
>> NOT MUCH, MAN.
I NEED A SEAHAWKS FIELD GOAL.
THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN 11 1/2
DOESN'T SOUND SO CRAZY.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> 14 1/2 --
>> YOU THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
KICK A FIELD GOAL DOWN 14?
>> SORRY --
>> WE'RE WEIR IN THE PARLAY.
>> IN THEY'RE RE, YOU NEED
SCORING OPPORTUNITY.
>> WHAT DO WE -- WHAT'S HURTING
US STILL?
>> McCAFFREY, McCAFFREY,
McCAFFREY.
>> WELL, NO --
>> THE 49ers ARE GOING TO COVER.
GENO SMITH IS GOING TO BE TOUGH
BECAUSE HE NEEDS 12.
BUT I CAN'T IMAGINE --
>> IT'S PROBABLY THE McCAFFREY
ONE THAT SEEMS THE LEAST LIKELY.
LOCKETT AND SMITH, IF THEY'RE
GOING TO THROW IT --
>> I COULD -- I WILL SAY I CAN
SEE THE NINERS GETTING IN SECOND
AND 8, RUNNING A SCREEN --
>> JUWAN JENNINGS.
>> ONE I COULD SEE.
>> THAT GREEN.
>> WHAT'S THE CAT SAYING?
>> NO, NO, T HUFANGA.
>> YEAH, HIT.
>> IS THAT TRUE?
>> WHAT'S THE CHAT SAYING?
>> TONY BONES, KILL JUST MOSSED
HIM.
>> HOW'S THE CHAT FEEL --
>> FEELS GOOD ABOUT LOCKETT.
>> MHB4, IF HE SCORES A 50-YARD
TOUCHDOWN, HE'LL DONATE 50K TO
CHARITY.
>> SCORE A 50-YARD TOUCHDOWN?
>> DONATEFYK TO CHARITY.
>> GOES TO 12, SHOULD GIVE 12K?
THAT'S KIND OF WEIRD.
>> WHAT'S THE Y?
>> I AM NOT UPDATING THIS.
>> YOU'RE ALMOST TRYING TO GET
OUT OF DOING CHARITY AT THAT
POINT.
>> YEAH, I DON'T GET IT.
>> HOW DO YOU MAKE THAT GREEN?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
>> DAWSON KNOCKS ATTS AND ALL
40 --
>> THE GUY IN THE CHAT TOLD US
TO CALM DOWN, HE'S A SECOND HALF
PLAYER.
>> YEAH?
>> BROCK PURDY'S OUT THERE
BALLING.
>> WHOPPER WHOPPER WHOPPER
WHOPPER WHOPPER WHOPPER.
>> YEAH, SMACK HIM!
SMACK HIM!
COME ON, MAN!
STOP PLAYING.
D.K.
>> WE GOT A TEDDY FRIDGEWATER IN
THE CHAT.
>> TEDDY FRIDGEWATER?
>> TEDDY FRIDGEWATER.
>> THAT IS AN AMAZING --
>> FRIDGEWATER.
>> COULD BE FRAUDWATER.
>> THEY COULD HAVE DONE
FRAUDWATER.
>> IT IS INCREDIBLY IMPRESSIVE
THAT MY BEST BET OF MITCHELL
OVER 38 1/2 YARDS HAS MINUS 1
YARD.
>> YOU GUYS, MINUS 1 YARD
RUSHING, 25 YARDS.
>> THAT IS TOUGH.
>> THAT'S -- I LOVE THAT.
>> HERE'S ONE.
HERE'S ONE.
>> I DON'T LOVE IT, BUT YOU GET
IT.
>> NICE.
>> OH, GOD.
>> IMAGINE.
>> METCALF IS PLAYING TOO WELL.
>> REALLY WELL.
>> IMAGINE BEING THE GUY --
>> DID YOU BET ANYTHING D.K.
METCALF RELATED?
>> I DID, I HAD OVER 4 1/2.
>> I HAD TO THIN IT --
>> I DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
>> IT WAS THE BEST BET, IT WAS
THE BEST BET.
>> DID YOU BET IT?
>> YEAH, DID I BET IT?
B
DOES A BEAR POOP IN THE WOODS?
>> I'M NOT A BIG BEAR GUY,
MYSELF.
>> BRYCE, I'M PREPPING --
>> WHY ARE WE RUNNING?
>> CAN'T WAIT.
>> FLAG?
>> BRINGING IT BACK.
>> BRINGING THAT BACK.
>> WHOA, WHOA, THAT WAS KIND OF
DIRTY.
>> LOOKS LIKE INTENTIONAL FACE
MASK.
>> THAT'S GOOD.
>> BRINGING IT BACK, BRINGING IT
BACK, BACK BRING IT BACK, BACK.
>> I LOVE FOUR PENALTIES IN THIS
ENTIRE GAME.
>> WE'VE GOT TO STOP THEM RIGHT
NOW AND GET GENO PASSING FOR 22.
STOP THEM RIGHT NOW.
GET THE BALL BACK.
THEY WILL THROW TWO MORE PASSES
TO CHRISTIAN McCAFFREY.
WHETHER OR NOT HE CATCHES THEM
IS UP TO US.
NOT UP TO US, SORRY.
>> NO, NO, DON'T PUT THAT ON US,
THAT'S NOT UP TO US.
>> FALSE START.
>> WOW.
>> WHAT ARE THEY DOING?
>> THEY MIGHT SOB BACKED UP
THEY'RE GOING TO RUN IT NOW.
>> NO, NOT DOWN TWO TOUCHDOWNS.
>> IT'S KIND OF CRAZY.
I FEEL THE SEAHAWKS HAVE
ACTUALLY PLAYED PRETTY WELL.
>> PRETTY WELL.
>> ALL THINGS CONSIDERED.
FEEL LIKE THEY'D GOT SOMEONE
BREAKS GOING THEIR WAY -- THE
FUMBLE IS TOUGH, THAT'S BAD.
>> THYMEOUT?
>> PETE!
>> HE'S GOT THE CLOCK GOING,
MAN, COME ON.
>> TED FRIMGWATER, GREAT NAME.
>> HOW'S THE CHAT DOING THIS.
>> FEELING GOOD ABOUT LOCKETT,
SAYS JACK CAN.
>> YEAH?
>> YEAH.
>> WE'LL TAKE THOSE VIBES.
NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE TO GO OUR
WAY.
>> BRYSON SWEATING.
>> YEAH, AGREED.
>> NOTHING TOO BIG.
>> TRYING TO GO DEEP.
D.K.
>> YEP.
>> OH, BOY.
>> WOW.
>> WOW!
>> TOLD Y'ALL.
>> HE HAD THE STAT.
>> THAT WAS DANGER OF PASS
INTERFERENCE.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS.
>> HE PULLED HIM RIGHT HERE,
WATCH.
>> TOOK HIS TOWEL OFF.
>> WHAT ARE YOU ROOTING FOR,
BRI?
>> HE'S ROOTING FOR THE SCORE TO
CHANGE.
>> ROOTING FOR A CLEAN GAME.
>> THAT'S AN INCOMPLETION,
THAT'S BIG, 19, 20.
>> PLAY TWO SAFETIES.
DON'T DO THE ONE SAFETY THING.
TWO SAFETIES UP TOP.
>> PLEASE DON'T THROW THE BALL
BACKWARDS.
>> GO GET 'EM, BOSA.
>> GOING BACK TO HIM.
>> WHAT'S THE FLAG?
>> THAT'S GOT TO BE --
>> HE DID PUSH OFF, LINED UP.
>> OH!
>> IT'S FINE.
>> LOOK AT THAT, THROW THAT.
>> I THINK IT'S ON SEATTLE.
>> THAT WAS WEIRD.
>> THAT'S HIM.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> THEY'RE GOING TO RUN THE
BALL, 100%.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN DO
THAT IN THE PLAYOFFS, DOWN TWO
SCORES.
BUT YOU'RE PROBABLY RIGHT.
>> SECOND AND 30.
>> WELL --
>> DECLINE THAT, RIGHT?
>> WHO IS DOWNFIELD?
16?
>> 68.
>> OH, 68.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S NOT A --
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY.
>> IF YOU'RE PAST MORE THAN ONE
YARD.
IF IT'S TWO YARDS, OFF THE
FIELD.
>> DANG.
>> THIRD AND -- THIRD DOWN?
>> DECLINED.
>> OH, THAT'S RIGHT.
>> WE STILL GET THE PASS
ATTEMPTS.
>> YEAH, YEAH, THAT'S BIG.
>> WE'RE GOOD, WE'RE TRACKING.
WE'RE TRACKING.
WE NEED McCAFFREY.
>> LOCKING IN THE BOTTOM, RIGHT?
>> WHY DO THEY NOT CONE IT?
>> GO GET 'EM, BOSA.
>> NICE.
>> WHY WAS THAT NOT TO LOCK AT
THE TIME?
>> THIS IS WHEN YOU COME INTO
PLAY, VINCE.
ELI, THAT 30 YARDS, I'M TELLING
YOU.
I MEAN, I'M TELLING YOU, THEY
ABOUT TO RUN THE BALL.
>> STILL AT MINUS 1.
I'LL TAKE ANYTHING AT THIS
POINT.
>> WE NEED 15 YARDS FOR LOCKETT
AS WELL.
I THINK AT THIS POINT, 22 PASS
ATTEMPTS FOR GENO.
>> I FEEL DAK AND LOCKETT ARE
FAIRLY GETTABLE.
>> THE GENO THING I THINK IS
GOING TO HAPPEN, WE NEED THE
BALL BACK TWICE.
>> WHEN THEY'RE IN GARBAGE TIME,
I WOULD THINK SOMETHING GOES TO
LOCKETT THERE.
>> YEAH.
>> I'M WORRIED ABOUT McCAFFREY'S
RECEPTIONS.
>> THERE WE GO.
>> KYLE SHANAHAN'S AN IDIOT.
HE WILL THROW THE BALL.
>> RAY-RAY CAN FLY.
RAY-RAY'S GOOD, BRO.
>> HAVE YOU SEEN --
>> 49ers ARE GOING TO THROW THE
BALL.
>> HOW MANY TIMES HAVE WE HAD TO
WATCH KYLE SHANAHAN MELT DOWN?
>> I MEAN --
>> I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
THROW.
>> HE'S ASK CONSERVATIVE.
>> MIGHT THROW BUT --
>> IF THEY'RE GOING TO THROW --
>> KYLE SHANAHAN, THEY'RE GOING
TO THROW THE BALL.
>> THEY ARE.
>> THEY MIGHT THROW TO BE
HONEST, THEY MIGHT.
BUT I LIKE --
>> PASS ME THE WATER.
>> THANK YOU.
>> UH-HUH.
>> THAT'S TWO FOR BRYSON.
>> I DON'T BLAME YOU, VINCE.
THIS IS NOT EASY, MAN.
THIS WAS A POINT WHERE I WAS
2-1.
I WAS REALLY --
>> THAT'S TOUGH.
>> I KNOW, THAT WAS --
>> ONLY 66%?
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S TOUGH.
>> THOSE WERE THE DARK DAYS FOR
ME.
>> WHAT DID YOU DO THE REST OF
YOUR LIFE DAY?
>> I KNOW.
I LOST SLEEP.
NOW I'M BACK ON THE MOUNTAINTOP,
HITTING 80% AGAIN, THE PEOPLE
ARE GETTING RICH, I'M GETTING
RICH.
>> NICE.
>> YEAH, IT'S GOOD.
>> 7-2, 8-2?
>> D.K. HIT LIKE FIVE
RECEPTIONS.
IT WAS ALMOST OVER IN THE FIRST
HALF.
>> DID THAT CASH?
>> I DIDN'T --
>> DID THAT --
>> IT DID, YEAH, YEAH.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF WE WANT TO
TAKE THE SPREADSHEET SO WE SEE
THE --
>> YEAH OH, YEAH, LET'S DO A
LITTLE SPREADSHEET.
>> TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF A
SPREADSHEET.
>> YEAH.
HOLD ON, HOLD ON.
>> RYAN'S INPUTTING -- IS THAT
HIS?
THAT'S RITTER'S.
>> EVERYWHERE I TAKE THE
SPREADSHEET, I THINK THAT'S A
GOOD IDEA.
WE'LL SEE.
>> THERE'S NO REASON TO, LIKE,
SHOW OFF.
I MEAN, WE'RE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER.
>> RITTER, WHO'S YOUR FAVORITE
"MASKED SINGER" JUDGE?
>> ROBIN THICKE.
>> YEAH, I CAN SEE THAT.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT -- THAT "MASKED SINGER"
CLIP OF KERMIT THE FROG COMING
OUT OF THE COSTUME IS
OBJECTIVELY ONE OF THE FUNNIEST
THINGS.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF EYE SEEN
THAT.
>> ALL-TIME TELEVISION CLIP.
>> IT'S LIKE ACTUALLY THE --
>> IT'S "THE MASKS SINGER."
THEY'RE LIKE, WHO IS IT?
YOU SEE THESE LITTLE HANDS PEEK
OVER AND ALL THE JUDGES GO --
IT'S KERMIT THE FROG.
AND THEY JUST LOSE IT.
>> THAT'S FUNNY.
>> I'VE NEVER WATCHED THAT SHOW.
>> IF YOU LIKE -- IF YOU'RE
WATCHING THIS AND YOU LIKE
"MASKS SINGER" WE'LL GIVE YOU
SOME SOCKS.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT I DO LIKE,
RIHANNA HALFTIME SHOW.
>> OH, YEAH, RIHANNA, NOTED METS
FAN.
>> IS THAT TRUE?
>> YES.
>> LeBRON FAN?
>> I'M PRETTY SURE THAT'S NOT
BASEBALL.
>> I'M PRETTY SURE SHE'S NEVER
BEEN TO A METS GAME IN HER LIFE.
>> LET'S LOCK IT.
>> THAT IS ACCURATE.
>> NO WAY.
>> I DON'T SEE RIHANNA IN
QUEENS.
>> THAT'S NOT IN QUEENS.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT.
>> IT'S A METS SHIRT.
>> THEY THREW THE BALL.
>> LOOK UP ANNE HATHAWAY --
>> OH, NO, NO, NO --
>> IS THAT REAL?
>> ANNE HATHAWAY WEARING A
WOODHEAD JERSEY.
CHARGERS WOODHEAD.
>> YEAH.
ISN'T THAT AN AMAZING PICTURE?
>> MAHOMES DIDN'T DO THAT.
>> THE CHARGERS LATER --
>> OH, WHAT DID I SAY?
>> OH MY GOD, OF COURSE THEY
ARE.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> HOW'S THAT, DEEBO?
>> THERE HE GOES, THERE HE GOES.
>> LET'S GO, LET'S GO!
>> HOW'S THAT, DEEBO?
>> HE JUST JOGGED.
>> WOW.
>> HOW'S THAT, DEEBO?
>> UNDER 10 MINUTES LEFT?
>> WOW.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> SEE YA.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> THAT'S IT.
>> THAT'S DEFINITELY IT.
>> YEAH, IT'S OVER.
>> WHAT DOES HE HAVE?
TWO RECEPTIONS?
>> YEAH.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> RUSHING YARDS --
>> DRIVE THE LAST A LITTLE --
>> THIS DRAMA IS GOING TO BE
PRICELESS.
>> WHICH IS -- THAT'S WHY WE'RE
HERE, THAT'S WHY WE DID THIS.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> DO I WANT TO SIT HERE ON ODD
FOR 10 1/2 MINUTES?
WHAT I NEED -- THERE'S NO FIELD
GOALS.
NO FIELD GOALS FOR THE SEAHAWKS
ANYMORE, WHICH IS GOOD FOR ME.
I NEED THE SEAHAWKS TO DRIVE.
>> NINERS WOULD KICK A FIELD
GOAL.
55, 41 -- AM I DOING THE MATH
RIGHT?
>> ANY SCORE IS GOING TO PUT ME
EVEN.
>> YEAH, YEAH, OKAY.
TOO MUCH MATH HERE, MAN.
>> I KNOW.
>> IN BETTING IN GENERAL, RIGHT?
CRUNCHING NUMBERS ALL DAY.
>> I NEED A SEAHAWKS DRIVE.
I NEED THEM TO GET STOPPED.
I NEED THE NINERS TO MILK THE --
OUT OF THE CLOCK.
>> LONG DRIVE HERE.
>> A PARLAY YOU DIDN'T TELL
ANYBODY ABOUT?
>> IT'S EVERYONE'S MINIMUM
RECEIVING YARDS.
IT'S PRETTY BRYSON-Y, HONESTLY.
>> I LOVE THAT.
>> DEAD AIR.
>> BAD VIBES.
BAD VIBES FROM THE SEAHAWKS
CORNER OVER HERE.
>> RIGHT SIDE, BAD BEAT
SITUATION.
>> I'M NOT READY TO GIVE UP ON
IT.
>> YOU CAN SEE YOURSELF -- DO
YOU CONSIDER YOURSELF AN
OPTIMIST, PESSIMIST?
>> HE'S A METS FAN.
>> IT'S A SEASON.
>> AS I CONSIDER MYSELF ONE OF
THE TOP-TIER PESSIMISTS OF OUR
TIME --
>> YEAH, I MEAN, THE VIBES FOR
YOU --
>> I WOULD SAY 0% CHANCE.
>> I CAN'T LIVE LIKE THAT.
TWO REASONS.
ONE, WE'RE LIVE IN THE BR APP
RIGHT NOW.
>> SHOUT-OUT THE APP.
>> SOME OF US, THE VIBES CAN BE
DEAD FOR 20 MINUTES, YOU KNOW.
WE'RE OKAY WITH THAT.
THAT'S NOT ME, THAT'S NOT WHO I
AM, KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> A MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
>> I AM THE MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
ALL WE'VE GOT TO DO -- ALSO,
D.K. SCORES HERE, THAT MAKES UP
EASILY FOR THE LOSS.
>> HEY, OKAY.
>> LIKE RITTER SAID.
>> BUT IT WAS NEXT TD, RIGHT?
>> ANY TIME, YEAH, YEAH.
>> OKAY.
>> I WILL SAY --
>> SHOUT-OUT B.K.!
>> I WILL SAY IT'S TOUGH BECAUSE
THEY'RE GOING TO NEED TWO
TOUCHDOWNS.
THE 9 1/2 THEN LOOKS BETTER THAN
TAKING THE 11 1/2.
THIS IS NOT A FIELD GOAL
SITUATION ANYMORE.
>> YEAH, WELL.
>> IT LOOKED GOOD FOR A SECOND.
>> IT DID.
>> YEAH.
>> THE SEAHAWKS PLAYED WELL.
>> THEY PLAYED WELL.
>> YOU KNOW WHO WOULD HAVE WON
THIS GAME, THE LIONS.
THE LIONS WOULD HAVE WON THIS
GAME.
THE LIONS WOULDN'T HAVE FUMBLED.
>> BROCK PURDY IS THE TRUTH,
Y'ALL.
I WANT TO UNDERSTAND, WE ARE
WATCHING GRATEFUL.
THREE PASSING TOUCHDOWNS, ONE
RUSHING TOUCHDOWNS, NO
INTERCEPTIONS, GREATNESS.
>> I LIKE TWO.
>> HE'S 49ers QUARTERBACK --
>> BURNERS.
>> TURNED IT ON.
>> HE'S THE STARTING QUARTERBACK
NEXT YEAR.
>> ABSOLUTELY STARTING
QUARTERBACK NEXT YEAR.
TREY LANCE PROBABLY IS GOING TO
GET TRADED THIS OFFSEASON.
>> PROBABLY FOR NOTHING, THOUGH.
>> FOR NOTHING?
HE'S THE BEST -- IF TREY LANCE
CAME OUT THIS YEAR, HE WOULD BE
ONE OF THE BETTER QUARTERBACKS
COMING OUT THIS YEAR.
>> TREY LANCE?
>> CHILL OUT.
>> YOU KNOW WHO COULD SCREW THAT
UP, THOUGH?
>> OH, LET'S GO!
>> GAME ON.
>> THAT'S GAME.
>> IF I WERE THE NINERS, I WOULD
STICK WITH BROCK.
I THINK BRADY IS GOING TO
WANT --
>> BROCK IS -- I THINK BRADY IS
GOING TO TRY --
>> MISERABLE.
>> YEAH, I DON'T -- I DON'T WANT
BRADY, I WANT BROCK.
>> BROCK BEAT HIS ASS.
>> BROCK BEAT HIM, WOULD BEAT
HIM BAD.
>> I FEEL LIKE THIS ACTUALLY IS
GOOD --
>> HOW DO THEY GET THEIR DOG
INSIDE --
>> WE'LL BE OFF --
>> GOT A GOOD PARLAY IN.
>> THEN THE QUESTION IS --
REMEMBER WHEN THEY WON --
>> NO, I'M SCREWED.
>> LIVE AND IN PERSON --
>> LETTING IT RIDE.
>> WHAT DO WE NEED?
WE NEED TWO TODDIES.
>> TWO TODDIES, AND A NO SCORE
HERE.
>> ELI MITCHELL, MINUS TWO.
>> YEAH, THAT'S A TOUGH BEAT.
>> A REALLY BAD BEAT.
>> A TOUGH BEAT.
THAT'S A TOUGH, TOUGH BEAT.
>> IT'S A TOUGH BEAT.
YOU SEE, THIS IS -- AND LIKE --
THIS IS PART OF THE PROCEEDS.
>> NINERS ARE GOING TO CATCH THE
OVER THEMSELVES.
>> BETS IN A SEASON, YOUR
RECORD --
>> IT'S TRUE.
>> THIS IS WHEN 17 --
>> 17, IT LOOKS LIKE A WALK IN
THE PARK.
>> THEY PLAYED SO WELL.
>> WHY ARE YOU SO QUIET?
DON'T YOU GOT A 49er FUTURE?
>> I DO.
I'M PRETTY HAPPY ABOUT THIS.
I JOUST THOUGHT THIS WAS GOING
TO BE A CLOSER GAME.
I WAS WRONG.
>> NO, THAT'S WHY YOU --
>> CLOSE GAME, THE SCORE DOESN'T
SAY THAT.
>> GO DOWN, DEEBO.
>> OH MY GOD, DUDE.
>> THAT'S HOW YOU HURT YOURSELF.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY.
>> GO DOWN.
>> I FEEL LIKE IT'S NEARING THE
POINT OF, LET'S GET THESE GUYS
OUT OF THERE.
>> YEAH, STOP.
>> YEAH.
>> JAWING.
>> ESPECIALLY DEEBO, WHO IS
COMING BACK FROM INJURY.
>> IF THE NINERS CAN SCORE --
>> WHAT WAS DEEBO'S INJURY?
>> PULL YOUR STARTERS.
>> WASN'T IT ANKLE?
>> I WANT YOU TO LOOK AT BROCK
PURDY'S STAT LINE.
323, 3 PASSING TOUCHDOWNS, 1
RUSHING TOUCHDOWN, A RATING OF
OVER 130.
>> IT'S SO CRAZY TO SEE HIM DO
THIS, AS SOMEONE WHO WATCHED
HIM.
>> YOU BET IOWA STATE SO MUCH
WHEN HE WAS THERE.
>> EIGHT PASS ATTEMPTS TO GO,
GREG WAS LIKE, PURDY AIN'T
PICKING UP, HE AIN'T DOING
NOTHING.
>> GUESS WHAT HE DID?
HE PICKED IT UP.
I TOLD HIM WHAT TO DO, BRYSON.
>> YEAH, IT'S A HIT.
>> YOU CALLED IT IN THE SECOND
HALF.
>> I TOLD HIM TO LOCK IN, BRO,
YOU'VE GOT TO LOCK IN, AND WHAT
DID HE DO?
THANK YOU, HE LOCKED IN, BABY.
>> 350.
>> I'M THE FIRST TO SAY IT.
>> I AM NOW ALL-IN.
I NEED THAT.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, YOU KNOW --
>> IF THEY KICK A FIELD GOAL --
>> I'M RUINED, I'M RUINED.
>> THEN THE SEAHAWKS, WHEN THEY
SCORE, WOULD GO FOR TWO.
YOU CAN'T HAVE A FIELD GOAL.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT, I'M SO DEAD.
>> DID WE GAIN A YARD?
>> MITCHELL.
>> ARE WE AT NEGATIVE FIVE
YARDS?
>> MIGHT BE MORE THAN THAT.
>> WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO CLIP
THAT.
>> YEAH.
>> THE THING IS, THOUGH --
>> NEGATIVE FIVE YARDS?
>> THEY WILL.
IN A PLAYOFF.
>> BEST BET.
>> EVEN IF THERE'S A --
>> YEAH, YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
IT.
LIKE THE STAT, ON THE SCREEN.
>> OH, GOD.
>> McCAFFREY'S OUT, THE PARLAY'S
DEAD.
>> NEGATIVE TWO.
>> HE'S NOT OUT THERE AT ALL.
>> HE MUST HAVE HAD A POSITIVE
PLAY.
>> BEGS THE QUESTION WHY THEY'RE
SIGNIFICANT GIVING THE BALL TO
DEEBO.
>> THAT'S A FAIR POINT.
DEEBO SHOULD NOT BE TOUCHING THE
BALL.
>> THERE WE GO.
>> HEY!
>> BACK TO YOU.
>> THAT'S WHAT YOU SAW IN HIM.
>> NEED A FIRST.
>> I FEEDED A LITTLE BIT MORE
THAN THAT, BUT WE'LL TAKE IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
OH, NO.
>> YOU KNOW IT WOULD BE --
>> NO FIRST DOWN.
>> GUYS, HEAR ME OUT.
McCAFFREY'S COMING IN.
FIRST DOWN.
THIRD AND 6.
SCREENPLAY.
>> WE'RE NOT BRINGING HIM IN IN
FIELD GOAL RANGE, UP 21, HE'S
DEAD.
>> I THINK THAT MIGHT BE WHAT'S
HIS NAME, JORDAN MASON.
>> BET, HE BACK THERE, 23.
YO, WATCH THIS SCREENPLAY.
I KNOW KYLE SHANAHAN, HE RAN THE
BALL --
>> NEED A FIRST, NEED A FIRST.
>> NO, WE'RE IN THE DEAD ZONE.
ALMOST TO THE DEAD ZONE.
>> RIGHT, BUT IF YOU CAN STOP,
YOU'RE 100% OVER, YOU HAVE LIFE.
>> THE DEAD ZONE.
>> YOU HAVE LIFE, THOUGH.
>> THEY SCORE A TOUCHDOWN --
>> THEY SCORE A TOUCHDOWN, WE'RE
EVEN.
WHICH IS GOOD.
>> SEAHAWKS ARE DONE.
>> IF THEY KICK A FIELD GOAL,
I'M SO DEAD, BECAUSE THE
SEAHAWKS WILL GO FOR TWO.
IF THERE'S A FIELD GOAL, 0%
CHANCE OF WINNING FOR BRYSON.
>> SEAHAWKS COULD KICK A SERVING
THEMSELVES.
>> A SAD FIELD GOAL.
>> VERY SAD FIELD GOAL.
THAT WOULD BE AMAZING IF I HIT
THIS ON A VERY SAD FIELD GOAL.
THAT WOULD BE AMAZING.
>> AFTER WHAT HAPPENED THE LAST
TIME WE DID ONE OF THESE
STRINGS?
0%.
>> TALK ABOUT A THROWBACK.
>> THAT WOULD BE GOOD RECEPTION.
>> GARBAGE TIME FIELD GOAL TO GO
OUR WAY THIS TIME.
>> B.K.37 DROPPED A SAME GAME
PAR HEY FOR TONIGHT.
TREVOR LAWRENCE, 225-PLUS
PASSING YARDS.
KEENAN ALLEN, 70-PLUS RECEIVING
YARDS.
>> I LIKE THAT.
>> AUSTIN EKELER, 25-PLUS
RECEIVING YARDS.
>> I LIKE THAT.
>> EKELER TOUCHDOWN, ETN
TOUCHDOWN.
>> MELLY COOK?
>> PRETTY GAME SCRIPTY.
>> WITH TWO TOUCHDOWNS?
>> I'M NEVER DRINKING AGAIN.
>> I'M NOT.
NO ALCOHOL TODAY.
>> B.K. IS DUE FOR ONE.
>> IS HE?
>> OH, YEAH.
>> BROCK PURDY KIND OF REMINDS
ME OF --
>> I LOVE THE AVATAR, B.K.,
THAT --
♪ B.K. HAVE IT YOUR WAY ♪
>> D.K.?
>> DANNY DIMES HAD A REALLY GOOD
SEASON.
>> AWESOME YEAR.
>> HE PLAYED VERY WELL.
>> CONSTANTLY IMPROVING, THAT
GUY.
>> YEAH.
>> TELLING YOU, WE GET DeANDRE
HOP
HOPKINS?
>> THEY'RE GOING TO GIVE HIM A
NEW CONTRACT THIS YEAR.
>> YEAH, PROBABLY A THREE-YEAR
DEAL, $30 MILLION A YEAR.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> I'M FINE WITH THAT,I THINK
THAT'S A GOOD --
>> THERE'S YOUR BOY.
>> IT'S A GOOD BRIDGE.
>> CAPPED ELI MITCHELL.
SECOND HALF GUY.
>> I THINK WE HAVE THE THIRD
MOST --
>> I WATCHED THESE BULLS.
THEY USED McCAFFREY IN THE FIRST
HALF.
THEN THE SECOND HALF, TO RUN THE
BALL, THEY USE OUR SPELL RUNNING
BACK.
MASON, ELI MITCHELL.
WHEN THEY NEED A PLAY, THEY PUT
McCAFFREY BACK WITH FRESH LEGS.
>> THAT'S THE RIGHT WAY.
>> I AGREE.
>> NOT RUNNING THEM INTO THE
GROUND.
>> CAROLINA, EXACTLY, EXACTLY.
>> SITUATIONALLY.
>> EXACTLY.
>> HE MOVED FRESH.
>> AND WE'RE BACK.
>> UNBELIEVABLE.
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW I'D BE
FEELING RIGHT NOW IF I HAD EVEN.
HOW I WOULD BE FEELING?
I STILL WOULD FEEL LIKE I'M
DEAD.
>> FIELD GOAL, 99.9% CHANCE.
>> 0% CHANCE THAT ODD HITS?
>> A FIELD GOAL HERE, 0% ODD
HITS, UNFORTUNATELY.
>> THAT WAS A DIME.
>> THAT WAS INCREDIBLE.
>> YEAH.
>> BROCK, YOU NEED A TUG.
>> RUN IT, BOY.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> TAKE YOUR TURN.
>> Y'ALL WANT TO KNOW WHO HE
LOOK LIKE?
OH!
>> OH!
>> YOU WANT TO KNOW WHO HE LOOK
LIKE?
GODDAMMIT, I NEEDED THAT.
>> THAT'S SUCH A GOOD THROW.
>> HOLY --
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE HE GOT THAT
BALL THERE.
>> Y'ALL KNOW WHO HE LOOK LIKE?
Y'ALL KNOW WHO HE LOOK LIKE?
HE LOOK LIKE 1-5 FROM KANSAS
C
CITY.
>> THAT IS SUCH A GOOD THROW,
DUDE.
OH MY GOD.
>> I DON'T THINK HE EXPECTED IT
TO GET TO HIM.
>> I DON'T THINK HE DID EITHER.
>> HE WAS SO FOCUSED ON THE
FEED.
>> OH, NO.
>> MAYBE HE'LL MISS THE KICK
RIGHT.
WELL, NEVER MIND.
I'M SORRY.
>> OH, NO.
OH, NO.
>> THAT SUCKS, MAN.
>> HAVE WE DEEMED IT
MATHEMATICALLY IMPOSSIBLE?
>> GOT TO BE OVER TWO.
>> BUT THE NINERS KICKING A
FIELD GOAL, DOES THAT DO
ANYTHING?
>> THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE TIME
FOR THAT.
>> I MEAN, LIKE --
>> THE ONLY CHANCE WOULD BE A
TOUCHDOWN AND 10 --
>> WAIT, NO, IT DOES.
>> I NEED --
>> IT IS.
>> I NEED A TURNOVER.
A TURNOVER IMMEDIATELY OFF THE
20 YARD LINE.
>> FOUR AND OUT AT THE 25 OR
TURNOVER, YOU HAVE A CHANCE.
>> SHOUT-OUT DANIEL.
FRIENDS LEGEND.
>> IS HE IN THE CHAT?
>> LOOK AT ALL THESE LEGENDS IN
ONE ROOM.
>> HEY!
>> GOOD TO HEAR FROM OUR GUY.
>> WE'RE GOING TO GET SOME GUYS
IN THE CHAT IN A SECOND.
ALERT IS OUT.
I AGREE, I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT.
TALKING TO MAX, SORRY, SORRY
ABOUT THAT.
>> NO, I AGREE.
>> FUMBLE.
LIGHT 'EM UP.
RUSSKIE!
>> WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THAT,
SAM?
>> GENO, EIGHT YARDS, GENO.
>> RUSSKIE!
>> EIGHT YARDS.
>> ALL RIGHT, BRI.
WE SENT AN ALETTER OUT,
EVERYONE'S COMING TO WATCH YOU
SWEAT THIS.
>> ON TWITTER, HOP IN HERE,
WATCH THIS.
>> GOOD LUCK, BRI.
>> DO YOU WANT TO STAND BACK
THERE?
>> YES.
>> WHATEVER YOU WANT.
>> I NEED ROOM, I NEED ROOM.
>> MAKE SURE CAMERON --
>> NO, NO, I NEED ROOM, BRO.
>> THIS IS A LOT OF ROOM.
>> I'M TOO HUNG OVER TO BE
SITTING DOWN FOR THIS.
I APOLOGIZE FOR THE CASAMIGOS
SHOT.
>> BACKING THE BALL WAY UP --
>> NO, THAT'S GOOD.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO PISS ME OFF,
A SAT PUNT.
>> A SAD PUNT?
>> THEY WOULD GO FOR IT.
THE QUESTION IS --
>> IF YOU GOT THE STOP, WOULD
SAN FRANCISCO STILL KICK A
KILOGRAM?
>> I DON'T THINK THEY WOULD.
>> WHY?
>> I THINK THEY'RE DEFINITELY
GOING TO GO FOR IT.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO DO A SAD
PUNT.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT IN A PLAYOFF
GAME.
>> NO.
>> MY ENTIRE-IS OVER.
>> COME ON.
>> PICK SIX.
>> PICK SIX, PICK SIX.
>> THERE'S TYLER LOCKETT.
>> HE'S OUT, HE'S OUT.
>> A LITTLE BOBBLE, BOBBLE.
>> ALL RIGHT, GENO.
I NEED THREE MORE YARDS.
>> YOU'RE GOOD.
>> FOR A PARLEY?
>> FOR A PARLAY.
>> WHAT'S THE JUICE?
>> 25 TO WIN.
IT'S MAKING ME LOG BACK IN, ONE
SEC.
>> KEEP ALL THAT CASH RIGHT
HERE.
>> GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE
CHAT -- WE NEED GENO.
>> CHAT.
>> WOW, WOW, WOW.
>> LET US KNOW WHAT YOU THINK OF
BRYSON'S BET IN GENERAL.
LET US KNOW WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT
IT CASHING.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HERE NOW.
>> WOULD YOU EVER BET $1,000 ON
THE GAME TOTAL?
ANY GAME IS THE BETTER QUESTION
$1,000 ON ANY WET?
>> WE NEED A PICK SIX.
>> EWE TALKING ABOUT GETTING
RELATIONSHIP AND YOU DON'T WANT
TO BET $1,000 ON A BET?
>> IF I BET A PARLAY THAT'S 10-1
AND PUT $1 ON IT --
>> DETROIT BOY WANTS TO KNOW
WHAT HE FEEDS.
>> THE PICK SIX.
>> YEAH, HE NEEDS THE TOTAL TO
BE HIGH.
>> I NEED A PICK --
>> ALSO, DETROIT -- SHOUT-OUT
LIONS.
DAN CAMPBELL, PUSH OF THE YEAR.
WHY ARE WE RUNNING THE BALL?
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
>> YEAH.
>> JUST TRYING TO GET OUT, NOT
GET HURT BEFORE THEY GO TO
CANCUN?
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> NOW I KNOW THE SADDEST P.A.T.
EVER.
>> JONES THE JEWELER, 49ers GOT
ME TO DAY SIX OF THE CHALLENGE.
>> DETROIT BOY, I WOULD CASH OUT
IF I WAS BRYSON, NOT A OPTION.
BUT GOOD TAKE, GOT TAKE, NOT AN
OPTION, THOUGH.
>> I NEED -- LIKE I STILL --
LIKE THEY'VE GOT TO GO FOR TWO.
BUT I THINK THERE'S THIS SLIVER
OF HOP --
>> THAT THEY GO --
>> THAT PETE CARROLL'S NOT SMART
ENOUGH TO REALIZE THE SITUATION.
>> AH.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU THINK THAT EXISTS?
>> I DON'T SEE ANY CHANCE IT
HAPPENS BUT --
>> YEAH, YOU NEED A PICK SIX OR
THAT.
YEAH.
>> THERE IS NO -- YEAH, NO
SITUATION, REALLY.
THIS GAME'S OVER.
>> OH MY GOSH.
>> THAT'S NOT GOOD EITHER.
I NEED THE SEAHAWKS TO SCORE
NOW.
I NEED IT.
>> TYLER LOCKETTE REALLY DECIDED
TO PUT UP A STINKER TODAY.
>> NO, BECAUSE IF THEY TURN OVER
ON DOWNS, NINERS, THEY'LL RUN
IT.
BUT YOU CAN BREAK ONE.
IT'S NOT INSANE TO BREAK ONE.
>> THE DETROIT BOY SAYING THE
LIONS --
>> AGREED, DRIT BOY.
>> THEY WOULD HAVE GONE AND
SHREDDED, REALISTICALLY.
>> YOU'VE GOT TIME, GENO.
>> STRIP SACK.
>> YOU'VE GOT TIME, BRO.
>> THICK -- COME ON, IS THAT NOT
HOLDING BACK THERE?
>> INTERCEPTION WRITTEN ALL OVER
IT.
>> DK37, PETE CARROLL IS
DEFINITELY A QUESTIONABLE
DECISIONMAKER.
>> THANKS, BK.
>> YEAH, WE GOT JACK TRYING TO
SWEAT THIS SAME GAME PARLAY WITH
US.
HE'S UPSET ABOUT TYLER LOCKETT.
>> HOW MANY LEGS DID WE END UP
HITTING?
TWO OF 5?
>> NINERS MINUS 2 1/2, AIYUK,
GENO SMITH.
>> DID WE HIT GENO?
>> HE'S AT 27, 28.
29.
>> STOP THERE.
>> OH MY GOD, THAT WAS CLOSE.
>> GOING TO GIVE TO IT HIM.
>> SO LOCKETT MIGHT STILL HIT --
REALLY, IT COULD FALL JUST
McCAFFREY SHORT -- THAT SUCKS.
>> WHICH WAS THE LAST THING WE
TALKED ABOUT.
>> WE HAD RUSHING YARDS FIRST.
>> WE DID.
>> I CAN FEEL IT IN MY BONES,
PETE CARROLL NOT GOING FOR TWO.
YOU SCORE IN THE MIDDLE THIS
GAME IS SO OVER.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO BELIEVE.
OH, NO, IT'S NOT D.K.
THAT'S TOUGH, THAT'S TOUGH.
>> OH MY GOD.
SEAN BIGMAN, Y'ALL DOING
ANYTHING FOR THE NEXT GAME?
PROBABLY CRYING.
>> PROBABLY CRYING.
>> FOR THE CHAT, LET'S GO
OVER -- A LOT OF US ARE ON THE
CHARGERS.
>> WE DO LIKE THE CHARGERS.
>> IS ANYONE HERE ON
JACKSONVILLE?
>> NO.
>> WE ARE ON THE CHARGERS.
>> WE ARE --
>> IT'S ALMOST SCARY.
>> WE'RE A JUSTIN HERBERT FAMILY
HERE.
>> COME ON.
>> WHO'S ON THE FIELD FOR THE
SEAHAWKS?
>> DEFINITELY D.K.
>> YOU THINK SO?
BECAUSE I DIDN'T SEE HIM.
>> BRYCE --
>> NOT ON THE FIELD.
>> HE'S GOT TO BE HURT.
>> OH MY GOD.
AT 30.
GENO, CATCH IT.
>> FOURTH AND 17 --
>> NO, THEY'RE NOT KICKING --
>> OH MY GOD, OH MY GOD.
>> TOO TIGHT FOR THIS.
>> THAT WOULD BE THE SADDEST
FIELD GOAL IN THE HISTORY OF
SPORTS.
>> THEY GET, LIKE --
>> IF YOU'RE JUST JOINING US
RIGHT NOW --
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN, RYAN?
>> I NEED D.K. TO SCORE.
>> THE SADDEST FIELD GOAL IN
HISTORY.
>> D.K. TO SCORE, HE'S IN THE
GAME.
>> IT'S FOR THE GAME TOTAL TO
END HIGH.
>> HE'S IN THE GAME.
>> WE HAVE SOMEBODY --
>> NO, NO.
>> YOU'RE NOT TELLING ME HE'S IN
THE GAME?
THAT'S NOT HIM, HE RUNS 14.
>> THAT'S NOT ANYMORE?
>> IT'S NOT HIM.
>> I LOOKS LIKE HIM, I HOPE HE
SCORES.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> LOCKETT OVER 45?
>> NO -- IT'S.
>> TRAE YOUNG WANTS TO KNOW MY
COLLEGE BASKETBALL PICK OF THE
NIGHT.
I'M NOT BETTING COLLEGE
BASKETBALL TONIGHT.
>> EVERYONE, FOR BRYSON, COME
ON.
>> YEAH, NOTHING ELSE MATTERS.
>> CHAT, PLEASE ROOT FOR BRYSON.
>> BRYSON TO CHAT.
>> EXTRA POINT.
>> HE'S IN.
>> HE'S GOT TO GET DOUBLE.
IT'S OVER.
>> TOUCHDOWN, EXTRA POINT.
>> DOESN'T MATTER.
>> THAT'S NOT -- DUDE --
>> KICK THE FIELD GOAL.
>> OH, THERE HAPPENED.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE FIELD GOAL?
FIELD GOAL'S GOOD.
>> KICK THE FIELD GOAL.
>> THERE'S NO WAY.
>> ONSIDE KICK?
>> KICK THE FIELD GOAL.
>> MAYBE.
>> KICK THE FIELD GOAL?
>> TWO-MINUTE WARNING HERE.
>> TAKE THE FIELD GOAL.
>> OH MY GOD, DUDE, OH MY GOD.
>> THIS IS HYSTERICAL.
>> GO THE RIGHT THING.
>> KICK THE FIELD GOAL.
>> FOR ONCE IN YOUR LIFE.
>> KICK THE FIELD GOAL, PETE.
>> YOU'RE KNOWN AS MAKING GREAT
DECISIONS.
MAKE ONE LAST ONE.
>> THE GAME'S OVER.
>> THE GAME'S OVER, KICK THE
FIELD GOAL, TAKE THE POINTS.
>> BRYSON, I'M TAKING A STROLL
FOR YOU.
>> OUT OF FRAME STROLL FOR
MASON.
>> OH, GOD.
>> FOR BRYSON.
>> WELL.
BRYSON JUST -- WHAT'S GOING
THROUGH YOUR MIND RIGHT NOW?
>> NOT MUCH, MAN.
HONEST HOPE -- THIS IS THE SAME
COACH THAT THREW THE BALL WITH
RUSSELL STINKSON ON THE 2 YARD
LINE INSTEAD OF HANDING THE BALL
TO MARSHAWN LUNCH.
>> SO YOU'RE SAYING HE MIGHT
CALL A SAD FIELD GOAL?
>> THERE'S A CHANCE FOR A FIELD
GOAL, THEY'D GO FOR THIS GENO
FUMBLE BACKWARDS.
>> THAT'S A GREAT POINT.
>> I WATCHED THE RAIDERS SHUCK
THE BALL BACKWARDS 20 YARDS TO
THE OTHER TEAM -- ANYTHING CAN
HAPPEN.
THAT SAID, I LOST.
>> THIS WOULD GET THE GAME TO
21, RIGHT?
>> WE'RE MISSING A B.K.
COMMERCIAL, THAT'S BAD VIBES.
>> NO VOLUME.
♪ WHOPPER HAPPY ♪
>> WHOPPER WHOPPER WHOPPER
WHOPPER.
>> DO WE HAVE ANY KICKERS OUT
THERE, BRO?
I LOVE THEM ALL DOWN.
I'M GOING TO HAVE A HEART
ATTACK.
THAT'S GOING TO END ME.
THEY'RE GOING TO RUN A FAKE
FIELD GOAL, AND THAT'S GOING TO
BE THE END.
♪ WHOPPER WHOPPER WHOPPER
WHOPPER ♪
♪ BRYSON'S ABOUT TO WIN HIS ♪
>> THREE OUTCOMES.
PICK SIX, FIELD GOAL CUNIT COME
OUT, OR TOUCHDOWN --
>> COMMERCIAL BREAK.
COMMERCIAL BREAK.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE AFTER THIS
ONE.
>> DEFINITELY AFTER THIS.
>> HERE WE GO.
>> CALL 911.
>> READY, READY --
>> DEFINITELY AFTER THIS.
OH MY GOD.
>> THESE ARE NETWORK
COMMERCIALS.
>> MENTALLY PREPARE FOR THE
WORST.
>> WHO CARES ABOUT NASCAR?
GET THIS OFF THE TELEVISION.
>> HERE WE GO.
>> JESUS, JESUS.
>> OH MY GOD, OKAY.
>> THEY'RE PLAYING WITH YOU,
BRYSON.
>> HERE WE GO.
>> COME ON, NFL, GET THE GAME
BACK ON.
>> COME ON, FLAG FOOTBALL RIGHT
NOW, THIS IS A JOKE.
>> HERE WE GO.
>> FIELD GOAL UNIT.
FIELD GOAL UNIT.
>> FIELD GOAL, FIELD GOAL, FIELD
GOAL, FIELD GOAL.
>> OH!
>> ONE MORE TIME.
♪ HAPPY BK ♪
>> HERE WE GO.
♪ WHOPPER WHOPPER WHOPPER
WHOPPER ♪
>> THIS IS A JOKE?
>> THIS IS INSANE.
>> HE'S BEEN BALLING TODAY.
>> FIELD GOAL, FIELD GOAL.
>> SORRY, BRI.
>>SOME.
>> ONE TIME FOR BRYSON HERE.
>> I THOUGHT THAT WAS -- OH MY
GOD.
>> TOUCHDOWN, EXTRA POINT, PICK
SIX.
>> THERE'S NO WAY.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE SOMETHING
DICED UP HERE.
>>> THERE'S NO WAY --
>> MAYBE THE HOUSE DOWN.
>> SORRY.
>> OH!
>> OH MY GOD.
>> HEAR ME OUT.
>> THEY SCORE A TOUCHDOWN HIKE A
MINUTE AND A HALF -- DON'T GET
ME WRONG.
THE GAME IS SO OVER.
I CAN SEE --
>> NO, THE GAME --
>> LET KEEP THE OFFENSE ON THE
FIELD.
>> I AGREE.
>> I KNOW.
>> THAT'S WHY WE SHOULD GO --
>> THAT'S MY HOPE.
THAT'S MY HOPE.
THIS IS MY TOXIC TRAIT AS A
BETTOR.
I'M A PESSIMIST.
AT THE SAME TIME, I BELIEVE IN
TRUE LOVE.
HOPELESS ROMANTIC.
BELIEVING HERE, MAN.
>> PICK SIX.
>> THAT WAS CHUMPING.
>> I THOUGHT HE WAS CHURCHING TO
BE HONEST.
>> THIS IS ABSURD.
>> ALL RIGHT, I NEED TO DRINK
SOME WATER.
>> YEP.
>> WHY NOT RUN THE BALL?
>> I'M SO UNWELL RIGHT NOW.
>> YEAH, RUN THE BALL THE WHOLE
GAME.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> RYAN, WHAT'S THE CHAT SAYING?
>> IF YOU GET STOPPED --
>> ANGEL C. SAYS, WHOPPER
WHOPPER.
>> YEAH, IT'S GOOD.
>> THIS REALLY HAPPENED.
>> THEY KICK A FIELD GOAL, DOWN
BY TOO MUCH TO DO ANY OF THAT --
>> D.K., D.K.!
>> THEY'RE SAYING -- WALK OFF.
>> WALK OFF.
>> HOLD ON.
>> KICK THIS FIELD GOAL.
>> WALK OFF.
>> THEY MIGHT -- NO.
>> THEY'RE SAYING --
>> WALK OFF.
>> NO.
>> THIS RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
>> I TOLD YOU HE WAS IN.
>> GREAT HEDGE BY YOU.
>> YEAH, WORKED OUT.
>> TOLD YOU IT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THERE'S NO ADMIT GROUND.
>> ONSIDE COMING.
>> WE'RE BACK INTO, LIKE, THE
LESS THAN 1% CHANCE.
BUT --
>> ONSIDE.
>> THE SHORT ONSIDE KICK, WE GO
THREE AND OUT, THEN THEY WOULD
MAYBE KICK A -- THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO KICK IT BUT A 50-YARD
FIELD GOAL OR SOMETHING.
OR A BREAK, A TOUCHDOWN.
BUT THE SEAHAWKS PROBABLY ARE
GOING TO CALL TIME-OUT.
>> YEAH.
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW JUSTIN
JEFFERSON DIDN'T GET 2,000 YARDS
RECEIVING THIS YEAR.
HE WAS BALLING.
>> YEAH.
>> HE HAD THAT 20-YARD GAME,
YEAH.
>> DIDN'T MATTER.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> THEY DIDN'T PLAY HIM.
>> THEY'RE GETTING A DELAY OF
GAME?
BACK HIM UP.
>> I WONDER IF THEY'LL EVER --
YEAH, A PLAYOFF GAME, HE WAS ON
ONSIDE ANYWAY.
>> IT WAS ALWAYS EVEN, BRO.
>> HAVE TO GO FIND THAT WAITER.
>> YEAH.
>> BROCK PURDY IS THE TRUTH.
>> HOUSE, HOW, HOUSE.
>> ANY CHANCE THEY GAIN A COUPLE
OF YARDS AND KICK A FIELD GOAL?
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
I MEAN, NO.
BUT --
>> THEN DO IT AGAIN?
>> WHAT IF THE SEAHAWKS --
>> NO WAY, NO.
>> GAME.
>> >> IS THERE, LIKE, ANY
KICKING RECORD ROBBIE GOULD
COULD HIT HERE?
>> I THINK HE HAS THE MOST
POINTS IN THE POSTSEASON.
>> THAT'S THE ONLY HOPE, YOU'VE
GOT TO --
>> YOU'RE SAYING -- IS THERE ANY
CHANCE -- SEVEN YARDS?
IT'S LIKE A 52-YARDER.
ROBBIE, GO KICK IT?
>> I MEAN, .01, YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEAN?
YOU KNOW.
>> VERY HESITANT.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE BRUTAL.
>> FACE SON'S REDEMPTION, BRO.
>> GO.
HOUSE, HOUSE, HOUSE!
OH -- TIME-OUT, TIME-OUT,
TIME-OUT, TIME-OUT.
>> THEY'RE NOT CALLING --
>> THAT'S THE GAME.
>> WE GOT ONE MORE PLAY.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> WE GOT ONE MORE --
POTENTIALLY ONE MORE PLAY, THEN
IT'S A KNEEL.
YOU GOT ONE --
>> THE THING ABOUT JORDAN MASON,
HE CAN HOUSE SOMETHING.
>> ISN'T HE THE ONE THAT GOT
TACKLED AT THE 5 YARD LINE?
THAT HAPPENS, I WILL HAVE A
HEART ATTACK RIGHT HERE.
I'M SO SERIOUS.
ON LIVESTREAM.
THEY'RE KNEELING, RIGHT?
>> PROBABLY.
>> WHY ARE YOU SHOWING US THE
PLAYERS?
>> SORRY, BRY.
>> OH MY GOD, ONE PLAY, ONE
PLAY.
>> BREAK ONE.
>> I'M SORRY.
>> YOU GAVE IT A GREAT RUN.
>> IT IS WHAT IT IS.
IT IS WHAT IT IS.
>> GET IT BACK NEXT GAME.
>> HONORED TO BE A PART OF THIS.
>> POVERTY, MAN.
>> NINERS TEAM TOTAL UNDER, GOOD
CALL, DUDE.
>> HEY.
>> NOT THAT YOU'RE AN I TOLD YOU
SO GUY.
>> WAIT, DIDN'T SOMEBODY TAKE
THE 49ers TEAM TOTAL UNDER?
>> YEAH, THEY DID.
>> I THINK IT WAS THAT GUY.
>> HOW'S IT, BROCK?
>> ALL RIGHT.
WELL.
>> DO WE WANT TO SHOW THE
FINAL -- WELL, NOT FINAL.
DO WE WANT TO SHOW THE
SPREADSHEET?
>> WHO DID THE BEST?
>> MIGHT HAVE BEEN ME.
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU BUT
SEEMS LIKE GREG HAD THE -- MONEY
LIKE JUST CASHED.
MINUS 460, CONGRATS.
>> VERY VALUABLE.
>> AWESOME BET.
>> I THINK THE ONLY THING I
MISSED --
>> BOSA -- DID BOSA GO SACK?
>> NO.
>> HE DID NOT.
GREG FINISHED 3-2.
YOU KNOW, I FINISHED 1-2.
BUT YOU KNOW --
>> BUT THOSE TWO DON'T COUNT.
>> NO, NO.
IT'S JUST --
>> I HAD MINUS 1 --
>> MY BEST HIT, THAT COUNTS FOR
TWO.
THEN I HIT A 9-1 LIVE BET.
>> THE LOSERS CUT IT IN HALF.
>> YOU'RE FINALLY GETTING IT.
>> IT WAS ALL AT THE BOTTOM.
>> VINCE WENT 0 FOR 3.
IT'S TOUGH.
IT'S LIKE LAST TIME.
RITTER WENT ONE FOR KITTLE.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
I HIT THE McCAFFREY BOOST AND
THE D.K. LINE.
>> D.K. LINE, D.K. LINE.
>> McCAFFREY BOOST IS --
>> WE ALL WON ON McCAFFREY.
>> DRAFT KINGS GAVE ME A $10
FREE BET BACK.
>> HEY!
>> THERE IT IS.
>> SHOUT-OUT DRAFT KINGS.
WE'RE BUILDING AN EMPIRE.
>> LOGAN WENT --
>> I THINK KITTLE MISSED HIS
OVER 3 1/2 RECEPTIONS.
>> YEAH.
>> YEAH, HE DID NOT.
>> HE HAD TWO.
>> GENO WENT --
>> GENO WENT OVER.
>> SO 3-2?
>> DID THE GENO IN THE PARLAY
HIT?
>> YES.
>> WE LOST ON LOCKETT AND --
>> HOW CLOSE ON LOCKETT?
>> SIX YARDS AWAY.
>> THAT'S ACCURACY.
THAT'S CRAZY.
>> WE NEVER -- HE ONLY HAD TWO.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> SO -- THAT WAS --
>> LET'S GO.
>> VERY TOUGH.
>> THAT'S TOUGH.
>> WE SAW IT.
>> AGAIN, THE BEST BETS ARE 8-2,
HOW TOUGH IS IT REALLY?
>> THE PARLAY --
>> NINERS SUPER BOWL.
>> THE SHOW LIVE AND STILL
ALIVE, HEY!
BANG BANG NINER GANG!
>> THAT IS SO GOOD.
>> LET'S GO!
>> THE VIBES HAVE BEEN RESTORED.
>> THAT WAS THE BEST PART OF THE
GAME.
>> THAT WAS THE ILLUMINATI
MOMENT WAS HIM THROWING THAT
BACK.
>> I TOLD YOU.
LET'S GET UP OUT OF HERE.
WE GOT ANOTHER GAME TO GO TO.
>> THANK YOU FOR WATCHING,
EVERYONE.
>> THANKS FOR TUNING IN, YOU
KNOW.
>> CHARGERS MONEY LINE.
>> COWBOYS MONEYING LINE.
>> FOR THE BR BETTING CREW, WE
ARE OUT OF HERE.
PEACE!
GO NINERS!